hi everyone I'm M and welcome to this
fantastic video in Java fundamentals for
beginners by simply learn but before we
begin if you love watching these videos
and find them interesting subscribe to
our Channel as we bring you the best
videos daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
and now let's go through the agenda for
this video real quick we'll brief you
with a detail introduction what is Java
after that we'll see the Java developer
skills and salary followed by the jdk
tutorial and we'll walk you through some
fantastic Concepts like Loops in Java
erors in Java and many more Concepts
after that you'll see some oops concept
like polymorphism encapsulation Etc
finally we will cover some essential top
10 best java projects you can mention in
your CV to make it stand out from the
crowd in your upcoming interviews and
speaking of interviews we have covered
you along with the most frequently ask
Java interview questions to help you
crack the most challenging interviews
but before we begin to understand what
Java is software development is a
rapidly changing field and software
developers need to stay up to date on
the latest advancements regarding the
tools Frameworks programming languages
and apps to achieve success Master the
latest coding tools strategies and
techniques through simply learn software
development coures by enrolling in any
of these certification programs you will
gain expertise in skills like agile Java
devops HTML 5 CSS 3 AWS JavaScript es6
soap and rest and GSP with hands-on
experience in tools like angula mongod
TV you will catch TI of top recruiters
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses you
can find the course Link in the
description box below and pin comment
and with that in mind over to our
training experts in today's era the
internet and smartphones have become an
integral part of our Lives we use our
phones for almost all of our day-to-day
tasks earlier we used to shop at malls
queue up in front of Banks and make our
travel bookings at travel agencies but
now we can do all this in the comfort of
our homes using smartphones all of this
is possible because of a high level
programming language called Java hi guys
welcome to this video that will tell you
everything you need to know about the
class-based object-oriented programming
language Java Java is an object-oriented
programming language anguage that is
used in a distributed environment on the
internet it is a high level language
that is easy to read and understand Java
is popularly used in console graphical
user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded systems apart from
these Java is also used to develop
software for devices it is used not only
in computers and mobiles but even in
electronic devices like televisions
washing machines air conditioners and so
on online forms Banking and shopping are
possible because of java Java is a
computer-based programming language
invented by James Gosling and Sun
Microsystems in
1991 he had a single Moto while creating
the language it was right once run
anywhere this meant that the code would
have to be written only once but it
could be used anywhere they named this
language Oak because of the oak tree
outside Gosling's Office later it was
named to Green then to Java Coffee which
was named after the coffee from
Indonesia and finally to Java in
1995 there are three editions of java
each programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have Java
standard edition this Edition contains
core libraries like java.lang java. Etc
secondly we have Java Enterprise Edition
this Edition has API like JMS ejb JSP
servlets Etc and lastly we have Java
micro Edition which is used to program
Java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on Java is an
objectoriented programming language
based on C and C++ however it is
improved and simplified to solve the
errors in programming Java files are
converted to bit code format using a
compiler and then executed by the Java
interpreter the whole Java code is run
on the Java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main Concepts in Java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching TV you use the TV remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in Java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class classes are used
to organize code just like how fruits
vegetables and clinical products are
divided divided into different sections
in a supermarket there are a lot of
features in Java let's start by looking
at them one by one it has a simple
syntax and is very easy to understand
and learn Java language is robust it
eliminates errors that occur in the CA
and C++ languages Java also has features
like garbage collectors and exception
handling this makes Java very unique the
most popular feature of java is that it
is platform independent here compilation
happens in bite code and because of this
Java can run on any machine it is a very
secure language as it contains no virus
Java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
Java do multitasking Java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so Java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all Java is not as fast
as C and C++ but provides higher
performance than any other other
language now let's see oops Concepts in
Java Java has four Concepts abstraction
encapsulation inheritance and
polymorphism in Java we use objects and
classes related to the real world that
makes the code easier to make and
understand abstraction means showing the
relevant information that is needed for
a task encapsulation makes the Java code
secure data is stored within the classes
and it is not easy to access the data
the next feature is inheritance as the
name suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in Java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ our
first question who is a Java
developer
so Java developer basically is a
professional computer software developer
who uses Java programming language to
build the
software now Java developer mainly uses
Java to build software for desktops
mobile phones and also develop software
for similar electronic devices such as a
smartphone tablet Etc now to become a
Java developer we need to have at least
a bachelor's degree in relevance stream
preferably computer science later you
might want to join an internship or a
training exercise that involves a
project or some highly recognized
certification like Oracle certified Java
developer then your dream job in your
dream company so this was a simple
walkth through or road map to become a
Java developer now moving ahead we have
our main topic for today's discussion
that is the skills required to become a
Java
developer now we shall categorize this
into two stages one is the beginner and
the other is a professional we shall
discuss each one of them separately so
first we will start with a beginner so
these will be the basic skills that any
interviewer will be expecting out from a
pure beginner so in the beginner section
the first skill that we will be
discussing is related to the
object-oriented programming Concepts in
Java so for a beginner the concepts of
objectoriented programming in Java play
a very important and vital role for an
interview so he or she should be having
a strong rip over the objectoriented
programming Concepts in Java so followed
by object-oriented programming Concepts
in Java we have the next important
Concept in Java which is the file input
and output operations and
serialization so serialization is
another way of executing your code from
a different place for example if you
write a code and you wanted to execute
the same code in a different place in a
different computer all you can do is is
just serialize your code to that
particular system and there the same
code will be executed so followed by the
second point the third important skill
we need to have is the good
understanding of data structures in Java
data structures or Java Collections are
the most crucial parts of programming so
for a beginner it's really important
that you have a good grip over all the
Java Collections so followed by that the
next important skill you require is to
learn how to handle exceptions
so exception handling plays a vital role
in real-time programming so you better
have that next after exception handling
we have the good understanding of jvm
and memory
management so jvm basically is the Java
virtual machine so what happens in Java
is you write a code and that particular
code is compiled and converted into bite
code so this bite code will be
transferred to jvm and then jvm executes
your bite code and re results in an
output so you need to have the good
understanding of jvm and the memory
management Concepts in Java for a
beginner level so followed by that the
next important thing is multi-threading
and synchronization in Java so all those
were the basic and important crucial
skills required by a beginner if you're
attending for an interview because these
are the basic skills that every
interviewer will be looking out in a
beginner so let's have a quick overview
of the skill set again so for for a
beginner level the major skill sets that
you require are to have a good
understanding of objectoriented Concepts
in Java next the file input and
operations and serialization Concepts in
Java good understanding of data
structures or collections in Java
exception handling jvm or Java virtual
machine and memory management and
finally multi-threading and
synchronization so these are the major
skills that are required by a beginner
now now followed by the skill set we
will have another slide that depicts
about the IDS that you must be
comfortable with so for a beginner these
are the basic Ides that you should be
comfortable with which are intellig
eclipse and net beans and also these are
the mainly used IDs in realtime
programming as well so if you are
comfortable with these three IDE e then
it will be an added way to your resuming
so followed by the beginner we enter
into the next level which is the
experience level so this is really
important so we have multiple skills
required by an experience level
candidate so the first one amongst the
important skills required by an
experience level candidate are a good
knowledge of big data and artificial
intelligence Yes you heard me right
artificial intelligence there is a major
misconception that R and python are the
only languages that are built for
artificial intelligence and data science
but in reality even Java can perform the
artificial intelligence data science and
machine learning jobs using the new
libraries which are dedicatedly written
for the purpose now for an advanced or
experien level candidate the knowledge
of these libraries and the workflow is
really important so followed by that the
next important skill required by an
experience level candidate is a good
understanding of blockchain next after
the blockchain there are multiple Big
Data Frameworks out there which you need
to
learn
next after that we have microservices
spring Boot and scripting languages such
as angularjs reactjs and JavaScript so
let's have a quick overview of the skill
set required by an experience level
candidate so those are Ai and ml
libraries in Java good understanding of
blockchain Haro and Big Data Frameworks
spring Boot microservices and finally
Advanced scripting programming languages
like angularjs JavaScript and react GS
now these skill sets might look big
complex complicated and hard to digest
but Java developers are categorized into
multiple streams of development just for
example we can see Java developers
working over web development Android
development full stack big data machine
learning artificial intelligence and
many more now let us consider three most
popular streams where we find Java
developers which are the web development
areas and Android development areas and
finally the full stack development areas
so first we will discuss the skill set
required by a web
developer so for a web developer these
are the major skill sets required which
are the good knowledge of java seret
Pages or JSP popular markup languages
such as XML HTML and next after that we
have model view controller so once
should have a good understanding of
model view controller or MVC
architecture followed by that we have
good knowledge of web Technologies like
CSS and JavaScript and finally Java
applets so the important Frameworks for
a web developer to be well vered with
are Apache struts play Google web
toolkit and finally GRS so these are the
popular Frameworks that are currently in
Trend and used by Java web developers so
followed by the web developer next we
have is the Android developer so an
Android developer is a software
developer who specializes in designing
applications for Android Marketplace the
Android Marketplace is a direct
competitor to Apple's App Store this
means most of the Android developers job
revolves around creating apps that we
use on our smartphones and tablets now
the skill sets required by Android
developer are good grip over the Android
SDK or software development kit next the
Android testing followed by that a
better understanding of Android API and
database database connectors like jdbc
and Android security and finally get
Version Control now get Version Control
will be really helpful to keep your code
updated now followed by the skills
required by an Android developer we will
go through some important Frameworks and
user interface development software
tools required by an Android developer
in real time first let us discuss the
user interface development tools like
flat and react s which are the most
popular ones amongst the others so
reactjs is an open- Source front-end
JavaScript library for building user
interfaces or UI components it is
maintained by Facebook and a community
of individual developers and companies
react can be used as a base in the
development of single page or mobile
applications so next after reactjs we
have the flutter flutter is an open
source user interface software
development kit created by Google it is
used to develop as applications for
Android iOS Linux Mac Windows Google and
many more from a single code
base so next we have the solar 2D Sola
2D is a free and open- Source
crossplatform software development kit
and then we have the Android Studio that
is another popular development kit just
for Android now next in the docket is
the Java full stack developer a full
stack web developer is a person who can
develop both client and server software
in addition to mastering HTML and CSS he
or she also knows how to program a
browser like using JavaScript jQuery
angular and view so now the major skill
sets required by a fullstack developer
are having a good understanding of
software design and architecture
understanding of devops knowledge of
microservices apis and libraries design
patterns in Java react and angular
scripting languages and finally should
be capable to work on front end and back
end so these were the major skills
required by a full stack developer so
followed by this we shall also discuss
the major Frameworks required by a
fullstack
developer so these are the major tools
Frameworks and scripting languages that
are supposed to be known by a fullstack
developer we have the integration tools
such as genin and devops related tools
like cubits and Docker and scripting
languages like and react and Frameworks
like spring and testing tools like
junit so with this we will move ahead
into our next important topic that is
the roles and responsibilities of a Java
developer so first we will discuss the
roles and responsibilities of a Java
developer at beginner level so the
important roles and responsibilities for
a beginner are to be able to define the
objectives by analyzing the requirements
of the clients followed by that to be
capable enough to complete the assigned
job before the deadlines design and test
basic codes resolve the reported issues
in time and troubleshoot the code
improvise the existing code quality and
finally support the user with proper
documentation of the code so these were
the important responsibilities of a Java
developer at beginner level now let us
advance to the next level where we will
discuss the roles and responsibilities
of experience level
candidates so the roles and
responsibilities of an advanced level or
experienced level candidate are all the
basic responsibilities of a beginner so
followed by the basic responsibilities
an advanced level Java programmer should
be having a thorough knowledge of system
functionality and features followed by
that the experience level Java
programmer should be able to design and
develop user interface enhance the
reputation of the company recommend
updates based on the performance ensure
the best possible responsiveness and
finally explore and add value to the
achievements of fellow
co-workers so these were the important
roles and responsibilities of a Java
developer both at beginner level and
experienced level now let us check out
the companies which are looking for Java
developers there are many companies that
are looking for Java developers in the
current IT industry some of the major
mnc's looking out for Java developers in
the current IT industry are cognizant in
for
Oracle Cap Gemini Dell Amazon weo
emphasis and Accenture now that we have
discussed the company's hiring Java
developers let us take a step further
and discuss the salary trends of the
Java developers in the current it
Industries now let us discuss the salary
tends of Java developers in India first
so the salary trends for a Java
developer who is going through the the
beginner level or an internship level
start from 2 lakh to 4 lakh rupees perom
similarly for an experience level Java
developer the salary Trends start from 5
lakh and go up to 10 lakhs and above
based on your experience level and skill
set now let us go ahead and discuss the
next country which is the United States
of America so for a Java developer at
beginner level America offers $55,000 to
$80,000 per anom so similarly for an
experience level candidate America
offers $885,000 us to 1 lak 25,000 US
perom based on the experience and skill
set now finally we have the United
Kingdom the United Kingdom offers 45,000
to 60,000 for a Java developer at a
beginner level and similarly for an
experience level Java developer United
Kingdom offers £65,000 to £85,000 per
anom so these were the salary trends of
java developers in multiple countries so
if you wish to join the right training
exercise that covers the complete skill
set according to the standards of top
mnc's created and explained in a
detailed manner by real-time industry
experts then simply learn would be the
right choice if you visit the simply
learn official website for Java related
training then you can find the simply
learn has beautifully organized all the
major topics of java in a result
oriented manner that will be helpful for
both beginners and
professionals
so the key features of java training
offered by simply learn will have 70
hours of Blended training Hands-On
coding and implementation of Two web
based projects it also includes
hibernate and spring Frameworks 35
coding related exercises on code Java
and lifetime access of self-based
training and finally the flexibility to
choose your own classes so the benefits
of java certification training offered
by simply learn will have the following
you can achieve your designation of
becoming a Java architect Java developer
database administrator or web developer
with the certification from Simply learn
on Java so the average salaries for a
Java developer with certification will
be varying from 16 lakhs as minimum and
will also reach up to the maximum of 27
lakhs perom the Java certification from
Simply learn has been recognized by
multiple multinational companies and
some of the major MNC companies that are
hiring Java developers with the
certification of java are vs fago Oracle
Accenture City Bank and many more now we
have the three varieties of training
options which are self-based learning
online boot camp and corporate training
so what is Java it is a fast reliable
and secure programming language that can
be used in several websites and
applications it can be used to create
applications in a single computer or one
that could be distributed across several
servers and clients Java can be used in
several scenarios independent of the
system that it is used on so let's look
into what Java development kit
means all the Java applications and
applets are developed using the Java
development kit that is jdk now the jdk
consists of the Java runtime environment
an interpreter a compiler an archiver
and a do document generator and a few
more tools that go into developing a
Java program so now let us have a look
at the components of jdk java runtime
environment JRE primarily is a part of
jdk and it can also be termed as Java
RTE the jdk provides the minimal amount
of requirements needed to write and
compile a Java program JRE consists of
the jvm supporting files and the core
classes the jvm is key to both jdk and
the JRE because it is embedded into them
now whichever Java program is being run
the jvm is that component of java that
executes a program line by line thus
giving itself the work of an interpreter
we are now in a position to Deep dive
into the process with which jdk JRE and
jvm work let's take a source file and
save it with the extension. Java this
file is compiled and converted into a
set of bite code which changes the file
extension into class this is done
specifically by the jdk now here are the
steps that follow class loader it makes
sure that all the necessary classes are
loaded in the time of the execution of a
program Next Bite code verifier that is
jvm the bite code verifier checks the
code for errors or irregularities based
on access rights on objects or
implementation of pointers it makes sure
that the code fulfills the
specifications of jvm and does not break
the system integrity and finally
interpreter which is jvm now while
running the program The Interpreter
loads checks and runs the code the
implementation is made by the JRE which
is the final process the latest release
is jdk9 and it was released in October
2017 but it was in jdk8 that a new
feature called the Java Lambda
expression was introduced that changed
the pH of java now Java Lambda
expression is a kind of function which
does not need any class to be created it
has been included in the latest version
of jdk as it provides a clear concise
way to pass functions around this also
replaces earlier bulky Anonymous classes
and reduces code verbosity that is the
length of the code the Syntax for the
Lambda expression is this
argument list arot token body now the
syntax consists of three components
which are argument list this can be
empty or non-empty next the arrow token
now this is used to link argument to
body and finally body this contains the
statement that works with the
function let us now just see an example
of using Lambda expression and
contrasting it with how code would have
been written with Anonymous
classes this is the old
method and this is the new method with
Lambda
expression just have a look at how
Lambda expression syntax has been used
over here the jdk9 has been released
recently and it seems promising with
respect to new features and abilities
here are some of the
features the first one is Java platform
module system this module allows strong
encapsulation and declare explicit
dependencies next jshell with the help
of jshell one can directly start writing
the code on the console and execute them
improve Java doc Java docs have got the
search right in the API documentation
and as an added bonus the output is also
compliant to HTML 5 next stream API the
stream API also introduced in Java 8
allows programmers to easily paralyze
code for improved concurrency and
introduces functional programming
abilities to the language the stream API
in conjunction with Lambda Expressions
also comes in handy while iterating
filtering and extracting large amount of
data the release of multi jar makes it
possible for codes to be run on the
newer versions of GDK to be released so
first of all understand why do we need
Loop statements so generally whenever
you are dealing with some data
structures in jav
which can store multiple elements for
example we saw array which can store
multiple elements string is also
basically technically a character array
which is storing multiple characters so
whenever you have these kind of data
structures where you have multiple
elements being stored in the same then
in that case you would like to have a
way to iterate or access all of the
elements in a seamless fashion one of
the ways is to access them individually
one by one but that's too much of work
that's too much of code there has to be
a simpler way of accessing all the
elements one by one if I want to and
that's where the majority of the use
cases for using Loops coming to picture
now Java provides multiple constructs to
write Loops in Java there is a while
loop there is a do while loop there is a
for Loop there is also an enhanced for
Loop and in the previous versions of
java a use case of iterator was also
very popular
so there are multiple ways in which you
can actually iterate over a collection
and access all the elements of the
collection one by one and you can use it
to multiple useful cases for example if
you have a huge array of employee salary
and you want to give bonus to each of
the employees and add the bonus to the
salary then you need to do this addition
for all the employees it would be nice
to have to return a while loop and the
while loop can automatically access all
the employee salary by one and keep
adding the bonus to the salary this
would be an easier way to do this rather
than individually updating each employee
salary and the first Loop statement we
are going to understand is a while loop
so the syntax of while loop is very
straightforward you write the while
keyword you enter the actual condition
which will be evaluating to a Boolean
true or false so you write the
expression which will be a Boolean
expression exactly similar to the
conditions which you you use to write in
your if statements so you write your
condition which will evaluate to either
true or false and then you write your
statement and these statements will keep
executing till the time this particular
expression evaluates to true so
generally the way it works is that it
will enter the V block it will evaluate
the expression if the expression becomes
true then the statements inside this
particular V block will be executed and
after the uh execution of the statement
it will again go back again valate the
expression we call them steps basically
so it will go to the next step again
evaluate the expression if this again if
this still holds true it will again go
inside execute the statement move on to
the next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this Loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the IDE and look at an example example
of it so I have already created V demo
for it here it is it looks very small
and simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why
we'll be we'll be using the V Loops so
I've created a v demo class I've added a
public static void main method here
which is the entry point I have declared
a variable which is int count equal to 1
so the count value is one right now and
then I'm writing a condition here I'm
saying while count is less than then do
this so it will print the current value
of count and after that I'm using the
post increment unary operator if you
remember we covered this in the previous
sessions what is the meaning of this it
basically will increment the value of
count by one this expression is is
equivalent to if I write it in this way
if I write count equal to count + 1 this
is exactly the same as this no
difference so this will have the same
impact I will just remove this line
because we already have the count Plus+
here so if we try to understand this we
are basically incrementing the count and
then checking the condition again so at
first time it will be 1 less than 10 yes
that is true it will go inside and print
the count value the current count value
which will be one and then it does count
Plus+ so now the count value becomes two
it will again go back here again check
the condition saying is 2 less than 10
yes that is true so the while condition
again becomes true it will again go
inside this print the current value of
count which is two then do count Plus+
so it will again increment the value of
count so the now the count value becomes
three again go back here at condition
and saying is three less than 10 yes
that is still true again come here print
the three again go here make count as
four four less than 10 prints four again
count Plus+ count becomes five and so on
so forth it will keep doing that till
the value becomes 10 so at a step when
count Plus+ results in the count value
being up updated to 10 it will go here
and say is 10 less than 10 now that is
not true because 10 is equal to 10 but
10 is not less than 10 so this condition
will become false and it will exit of
this while loop and it will come here
and it will execute if there's if there
was anything written after the while
loop that will be executed so that's the
idea that you want to do something till
a particular condition holds true then
you can use the while loop Define your
condition and execute the statements and
try to do something which changes the
state of this condition here I'm
changing the count so that every time a
new evaluation happens if I comment this
this will result in an infinite Loop
because 1 will always be less than 10 I
will not be incrementing the count here
and it will keep running forever it will
never stop it will just keep printing
one one one every time till your
computer program runs out of the memory
so always remember not to end up into an
infinite Loop that's probably one of the
biggest mistakes and any beginner
programmer does so please try to be
aware of that particular loophole not
try to run an infinite Loop always try
to write something in the code block
which can change the state of the
condition and also make sure that that
state condition sometimes sometime
should become false you should also make
sure that that that always becomes false
because if I do this if I do this then
this condition will always remain true
because it is already one then it will
become zero then it will become minus
one - 2 - 3 so on so forth but that
value of count will forever be less than
10 and again you will never be able to
exit this Loop your program will be
stuck in this Loop till your program
runs out of the memory so always
remember to write a a statement or a
statement of execution in your in your
code block which can change the state of
the condition which results in some
eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and
that's it after 9 the moment the count
Plus+ resulted into the count value
becoming 10 it checked that condition
and then it just came out of the loop
because 10 is not less than 10 and the
condition became false so always do
something inside your code block which
results at least one scenario where this
condition becomes false and that is how
you can use the while loop now you can
see this is a pretty generic code and
you can write any kind of condition here
write any code you want to execute here
and then do something to change the
state of the condition as well in a
positive way in a way which results this
particular condition to be false at some
point of time and then your while loop
will run fine so this is all I wanted to
cover in terms of the while loop hello
guys let's get started with today
today's topic which is about how to use
do while Loops so let's understand when
do we need that and how do you actually
use that let me switch to the Java
documentation and if I can find some
syntax of it as well yep so as you can
see here if I just highlight this
portion this is how you actually write a
do while statement block so you write do
you start a code block you write some
executable statements and then after the
code block ends you write a v expression
and end it with semicolon this is the
syntax basically it starts with do a
curly braces some executable statements
a while block or a while statement
basically with an expression ending with
a semicolon let's understand this with
the help of a program to understand the
structure better so for this I have
created a sample program here which is
called do while demo again having a
public static void main method
and it has a variable which is count and
it is initialized as one then I write do
I write this code block or the curly
braces and then I am just printing the
value of count then I am incrementing
the value of count and then I am writing
a condition which says while count is
less than 10 and semicolon if you
compare this with the previous demo we
ran if I just put them side by side we
had while condition state M and and the
and the state change condition here we
have do statement condition change
statement and then we check the
condition at the end so the idea is that
if you have a use case where before you
even evaluate the condition you want to
print something even before you evaluate
the condition if you want to do
something in that case you will use the
do while loop even before the while
actual while loop starts if you want to
execute a state M you will use do while
loop for example if you want to print
the initial value of the count even
before the condition checks then you can
use dowi Loop if that is not your use
case you can use a simple y Loop which
is described here in this program so
coming back to the do while so I say do
and then I'm saying print this
particular statement without checking
anything this condition will be executed
for the first time without any condition
check at all this will just work as is
like a normal Java statement after that
I'm incrementing the value of the count
and then I'm checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked the first increment has
already happened but in the while case
we did the comparison before even the
first increment the first comparison
happened with the original value of
count but here the first comparison is
happening with the incremented value of
the count hope you get the difference in
a better context now that you will use
this when you want to do some write some
initialization code before you actually
hit the condition so this condition will
be evaluated with 2 less than 10 and
then the value will be printed let's
print this example and we'll also try to
play around with this example a bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better if I run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it will go back
to statement number nine again print
this again do an increment on the count
and again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say 3 less than 10 now similarly print
the value increment check this will
continue to happen till this particular
condition becomes false and once this
condition is is false it will exit out
of this whole dowhile Loop and it will
go to the line number 12 and if you have
any statement written there you can uh
that statement will be executed in this
case so let's try to change some values
here and let's see if if if we can make
sense of this program if it change the
value let's say if I put 11 here what
will happen now let's run this program
you will say the now you will see that
this particular output is displayed
which says count is 11 so what happened
here here that count was 11 it entered
the dovile block it went to this
particular statement which said count is
11 then it incremented the value so the
value became 12 and obviously 12 is not
less than 10 so it did not print it
again it only printed once even if the
first time the condition was checked the
first condition execution itself
resulted in false still line number nine
got successfully printed and that's the
whole that's that's the whole idea
behind using the do while what if I
change this value to 10 let's see what
happens and after that we'll run one
more combination to just make it more
interesting This Time Again count is 10
line number 10 will be printed as count
is 10 then at line number 10 the count
is incremented to 11 and 11 is not less
than 10 so in this case the loop ends
and it will move out now what happens if
I do this if I say less than equal to
here let's run this program and
interpret the output now again only one
statement is printed because in this
case the count is 10 10 is printed here
and we are saying 10 + 1 11 11 is still
not less than equal to 10 and that's why
the loop just exits let's make it nine
and see what happens now you see two
values so count is nine it enters the
dowi loop goes to statement number nine
prints the current value of count which
is nine then increments the value to 10
then at line number 11 this V statement
is executed and the condition is checked
is 10 less than equal to 10 yes 10 is
not less than but 10 is equal to 10 so
this condition will hold true it will go
back here print count is 10 make count
11 again check the condition is 11 less
than equal to 10 no it's not and then
the condition will return to false and
loop will be exited so hope this will
give you a better understanding now
since we ran different permutations and
combinations of the values and we saw
when this will be executed and when this
will not be executed but the bottom line
is very straightforward that whenever
you want to write some pre-processing
logic even before checking the very
first condition of your Loop then in
that case you will be using a do while
loop otherwise a normal while loop or a
for Loop will absolutely work fine hello
guys let's get started with today's
topic which is about for Loops in Java
so so far we covered about while loops
and do while loops and we also saw
different examples of using different
types of data structures like arrays but
one of the core requirements whenever
you are working with any kind of
collection is to iterate over it exactly
similar to what I explained in the do
while and while lectures that you would
often require to iterate over a
collection or a data structure and for
that one of the most sophisticated and
easiest way to do that is using for
Loops so let's understand the syntax of
for Loop first and then we will also
look at an example of it in the in the
Eclipse IDE so I have just opened the
official Java docs here so if you see
this is basically the syntax of a for
Loop statement so let's understand it
and let's also try to compare it with a
Y Loop so that we can understand how it
Compares with the while loop so if we
see the syntax we first see the term
initialization then we see the term
termination and then we see the term
called increment now if I try to compare
it with a Y Loop there also you
basically did these three things you
first initialized a variable outside the
while loop which is called
initialization and then you wrote a
condition which is your termination
condition you wrote a condition saying
let's say while I is greater than 10 or
while I is less than 10 so that is the
condition which is also the termination
statement the loop will continue to
execute till that condition evaluates to
false and that's when the loop
terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the i++ which we
used to do in the while Loops so these
three portions together make or
constitute any kind of loop in any kind
of programming language and for Loop if
you see the the kind of code which you
use to write in a while loop in multiple
lines where you first initialize a
variable then you write a condition in
the while block and then inside the
while block you use to increment the
variable all of that can be done in a
single line in the for Loop and that's
why I said it it is the most
sophisticated and easiest way to write
Loops in Java so you write all of these
three things the initialization
the condition and the increment or
decrement values in the single line and
then you start with a curly braces and
you write the code which you want to
keep executing till the condition
evaluates to false that's the basic
syntax of it so let us try to understand
this with the help of an example so here
I have opened a class which is called
for demo and this is a class which will
demonstrate the usage of a for Loop so
again we have a public static void main
method which which you can see here
which is the entry point and then I use
the keyword for I put standard braces or
the brackets and then I do the
initialization so this part is the
initialization part you initialize the
variable so I just say in I equal to 1
initialization done you end it with a
semicolon so that it is a single
statement understood by Java and then
you write this condition which is your
evaluation SL termination condition so
this condition is basically the the
deciding factor of how long your Loops
should run it's exactly similar to what
you used to write in the while block if
I just show you the example this is what
we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while uh syntax or the
construct and then we did the increment
here so we are doing all of these three
steps but we are doing it in a single
line so this is our condition and then
we write our increment or decrement uh
values which are going to change the
evaluation condition every time at every
step so we are saying I ++ so
technically what I am saying here is
that start with i equal to 1 and then
check the condition I less than 10 so in
the in the first step it will be
checking if 1 is less than 10 if the
condition holds true go inside the for
Loop execute the statement at line
number seven and then go back to this
particular statement so we do I ++ so I
becomes 2 and then you again go back to
the condition and again you check if 2
is less than 10 yes it is so again you
go inside inside the for Loop and do
whatever is written there there can be
multiple statements here for now I have
just written one system.out.print Len so
that happens and once all the execution
is finished inside the block it will
again go back to the increment does the
increment so 2 + 1 becomes three again
does the evaluation EXE and if the if
the condition holds true it will again
go inside so this will continue this
condition checking execution and
increment will continue till the time
this condition holds true the moment
this condition becomes false the control
will come out at line number nine so
that's the basic anatomy and control
flow it's very important to understand
the control flow of a for Loop otherwise
you might end up into a program which is
forever running and which will just eat
up all the memory available in your jvm
so be very sure of what you write in
your for Loop be very sure of especially
these two parts the condition and the
increment or decrement so this is very
important piece the initialization
happens only once and then this
condition evaluates if the condition
holds to True some code executes goes
back to the changing statement which can
be an increment decrement whatever and
again compares the updated value with a
condition so this will keep happening
let's run this code to interpret the
output so I will right click go to run
as Java application and if I interpret
the output here I can see that it
started with count is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
and 9 it stopped at 9 so what happened
there let's try to evaluate the
termination condition so let's say I has
become 9 and 9 is less than 10 so it
goes inside and it prints count is 9
which is I then it goes here and it says
9 + 1 I ++ means 9 + 1 the current value
of I + 1 it becomes 10 and then it again
compares the condition so now 10 is not
less than 10 10 is equal to 10 but it is
not less than 10 so the condition
becomes false and count is 10 is never
printed because this condition has
become false it will jump out so let's
say if I do this if I put an equal to
here and if I now execute the same
program this time I will see 10 here and
because I have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the I will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite Loops for
example if I say I = to 1 I leave it
that and I say IUS minus so what happens
I = to 1 1 is less than 10 yes it goes
here prints the value and then I
decrement the value I don't increment
the value I decrement the value so
whatever value comes out will always be
less than 10 and this Loop will run
forever for fun let's try to run this
and I will I will have to kill this
program manually but just to show you
what happens and what you should not do
in your in your Java program so you see
it will continuously keep printing the
values till the program runs out of
memory till it eats up all the available
memory it is it is forever running it
will never stop because the condition
will never remain never never evaluate
to false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever so I'm
just going to kill the program but this
is something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing Java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers hello guys and let's get
started with enhanced for Loops in Java
we generally use the enhanced for Loops
for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for Loop and this for Loop is
even simpler like I said it's even
simpler than uh writing a classic for
Loop and the syntax is simply like this
you again start with for put the
standard brackets and then let's start
from the rightmost because then it I
will be able to explain it better you
specify the collection in the rightmost
side of the bracket The Collection can
be an array it can be a list can be a
map so whatever different kind of
collections which are available in Java
and we are going to cover collections in
detail so don't worry if you don't
understand what are lists and what are
maps and what are sets we will go into
detail of each of these one by one in
the upcoming sessions but the idea is
that you put the collection to the
rightmost then you put a colon and then
you put a representation of the member
of this collection so for example here
this numberers is basically an INT array
so this int array means that this array
Can Only Hold integer numbers and that's
why we write int here because this array
is only having integers then we put any
placeholder variable name this can be
anything you can even write it as I if
you want to you can write it as has
anything any variable name which you
want to write this is a temporary
variable so now this code is going to
execute in a manner that it is going to
iterate over this array one by one
starting from the first element going
till the last element you don't need to
write any initialization code you don't
need to write any termination condition
code and you don't need to write any
increment or decrement code also and how
these thre uh how these three values are
actually taken care of let's understand
that as well so when we talk about the
initialization as I have put an array
here a data structure here the automatic
initialization index is going to be the
first index so when we do the iteration
when this for Loop is going to execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable with the value at
the first index which is the index zero
as you know that array is a zero index
based stru structure then comes the
condition part so the condition
evaluation is going to be again based on
the size of the array or the size of the
data structure which you're using it is
going to start from the first index
which is the index zero and it is going
to iterate till the arrays last element
is reached so technically start from the
index zero and go till the last element
that's your evaluation condition and
then comes the increment part so at each
step after it has successfully accessed
the first element automatically the
index is going to be updated to pointing
to the next element so if it starts from
here once the first step iteration is
complete I is automatically going to be
incremented to index one and then it
will basically this I will be holding
two then in the next iteration the same
I is going to be holding three similarly
I will keep holding the new value of the
collection item one by one till the
collection items last element is reached
so this is the basic premise that you
can write a collection variable here and
keep iterating over it and this whatever
variable you write here will hold the
current items value one by one so in the
first step this I is going to hold one
in the second step this I is going to
hold two in the third step this I is
going to hold three and so on so forth
that's the basic idea so now let's run
this program to see what kind of output
do we get so you can see we basically
are able to print all the elements of
the array and that's probably one of the
most popular usage as well that if you
want to just print all the elements or
access all the elements of a array or a
collection one by one then just use
enhanced for Loop so you can see at each
step it is printing the the value of I
and the value of I is basically the
subsequent elements of the array that's
the whole idea with enhanced for Loop
under the hoods if you talk about how
does it work under the hood it is
actually using the classic for Loop
construct itself but for developers it
is making it easier because it knows
that if you are iterating over a
collection you will start with the first
element and you will go till the last
element so it knows the initialization
value the termination condition and it
also knows the increment condition and
that's the reason you will use enhanced
for Loops in Java for iterating over
collections hello guys let's get started
with nested for Loops in Java so in
front of you you can see an example
which I have prepared for nested for
loops and in this particular example I
have created a two-dimensional array as
you can see on the line number six I
have created an integer array and I have
put two square brackets here which are
basically symbolizing that this is a
two-dimensional array so this
two-dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d Matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for Loops
to print this 2D array in a 2d Matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly let's first try
to inter uh interpret this particular 2D
array so we have a curly braces outside
and then we have these three Inner
Elements which symbolizes three rows
basically so this is the first row this
is the second row and this is the third
row and then each of the rows have three
elements each which symbolizes the
column values or the item values so it's
basically a 3 into 3 2D array which has
three rows and three columns so so we
can say that this is basically a 3 into
three array which has three dimensions
on the row side and three dimensions on
the column side or just a 3X3 Matrix or
3x3 2D array so as we know that in case
of arrays everything starts from zero so
technically if we talk about the indexes
it would be the index0 index one and
index 2 on the row side and similarly
index 0 index one and index two on the
column side so that's that's something
which you should remember because we are
going to use this particular concept
when we write the for Loop so let's try
to write the for Loop now if you look at
line number eight we put this keyword
called for and then we write the
initialization so we say int I equal to
0 then we are writing the termination
condition and we are saying R run this
particular Loop run this whole Loop
which ends at line 13 till I is less
than three and keep incrementing I at
every step that's what I'm doing in the
line number eight then inside the for
Loop I'm writing another for Loop which
has another different variable called J
it can be anything you can name it
anything you want and this also starts
with zero and this also has a similar
condition which is which says run this
particular Loop the line 10 basically or
this Loop which is signified by this
curly BRAC run this particular Loop till
the time the value of J is less than
three and keep incrementing J at every
step and at line number 10 print the
element of array which has the current
value of I and the current value of J
these are basically the positions these
are not the elements the element would
be represented by this whole but print
the element which is at current I and
J's position values that's what this
code means so let's try to do a dry run
on this particular code to understand
how this is going to work so at first we
have I equal to 0 0 is is less than
three and it goes inside it initializes
J as well with zero and J is 0 is also
less than three so this condition went
true that's why we went to line number
nine and line number nine condition also
went to true so we went to line number
10 remember that in this particular case
at line number 10 the values of I and J
are 0 and zero respectively and we are
saying print the array of 0 and 0o so
zeroth rows zeroth column element should
be printed so this is the zeroth row
because this is the first uh first
subblock and this is the first element
so in this case in line number 10 two
should get printed then it goes here and
it increments the J to 1 so 0 + 1
becomes 1 it again checks the condition
is 1 Less Than 3 so yes 1 is less than
three it goes here remember it did not
go up at line number eight it just came
back from line number nine so when it
comes here here I is still Z but J has
moved from 0 to 1 so now we are trying
to access the element which is at 0th
row First Column which is going to be S
so s is going to get printed similarly
on the next iteration J is going to get
incremented from 1 to 2 and again the
condition will be evaluated so 2 is less
than three all good it will again come
back to line number 10 and now it will
say print the value of zero row third or
the second column or the third element
so zeroth Row Third element which is the
nine so nine will get printed then again
J will be incremented and J will become
3 2 + 1 3 and now the condition will be
evaluated is three less than three no it
is not less than three the condition
becomes false so it breaks out of the
loop goes to line number 12 prints an
empty line because we are not writing
anything here so it will just print a
blank line and now it will go back back
to line number 8's condition and it will
do an increment of I and now I will move
from 0 to 1 and now the evaluation will
happen is 1 less than three yes 1 is
less than three so it will again go to
line number N9 again initialize J with a
fresh zero the previous J got destroyed
the moment you came out of the loop so
this is a new J so this J again gets
initialized to 0 0 is less than three it
goes here remember I was one in this
time so now it will print the value of
this 2D array which is sitting at 1
comma 0 basically second row first
element so second row first element
which is three again J is going going to
get incremented and it will become from0
to 1 so 1 is less than three yes it will
again come here and it will print the
value of the array which is sitting at
array of 1 comma 1 for row equal to 1
and column equal to 1 which will be six
similarly J will get incremented again
again 2 is less than three come back
here we'll print one then again we'll
increment J J will become three 3 is
less than three no it's false the
condition is false so it jumps out of
the loop goes to line number 12 prints a
blank line again goes back to 8 line
number 8 increments I and I now becomes
2 2 is less than three yes it will again
go here initialize J again with zero and
again does the same thing for the row
two and column 012 and again it will
come out of the loop this time again
when it will go here the value will
become from 2 to three and 3 is not less
than three so then it will break out of
the outer loop so the idea is execute
the inner loop for every value of the
outer loop remember this line because
that is how you will be applying your
knowledge of nested for Loops to be used
in in certain condition so whenever you
have a scenario where you have to
iterate over a collection based on a
certain value of another collection then
you can use nested for Loops or you have
a scenario where you have to iterate
over 2D or 3D arrays for example if we
were dealing with 3D arrays then you
would have seen three nested for Loops
here and where it will apply the same
logic that iterate over all the
collections all the values of the inner
loop on us particular value of the outer
loop then increment the value of the
outer loop and do the same thing again I
trade over all the values of the inner
loop based on a fixed value of the outer
loop so let's run this program and let's
see what kind of output do we get so
like I said our our motive our Target
was to print this in a in a matrix style
and you can see that it is printing in
in a sort of a matrix representation so
the first row gets printed here then the
second row gets printed here and then
the third row gets printed here if you
try to decipher it it will work exactly
the same way as I explained so I equal
to 0 0 Less Than 3 condition becomes
true comes here J equal to 0 J Less Than
3 condition becomes true comes here
prints the array of 0 comma 0 which is
two then prints the array of 0a 1 which
is 7 0a 2 which is 9 then J becomes
three it breaks out of the loop goes up
here I becomes from 0 to 1 1 is less
than three Yes again comes here
reinitializes a fresh for loop with a
new J setting to zero and it will it
will print the array of 1 0 1 1 1 2 then
similarly array of two 0 2 1 22 so
that's basically what we are doing we
are iterating we are picking the first
row and iterating all elements of it
picking the second row iterating all all
elements over it and so on so forth you
can do this for any end dimensional kind
of array or a collection so now let's
download Java let's go to Google and
search for Java download we'll go to the
link we see here oracle.com so now here
we have the web page here we can see
Java se13 so this is version 13 but this
isn't the one we are going to download
we going to download the eth version
version 8 which is here now we're doing
this because 8 is one of the more
commonly used versions of java so let's
click this and here we'll go down we
need to accept the license agreement
before we can download it now we have
two version here x86 and x64 now you can
download it depending on what version
your operating system is now if you do
have a Windows 10 operating system it's
highly likely you have a 64-bit version
of Windows now if you do have a 32-bit
version of Windows you can take the x86
so let's download this so we've actually
already logged in so we just need to run
the installer file now let's go to
downloads and run the file so here we
have the installer we go to the next
step
we'll select this to next here we can
see where the file is being installed to
we'll go to
next now if you want to change where you
want to install Java we can press the
Change option I'm just going to keep it
here we'll press next and let's commence
with
installation and there we go the
installation is now complete so we don't
need any tutorials or API mentation so
we'll just finish off and go to close
now to see if Java is installed in your
system we can go to command prompt and
type the term Java C which refers to the
Java
compiler now as you can see here this
shows a number of different options you
can choose from this also indicates that
Java has been successfully installed in
your system now if the installation was
not successful you'll see something like
Java C is not recognized as an internal
or external command operable program or
batch file but since we've done it
successfully this is what will be shown
now and now we going to set an
environment variable now what exactly is
an environment variable now assume you
have a file which has a Java extension
this environment variable tells the
computer that the Java program needs to
be called to run this particular file so
to set the environment variable we'll
need to go to control
panel here go into system in security
go to system and select Advanced system
settings and then this shows up now
before we go into environment variables
we'll need to go to where the Java file
was installed so let's go to this PC C
drive program files and here let's go to
Java so let's go to jdk which is the
Java development kit let's go to bin
here and copy this
path we'll go back to environment
variable
select path here and then press on
new paste this and okay now we'll go
back and go to JRE to the path of JRE
which is Java runtime environment you
click on this pin again and copy this
path select this
one new and paste
that and there we go the environment
variables are now set now let's talk
about running that simple program I told
you about now this is possible with the
help of an IDE an IDE or integrated
development environment will give us a
platform to code Java we will be using
eclipse and intellig as they are popular
and commonly used that being said there
are several other IDs that are available
in the market so now let's work with
Eclipse let's go to Google and search
for
Eclipse we'll go to this
link press download and then this shows
up let's click on download now we've
already downloaded the software so I'm
just going to directly go into the
install phase downloads and select
Eclipse with this you can see that there
are multiple options for you to choose
from so we're going to select Eclipse ID
for Java developers now you have other
options like for CN C++ JavaScript PHP
and so on let's go to the first one and
here you have the details you can change
them if you want but I'm just going to
go ahead with installation now press
accept
now here here we remember accepted
licenses and press
accept and then here as well we'll
remember accepted certificates select
this one and accept
selected and there you go the
installation is now complete let's click
on launch now so here we setting up a
directory as a workspace uh I'm not
changing it here so I'm just going to go
with
launch here we have the eclipse
workspace now let's close this first and
here we have the package EXP Explorer
now in case this doesn't show up you can
go to window Show view and select on
package Explorer so now let's go to file
new and Java project we need to set up a
project name I'm going to call it my
project
one go to next we'll go to source so
this is where the source code for your
program is going to be stored then let's
finish and now we'll click on my project
one go to Source right click new and
create a class we clim I'll name the
class my
class and create it and here we have it
so now let's write a simple program to
multiply two numbers so now let's write
the main
function open
bracket now we're going to initialize
the first
number now the second
one and finally the output and finally
the variable that will store the
output now we'll just give them a simple
print
statement
now let's run The Code by clicking this
option here using my class. Java and
there we have it here the product is
shown to be 100 indicating that the
program is running successfully now
we're done with Eclipse now let's move
on to the other IDE I was talking about
which is intellig so for that again
we'll have to go back to Google so that
we can download it search for intellig
download go to this link here so here
you can see that we have two options the
ultimate edition and the community
version now here the ultimate version
has way more options as you can see here
but it's a paid version and only has a
free trial now the community version is
free so that's what we're going to take
so we'll click on download here so I've
already downloaded the software so I
don't need to do it again so I'm going
to go downloads and so here we go let's
just click on next select the location
where you want to install it press next
now we will add a 64-bit launcher
shortcut on the desktop and create
associations so basically this means
that these are the different file
extensions that this will support so
java. gry and now let's go to the next
step we'll install now and we'll wait
and there we go the installation is now
complete let's not import any
settings we'll accept the privacy policy
we'll set
defaults now let's create a new project
so here make sure your project SDK is
set to the version of java you've
installed make sure this isn't blank
we'll go to next here you need to select
this option which is the create project
from template and we are now going to
create a command line
application press next name the project
which I'm going to call my project two
you can change the location if you want
I'm just going to keep it the way it is
and then and click on
finish so now we're going to create a
simple program through which based on
the users's input we can determine
whether a number is even or odd so first
we going to import the package scanner
through which we can take the user
input next let's go inside here let's
create the varable
reader
now let's ask for the users's
input enter a
number we're taking in the value now
in the variable
num
reader next int so this is with which
we'll be taking in the value from the
user so we're going to set up a
condition to determine whether the
number is even or not so if the
number when when divided by two provides
the remainder zero it indicates that
it's an even number we'll show them
then now for the else
case the number is not
even
or in this case
odd there we go we're done so let's run
this
program so let's enter
12 the number is even and there we go we
have a successful output this indicates
that the program is running successfully
let's begin with the fundamentals so the
first one in the fundamentals is the
data types so every programming language
has a data type so what exactly is a
data type so whatever the input you
provide in your program is a data type
for example if you provide numbers so in
that particular numbers we have a
different variety of numbers if you are
given just 1 2 3 so on without a decimal
number then that particular type of
input which is a number will be
considered as integer type if you
provide the same number with a decimal
point then that will be considered as
float and if you have the range greater
than float it will be considered as
stubble and so on so this is how we have
multiple data types in every programming
language so the most frequently used
data types in Java programming languages
are as follows at first we have the bite
followed by that we have short int long
next float then double Boolean and
finally care apart from this we also
have few other data types but these are
the most frequently used ones for all
the basic
programmingsoftware are used to store
the values so for example consider that
you wanted to run some athematic
operation on two different values that
is 5 and 10 so in order to do so you
might want to create a variable which
stores them for example you wanted to
store the value of 10 in a certain
variable a and the five in a certain
variable B so if you apply the
arithmetic operation that is AAL to a +
b then the value value of a which was
previously 10 will be updated to 15 so
here you can see the value is varying
and also it is storing the result so
this is why the variables are used in a
program in order to store a value and
this particular term variable is used
because the value can change at any
instance of time once after a certain
arithmatic or a logical operation is
performed on that particular variable so
similarly we have keywords unlike
variables keywords have a special
meaning no matter whatever you try you
cannot change the meaning of that
keyword for example consider main so you
cannot use the term main for normal
things because the part or the term main
is dedicated for a different purpose so
whenever you try to execute your Java
program the control flow will start
executing the program right when it
reads the term main so it has a special
meaning say similarly you have other
keyword such as int so that is dedicated
for integer type of values and float for
float type of values that is the decimal
values and bite for bite care for
character type data string for string so
every keyword or every term with special
meaning which is predefined and cannot
be changed is called as a keyword now
let's see the most frequently used
keywords in Java programming language so
similar to the previous one we have a
table here so in this particular table
we have the most frequently used
keywords in Java so you can see we have
Boolean final bite native and we have
void switch so switch is a conditional
statement so we have if if it is also a
conditional statement we will go through
this conditional statements as we
proceed in our tutorial and you can also
see the protected so this term which is
protected public so this is basically
the access modifier even this this
particular keyword have special meaning
this public this protected keywords
provide the information to the compiler
or The Interpreter about the
accessibility of that particular data
member or data manipulating method so if
it is protected from your accessibility
or is it available for you it's provided
by these keywords so we will deal with
access modifiers in the upcoming Parts
don't worry about that and as you can
see we have implements extend
so extance uh this term comes in
inheritance so inheritance is one of the
crucial concepts of objectoriented
programming you can also see abstraction
so this we will be dealing in the next
upcoming part where we will understand
the objectoriented programming Concepts
next we have interface return and so on
you can also see some keywords like
throw so throw will come in exception
handling so we will also learn about
exception handling in the upcoming part
so these are the most frequently used
keywords in Java so now we will move
ahead into our next concept so the next
concept is the operators in Java so to
understand operators let's go through a
table so on my screen you can see a
table which has some arithmatic
operators which have most commonly used
that is the Plus for addition minus for
subtraction similarly we have star slash
double plus double minus so double plus
and double minus say they are increment
and decrement operators respectively as
you can see we have A++ here which means
the post increment so the first value
will be read after that the value will
be updated next we have the
pre-increment the value will be
incremented first then the updated value
will be stored so that's that's how the
increment and decrement operators work
so we have the modulus over here so to
understand the operators that we use in
Java in a much better way let's try to
execute a sample program so on my screen
you can see a program which is based on
operators so we are currently on the
Eclipse IDE don't worry about the Ides
and Java etc etc so I will drop a link
in the description box below which will
explain you in a very detailed way about
how to install Java into your local
system and how to install Eclipse IDE in
your local system and also how to create
your first project how to create your
package how to create a new class how to
write your program and how to run on
that how to see the output and a
complete overview of the Eclipse IDE how
that works so everything will be linked
in the description box Bel you don't
have to worry about that so right now to
save time I have created the text
document which has all the programs that
we will be executing today so I will
also drop a link for that particular
file so that you can have complete
access to that file so that you can run
the programs in your personal PCS or
laptops and also understand the programs
in a much better way so now let's begin
with the program so this particular
program is basically designed for
athematic operations so you can see we
have the operators that is the addition
subtraction multiplication division
modulus and exit so basically we will be
taking input from you so the input will
be taken by the user that is we we using
scanner class here so scanner class
takes the input from user and that
particular input will be compared here
so we using the switch case here so if
you provide the option as one then
addition operation will be run similarly
second for substraction thirdd for
multiplication fourth for division fifth
for modulus and sixth to exit so this is
how the uh loop or the program works for
automatic operations now let's quickly
run this program and see the output so
you can see the program got successfully
executed and we have the console asking
for the first input let's provide some
random number now let's provide the
second number so there you go we have
our options over here now let's choose
um division operation for that you need
to provide the number four so there you
go we have the result over here which is
four now the loop has started once again
now it's in the starting stage again
it's asking for numbers now let's
provide 25 and uh five uh now let's
choose some operation that is addition
so for that we need to provide one so we
have the result again that is 30 now
let's again choose some number 10 five
so basically that's how the program
works so we have the brief idea how the
program is running now so now let's
quickly continue with our next topic now
to terminate this Loop you can provide
the option number six so we have
terminated it so I hope you understood
how the program flow is running so if
you did not understand don't worry I
have linked the document in the
description box below you can take the
access of that particular document and
you can check the program and run in
your local system and also you can make
some modifications to it as you can see
we don't have a default case over here
I've just placed the case one 126 and uh
I'm saying the default because you can
see that the options are from 1 to six
what if the user provides the number as
seven right so the program might crash
over here so for that purpose you can
write in another case that would be the
default case so the default case will
check if the number is anything above or
out of the range of 1 to six then it
should be providing you with an output
saying a wrong input has been given or
check your input or something similar so
that's how you can make some
modifications to it you're free to
modify the code as well don't worry
about that so now let's quickly begin
with our next concept so in the next
concept we have the conditional
statements so what are the conditional
statements or the control statements so
basically these are some yeah these are
conditions so what happens is just
imagine that uh you wanted to do
something or if you wanted to drive a
vehicle or if you wanted to drive a bike
so the condition you will apply on your
mind is if I know driving then I will do
it if not I'll not do it so that's what
you do right so basically you apply a
condition on your mind and you do it if
it is capable of doing or if you are
capable of doing doing it so in the same
way the conditional statements play a
major role in Computer Logic so before
writing a code or before you start your
program you provide the condition
perform this particular operation if the
provided condition is satisfied so
similarly you have these three
conditional statements in Java which are
if if else and nested if so we use these
conditional statements in Java to
implement our logic so we will
understand the conditional statements
particularly if if else and nested if in
a much more detailed Way by practically
running some programs based on these
three types of conditional statements so
now you can see that we are back on the
eclipse right now so this particular
code segment is based on the F condition
I hope the program is visible let's try
to increase the font size so I think
it's better now so basically we have an
input so we have the integer type of
input that is num and we have the number
as minus 100 so it is a negative number
and after that we have the if condition
so this is where the conditional
statement is provided so the condition
is if the number is greater than zero if
the provided number is greater than zero
then the control should enter the loop
which is this particular segment and
execute the statements present inside
that particular Loop so here we have one
single statement that is a print
statement that says the number is
positive in case the condition fails
imagine that the condition fails then
what happens is that instead of entering
this particular code segment this
particular code segment the control will
Skip and execute the next statement that
is Another Printer statement which we
have over here which says the if
condition is terminated control is
outside the condition block now since we
have provided a negative number the
second option should go ahead now let's
try to run this and see the output so
there you go as expected the program got
executed and we have only one statement
that is if condition is terminated
control is outside the block now let's
try it otherwise let's just eliminate
the negative number and now check it
again there you go now you can see the
program got executed and now we have two
print statements you can see that the
condition here was true so the control
entered into the statement or the code
block and this particular statement got
executed successfully once the
statements are executed and there is
nothing else to do then the control will
automatically exit this particular
statement and it will enter into the
next statement which is another printer
statement and we have the same output
over there so this is how the single if
statement works so you can also modify
this with an else so that's the next
program that we are going to see we are
going to execute some similar kind of
example for our next kind of conditional
statement that is if else so here only
we had one if condition so in case if
this particular condition fails then we
will be having another condition over
here which will be the else block so as
you can see we have another program so
this particular program is based on if
else condition so here you can see that
we have our first if condition which
states number should be greater than or
equals to zero if this particular
condition is true then this statement
should be executed which says the number
is positive else else if this condition
fails then what you must do the control
should avoid entering this particular
segment and it should directly hit the
next segment where we have the else
block which has another statement which
says the number is negative so this is
how the program works so here we will be
doing a little modification over there
instead of taking an input which is
previously defined as it was in the
previous example where we had given
minus 100 previously we are going to do
it a little differently this time we'll
be taking or reading the input directly
from the user so for that we are going
to use this scanner class so this is the
particular library that we will be using
so we have imported java. ut. scanner so
this particular code segment will ask
you for the input and you will press
some random number and it will read it
as its input now let's try to quickly
run this program and see the output
there you go the program go successfully
executed and now it is asking for an
input from the user now let's try to
provide a negative number so there you
go the program got successfully executed
and you can see that since we had given
a negative number the control did not
enter this particular code segment at
all it directly avoided to enter this
code segment and entered into the else
block and executed the statements
present in that particular else block
which was a simple print statement that
had the statement which read as the
number is negative now let's try to
execute the same program again and see
what would be the output so there you go
now it's asking for the input again now
this time let's provide a positive
number so there you go since we provided
the number as a positive number this
condition was true and this particular
statement got executed since one of the
statements executed there was no need
for the lse block to be executed again
so you can see this particular code
segment runs in this way so once the
condition is checked so if the condition
is true then the true statement will be
executed in case if the conditions
result is false then the false
statements will be executed so you will
be provided with two options so one
option for True validity and another
option for false validity so this is how
the if else block works I hope you
understood this now with this let's
continue with the next type of
conditional statement that is the lsf
ladder so on my screen you can see there
is a change of program we have stepped
into the next type of conditional
statement that is the lsf flat up so
basically everything will be same we
will be provided with only one condition
so we will be checking the validity of
that particular condition so if the
provided condition is true then the
first one will be executed if it is not
then the second one will be executed if
the condition fails for the first two
the third one will be executed if the
first three failed then the fourth and
if all the four fails then we will have
one last else which will print the last
segment or statement so this is how the
else if lad works so basically it's
completely similar to if else but the
only difference is instead of one else
block we have multiple else blocks
that's the only difference now let's
quickly execute this program and sa the
output so basically we are going to take
an input from the user so we will be
entering one for noodles two for
milkshake three for fruits four for
coffee so something like that and if we
provide anything else than one to 2 3 4
then we will be having an else statement
which says it's an invalid input so the
flow of this particular lsf statement is
similar to uh the switch statement
having said that we will also discuss
something about switch statement as well
basically we'll try to execute a program
based on uh switch statement and we will
also understand the control flow of that
don't worry about it now let's quickly
execute this particular program first so
there you go the program got
successfully executed now it's asking
for an input uh let's select noodles
that's how it works we have the output
noodles so the choice is equals to is
equals to 1 so the first one was true so
it executed the first code segment and
everything else got suspended because uh
this was not necessary to be executed
because the condition was true over here
and according to that only this
particular statement was supposed to be
executed so that's how it works now
let's switch into the next conditional
statement which is the switch so you can
see that we have a program on my screen
which is based on switch case so uh you
can see that there is some similarity
between this particular program and the
first program we dealt with that is
based on operators so we also have the
default code segment over here so this
was what I was talking about you can add
a default code segment in that
particular program which is the operator
program and do some modification so this
is what the suggestion I gave over there
now basically what happens in this
particular code segment is is so we have
Monday as the day one of a week Tuesday
as the day two of the week and so on so
uh to select one particular day of a
week you need to provide an input so
it's based on 1 2 3 4 and so on to 7 and
if you provide anything else than 127
you will be provided with an message
which says invalid input so now let's
try to um run this program and see the
output so there you go the program got
successfully executed now let's select
the weekend day so which would be
something between 6 and 7 so 6 is
Saturday and 7 is Sunday let's go with 7
so there you go Sunday now let's try to
execute this program once again and give
a wrong input and see if it works or not
let's provide eight there you go the
program identified it as a wrong input
so it gave us a message invalid input so
that's the use of default uh code
segment in switch case so you can
implement this in that operators program
and check out about how it works can be
considered as a homework though not a
problem now this is how the switch case
works so with this let's move ahead into
the next Concept in our Java tutorial
for today let's get started let's see
what strings are and how we can use
strings in Java Java strings are objects
that contains groups of characters like
arrays strings are immutable as well
immutable means once string is created
they cannot be changed or manipulated if
we use a string hello they are are
stored in a memory location like this 0
1 2 3 4 are the addresses of the
locations where each character of the
string is stored now let's move on to
creating strings there are two methods
of creating string string literal method
and using new operator this is the
syntax of string on the screen first
string type then variable name is equal
to sequence of characters in double
quotes this is called as string lit
method for new operator method we use
new operator and value of string is
given in the brackets now let's see a
simple program to understand the use of
strings with Java code let's create a
new project file new project next take
the box next I'm going to name it as
strings and for the base package I'm
going to name it as string as well
because all the programs I'm going to do
in this package for
Strings we have our main program right
here the main class now before importing
the strings we need to import some
pre-process of directives so for this
for this I'm going to import Java do iio
input output. star star means everything
inside the directive and I'm going to
import java. lang. Star this means I can
do all the operations that is needed for
Strings so there are two ways to declare
string this is the first one string s is
equal to Simply learn now we have a
string s and it contains the value
simply learn now I'm going to print this
system.out.print Ln plus s or I'm going
to name it as string I'll print string
first is equal to and then I'm going to
print this so double codes string is
equal to and plus s so let's run this
program and there we go we have string
is equal to Simply learn so it took the
value of s and printed that so let's see
the next type of string how we can
declare the
string Str Str is equal to new string
simply learn so this is the second
method how we can declare a string or
assign the values to string so to print
it I'm going to use string 2 is equal to
and then Plus St Str so let's execute
this as
well and and as you can see we have
string 2 is equal to Simply learn as
well so this mean both the methods are
to declare strings or to assign values
to the strings so you can use any of
them I prefer using first so it's easy
that's why you don't need to write new
and string so let's move on to the new
topic classes and strings we all know
that strings are immutable now what if
we want to change something inside the
string then we use these methods to
manipulate strings in Java first one is
string Builder the string builder in
Java represents a mutable sequence of
characters it is an alternative to
string class as it creates a mutable
sequence of characters next is string
buffer string represents fixed length
immutable characters of sequences while
string buffer represents growable and
writable character sequences it will
automatically grow to make room for
additions like appending inserting and
deleting next we have string tokenizer a
string tokenizer object internally
maintains a current position within the
string to be tokenized some operations
Advance this current position past the
characters processed string tokenizer
class in Java is used to break a string
into tokens a token is returned by
taking a substring of the string that
was used to create the string tokenizer
object now let's see different methods
for functions that can be done on
strings in Java we have lot of methods
or functions in strings these are few of
the the methods that are used by
programmers frequently and we will be
using in this series of our Java
tutorial next let's have a look at a
program where we are going to reverse a
string and compare to string this is
going to be an interesting program and
you will be able to understand string a
lot better so let's get started so first
we'll see how to compare two strings and
then we'll see how to reverse a string
so let's create a new project file new
project let's click on next take the box
next I'm going to name it as compare and
reverse because I'm going to do both the
programs in the same program and we have
our main function here to use some
classes or to use some methods we need
to import some of the strings from java
so I'm going to import strings do
compare compare dot string
compare so let's write our code code
here so I'm going to use four strings
first string S1 is equal to then I'm
going to use new string and I'm inside
it I'm going to name the string as
simply
learn S capital and for the next string
string S2 is equal to new
string uh let's give it as practice for
the third string S3 new string let's
give it a study and for the four fourth
string we are going to match the third
string to show all the outputs that's
possible study now we are going to
display some output using the function
equals so what equals does is it it
compare two strings so first I'm going
to use it make it as user friendly by
writing comparing string one and then
comparing string two and then semicolon
so that everything will be separated you
can easily find out what the result will
be and then this is the main part S1 do
equals and in the bracket S2 because we
are comparing S1 and S2 so S1 do equal
S2 so this function automatically checks
whether S1 is equal to
S2 now same thing we are going to do
with string S3 and string S4 again this
user friendly S3 and
S4 semicolon s 3 dot = S4 we know that
S1 is not equal to S2 but S3 is
definitely equal to S4 so let's try it
with one more sentence so that we can
compare one more string so I'm going to
compare S1 and S4 so I'll copy paste it
and instead of S3 I'll write S1 and same
I'll do with S1 do equal S4 so let's run
this program oh before running we have a
error here so I'm going to delete that
inut import because we have not used it
so now let's run the program and yes we
have a result comparing simply learn and
practice is false that's definitely
false study and study both strings are
matching so it's true and simply learn
and study they don't match that's why
it's false so let's get started with our
second program that's reversing a string
so I'm going to delete everything from
here and I'm going to write same code
here only so first I need to assign a
variable of
string string input equals I'll name it
as simply learn and this is the main
part guys we use string Builder because
the string is immutable and as we
discussed earlier string Builder allows
us to do manipulation so I'll use one
more variable input one and new string
Builder so in input one we can do any
manipulation that we require so first
I'm going to do input 1 dot dot append
so that I can do operations that I want
on it either reversing or deleting or
concat so I'll take append of input and
lastly input 1 is equal to input 1 do
reverse this function reverse the string
that is there in input
one now to print the value of the
reverse
string the reverse string is and then
input one so here's the catch guys we
have to use string Builder so that we
can do menu ulations inside the string
if we don't use string builder then we
will get an error that unable to
manipulate the string or unable to
reverse the string so string Builder is
the main thing here so that we can do
all the operations that we want either
reversing or concat or deleting anything
from the string or deleting an element
or adding anything to the string so all
that happens because of string Builder
so now let's run this
program
and there we go we have a result the
reverse string is the reverse of Simply
learn now let's try it with something
that is palindrome so we have our
language malum if we reverse this we'll
get malum so this is kind of palindrome
string and see the result the reverse
string is also malum so this is how you
reverse a string so this brings us to
the end of this video we learned about
strings the functions for Strings and
the method meths we use in strings and
lastly we learn how to compare two
strings and how to reverse two strings
so as I described earlier that array is
basically a container which can store
values or a sequence of values or
sequence of numbers or sequence of
characters into itself we can think of
it as a box which can store all the
values in a continuous fashion as you
can see here this is a just a pictorial
representation and this is coming from
the official Java docs and you can see
that we if we create an array of size 10
then we have these 10 blocks created
here you can see 1 to 10th so the whole
length of boxes the number of boxes here
are 10 but the way arrays are designed
is that the index index is basically
used to access the element in this
particular box the index of the boxes
start from zero so it goes from 0 to 9
so remember the array length is 10 it
array the array can contain 10 elements
but the index of the array starts with
zero and will always end at length minus
1 which is 10 - 1 in this case which
comes as 9 so it will always be length -
one it will always start the index will
always start from zero and go till
length minus one length can be anything
in this case the length is 10 so the
index ends at 9 if the length was 20 the
last index will be 19 but in total you
have these 10 memory locations we also
call them as continuous memory locations
because they are continuously placed and
aray basically blocks 10 memory
locations and creates a container over
it so this is how an array basically
looks like inside the memory and uh
whenever you want to access the elements
of the array you will say array of zero
or array of one or array of two you
basically need to specify the index to
access the element at index for example
if you want to access the element which
is sitting in this box you need to say
array of index 8 and we'll see how we
can do that but this is the basic uh
understand understanding and idea of the
concept of arrays so let's try to
understand this with the help of an
example I will switch back to Eclipse
IDE and I've created a very simple
program here to demonstrate the
functionality of arrays here so we
already covered in the previous lecture
of what is package and what is public
and what is class how do we give the
class name and what is the meaning of
this particular method so I'm not going
to cover that again we'll start directly
from here so here the first thing which
I'm doing is I'm declaring an array of
integer this is a variable name the
identifier basically it can be anything
and this is the data type it's an
integer array and as we as we covered
this as well that whenever you put
square bracket in front of a data type
it becomes an array data type so this is
an integer array representation now we
just declared an array but we still
haven't allocated a size to it so you
can do that with this particular uh
syntax so you can put the variable name
of the array and say new int and put the
right size here this size can be
anything and once you do this now array
will actually allocate those memory
boxes which we covered here the moment
you do new int 10 this box these boxes
continuous boxes will be placed in the
memory and the memory is allocated to
this array we call this memory
allocation this is how you allocate
memory to the array so we allocated
memory to this array for storing 10
integers the next thing is now we can
start storing elements in those boxes so
like I said that the array index always
starts with zero so if you have to store
the first element you actually have to
store it at index zero location so you
give the array name you provide these
square brackets and you put the index
value within the square brackets that is
how you basically point to a particular
element inside the array so we say an
array of zero and we put the value 100
then we initialize the second element
which will be index one then will be the
third element which will be index 2
fourth element index 3 Fifth Element
index 4 Sixth Element index 5 and so on
until we store till the last element so
this is the 10th element which is
accessible as index 9 and the value is
1,000 basically so from 100 to th000 we
stored 10 values in this array and we
stored them by accessing the index and
this is actually the only way you can
store values in the array by pointing to
the indexes so we go from 0 to 9 and we
stored all the values 0er being the
first element and array of 9 being the
last and the 10th element remember the
length minus one concept okay so now we
will try to print all the elements one
by one that's pretty much what we are
doing now so as we covered in the
previous lecture that we use
system.out.println to print anything and
we understood the whole meaning of this
so I'm not going to repeat that now uh
we want to print the first element the
first element is sitting at index zero
and we can access that element with this
syntax by providing the variable name
and the actual index value so I'm just
writing a random string here which says
elemented index index0 and then I'm
putting this plus here and putting the
variable name this plus is basically
used to concatenate the output of a
static string with a random variable or
basically you can print anything uh with
using plus plus is used for
concatenation so I'm just trying to
print this whole value but here this is
a string value which is a static string
and then I have a value coming from the
array so whenever you have to print some
value from a particular data type or
variable or elction then you can use
this plus syntax to concatenate a string
static string with your actual value so
that's what I've done here by saying
plus and array zero and similarly for
index one I'm printing the the first
index then for two three so far and so
on so forth till the index 9 so
basically I'm just printing the all the
values of the array starting from index0
to index 9 so that's all which which is
written in this program now let's try to
run this program so I will right click
go to run as and go to Java application
and hit on this and now if I just expand
this console you can see all the
system.out.print and statements have
been executed and they printed this so
this is the static string part in fact
including the colon this is the static
string part element and index zero
printing exactly as is and then
dynamically the zeroth index element of
an array is printed here similarly we
have printed the index one location
element index 2 location element index 3
location element and so on so forth till
the index 9 location element so in total
these are the 10 elements but the index
always works from 0 to length minus 1 in
this case it will be going from 0 to 9
so this is basically all which I wanted
to cover in this lecture the whole idea
was to give you more understanding of
arrays and remember this is just just an
integer array you can similarly create a
character array you can also create a
string array for uh for you as well so
it it it's completely uh it's completely
uh related to the data type you're using
if you create a car array then you can
only store characters into it if you
create a string array then you can only
store strings into it and now you can
probably relate back to this particular
thing which I explained in the previous
lecture that we create this string array
for the reason that when you run this
particular program and if you want to
provide any command line values command
line arguments to the program those
arguments will automatically be stored
in this args and then you can access
this as args of zero args of 1 Etc in
your program that's the whole concept
let's get started with understanding
arrays in detail we have been talking
about arrays throughout this course of
java in the previous sessions as well
and we have covered some basic
understanding of how to create arrays
how to declare them how to fill values
in the array and how do we print the
array with positions as well as the
array as whole but whatever examples
which we took previously were
onedimensional arrays because arrays can
have more than one Dimensions as well
you can create a onedimensional array
you can create a two-dimensional array
you can create even a three dimensional
array and you can go up to as many
dimensions as you can handle in your
Java program so it depends upon the kind
of complexity you want to have in your
program and the kind of values the kind
of structure you're are going to store
in your arrays and based on that need
you can choose whether you want to use a
1D array or onedimensional array or a 2d
array or a 3D array and so on in these
sessions we are going to talk about 1D
arrays 2D arrays and 3D arrays and after
that we leave up to you to try out more
dimensionals if you want to we have
already covered the basic array
structures which were onedimensional
arrays so I will just give you a quick
walk through of how we actually handled
one-dimensional arrays so this is a
sample program to demonstrate
onedimensional arrays if you remember
this is how we use to create arrays we
write the data type of the array and
then we write the square boxes which
denote that this is an integer array
data type we assign a variable to this
and then we initialize the array with
the size four so new is the keyword
which is used to initialize anything in
Java and and we are going to use this
heavily when we talk about classes and
objects and even collections literally
any object which you want to create in
Java requires a new keyword so here I'm
writing new and then int 4 which means
create an array of size 4 and then I'm
filling the value of the four positions
which I have created as part of this
array and if you remember when we create
these kind of arrays we store them in a
zero index based position the first
value getss stored at zeroth index
position and then so on so forth so it
will always start from zero and never
start from one remember that and after
that we just print all the values of
individual positions of the elements in
the array and if I just run this program
all of the elements of this particular
array should be printed one by one so if
I just show the full console of the
output we can see that elemented index 0
was 10 elemented index 1 was 20 element
at index 2 was 30 and element at index 3
was 40 so this was just a quick
refresher of how onedimensional arrays
can be written and whenever you declare
a very simplistic array it will
generally be a onedimensional array now
let's look at the twood dimensional
arrays and how do we write them when do
we need them for that I have created
another example which is says twood
dimensional array I just created a class
and it has a public static void main
method and I've created a two
dimensional array this time so let's
understand this two dimensional array in
a bit detail and when do we need that
generally you would need to use two
dimensional arrays whenever you are
trying to do any Matrix calculations if
you if you understand what do you mean
by matrix it's basically a 2X two
structure which stores the values in the
form of rows and columns so imagine a
table of two rows and two columns then
it will be a 2x2 matrix so if you want
to store that particular table in a Java
program you would need to store that as
a matrix as a two-dimensional Matrix
rows being the one dimensional and
column beings the other dimension and
that's what we are doing here and if you
want to store that 2D Matrix in a Java
program the approach and the procedure
for it is pretty similar to how you
create a onedimensional array with
slight changes the first change is
instead of a single square bracket
you're going to write two square
brackets because it is a two-dimensional
array so remember the number of square
brackets you are going to put while
initializing and declaring the array is
the number of Dimensions which your
array is going to have since this is a
two-dimensional array example that's why
you see two brackets here if this was a
three-dimensional array example you will
see three array three square brackets
here and so on so forth so that's the
first part of it second part to
understand is to how to store the data
remember remember I told you always
imagine the structure of rows and
columns whenever you are trying to store
a two-dimensional array in Java so what
are rows and what are values and how do
you represent them while you declare and
initialize a two-dimensional array so
you start with the curly braces as a
normal 1D array but inside the curly
braces you create nested curly braces
blocks you can see three blocks here
they start with their own curly brace
and end with their own then this curly
bra starts here and ends here and then
this curly brace starts here and ends
here idea is that you provide this outer
curly braces to define the overall
structure and then inside each of the
curly braces is going to represent a row
in your two-dimensional array so each of
these values this blocks is going to
represent a row so I can say that this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and if I try
to visualize it in terms of columns then
this is the first row First Column first
row second column First Row Third column
similarly second row First Column second
row second column second row third
column and third row First Column third
row second column and third row third
column so individual values are going to
be represented as columns and the whole
curly Braes is going to be represented
as arrays that's the basic mental idea
or mental image you should have while
declaring a twood dimensional arrays
remember to declare the rows inside the
nested curly braces and whatever
elements you have will automatically be
indexed as columns another thing to
remember that since this is an array
data structure everything starts from
zero and nothing starts from one so this
will be row 0er this will be Row one and
this will be row two I'm talking about
the position we can still call it as
first row second row and third row but
the position of this particular row
element is zero the position of this
particular row element is one and this
particular row element is two similarly
for column as well this is column 0o
column 1 and column two similarly column
0 column 1 and column two and so on so
forth once you understand this data
structure well and you have defined it
correctly then everything should fall in
place if you want to do a matrix
addition or if you want to do a a matrix
multiplication or a dott product all of
the kind of calculations can be
performed using the 2D array concept
here in this program what I'm doing is I
am printing the values of this
particular 2D array into a matrix style
and you see some strange code here which
is for ETC don't worry about this I'm
going to cover in detail what this four
means and how do you write this for now
what we can understand that we just want
to print this you might not need to
print this in your Java programs when
you write a production grid application
but you might want to do manipulations
on these uh arrays as Matrix maybe you
want to create a transpose of a matrix
or you want to do a DOT product or
addition or subtraction or whatever be
your use case in this case just for
demonstration purpose I'm printing the
values as rows and columns nothing else
so this all of this code from line 8 to
line 14 or in fact line 13 is just
showing how to print the values you can
see some some system.out and you can see
some construct here and like I said
don't worry about this I will cover this
in detail let's run this program and see
if my Java array is stored correctly and
how can I represent this so you can see
I have represented it in a style of a 2d
Matrix where this is the first row this
is the second row and this is the third
row similarly this is the First Column
containing the value 237 so column 0
will have value two and column 1 will
have this value three and column 2 will
have this value 7 for row zero let me
also do something here which can help
you understand this concept better let
me do a system.out.println and let's
print an individual value because like I
said the for Loop can be confusing here
to understand so let's say I want to
print ARR of zeroth row First Column and
see what kind of values do we get let me
comment this code comment is control
back slash and this code will be
commented and this code will not be
executed and now only line 15 will be
executed instead of the four block so if
I run this I get the value seven so row
0er and First Column row 0er First
Column is seven let's try with 1 one I
want to print the row at Z one position
remember not the first row but the one
position row which is basically
technically the second row so second row
second column and see what kind of
values value do I get in this case I get
six so second row second column
similarly if you change this value to
two then third row second column which
should point to four yes we get four
similarly you can write a value here as
zero and you can write a value here as
let's say two this will print the zeroth
row and the second column so similarly
whatever kind of value you want to write
you or you want to access you can access
it in this fashion and remember the
column and row index X will always start
from zero so this is a simple
demonstration of how you can use two
dimensional arrays and in this session
we also did a refresher of
onedimensional array let's get started
with how to create and use a
three-dimensional array or how to go
about using multi-dimensional arrays in
Java so as you can see from this image
we talked about 1D array which is having
just one axis then we talked about 2D
arrays in the last session where we had
rows and columns basically an x-axis and
a y axis and then we can also have a 3D
array which will have three axises which
will have an X axis a y AIS and also a z
AIS think of a simple box which every
box in this world will always have at
least three dimensions and from from
here you can go even build more complex
arrays which can have four dimensions or
five Dimensions or as many dimensions
as you want it to have and today we are
going to look at an example of how can
we build a 3D array and how do we access
those elements but this picture is just
to show you the mental model of when you
will be creating a 3D array so for
example generally an image data is
stored in in three dimensions so you can
you might want to store the image data
into a 3D array and there can be many
other use cases in the mathematical and
research computational use cases where
you might want to use a 3D array so but
remember there's an X axis there's a y-
axis and then there is a third axis
which is called The Zed axis so let us
look at a Java program to understand how
we can build a three-dimensional array
and for that I have created this class
which is called multi-dimensional array
it has a entrypoint method which is the
public static void main method and then
I have created an integer array and and
this time instead of one or two square
brackets I have three square brackets
and if you remember I mentioned this in
the previous session as well the number
of square brackets which you're going to
put while initializing the array is the
number of dimensions of the array and
since in this particular program I'm
going to demonstrate a three-dimensional
array that's why you see three square
box boxes let me just minimize this y so
we have three square boxes here and we
have created the variable name as a r r
or short form as aray then we start with
the outermost curly braces as is then we
put another curly braces which starts
from here and it ends here then another
set of curly brace which starts from
here and end here so this is the this is
the First Dimension this is the second
dimensions and these are the third
dimensions that's how you're are going
to define the different dimensions
remember this is the First Dimension
when the first curly brace starts then
you have the second dimension which
covers this hole and this hole and then
you have third dimension which are these
so that's how you're going to visualize
and and put the three dimensions in use
while declaring a three-dimensional
array and the values work in the same
fashion it's it's a zero index based
position so since we do not have an
official name for the third dimension so
I'm just going to use x axis y axis and
Z axis to refer to the three axises so
this would be X of 0 this would be y of
0 and this would be Z of 0 similarly X
of 1 y of 1 and Z of 1 and so on so
forth so now if I try to access the
value which is at zeroth X position
first y position and second Z position
what's the value do we get here let's
run this program and understand and
interpret the output okay uh so when we
ran this program we got the output as 11
so let's understand this output so when
we say the zeroth position on X the
first position on Y and the second
position on Zed so this is the zeroth
position on X and this is the first
position on Y and then this element is
012 is the second position on the Z axis
so to to describe it in a nutshell this
defines the xaxis so we have two
elements on the x-axis here this one and
this one then we have two elements on
the y- axis on each x-axis so this is
one this is two on the first x- axis and
this is one and this is two on the
second y second x-axis so 2 x and 2 Y
and then on the Z axis I have three
elements each so hope this helps you
understand and visualize this so x-axis
and this one is other xaxis and then y
AIS y axis and then elements inside this
are Z axis so I'm saying zero with
x-axis in this block first on the y-
axis which is this block and then second
element or the Z or second position
element on this particular a in this
particular block which is 11 and that's
why we get 11 if I print zero let's say
I I change this particular value as one
so now the output should be coming from
this side so second X position because
it's one second y position so this will
go here and then the two position which
is the third element of the Z axis which
is 13 so let's see if we get 13 yes we
get 13 here so this is just to show you
how you can interpret this particular
array and always be mindful of how you
are structuring this array if your
structure is gone wrong then your
program will become useless and it will
give you a lot of unpredictable outputs
which might not make sense and which may
introduce errors in your program so be
very careful how you define the
structure of the elements here that's
the key and after that you just need to
understand the x axis the y axis and the
Zed axis always remember all the aises
start from zero so when I say two I'm
basically referring to the third element
and not the second element so this is
all I wanted to cover in this particular
particular session where we describe how
we can use a three-dimensional array and
from here you can go to any lens like I
said you can add more square brackets
here and go to four dimension or five
dimension or six Dimension but remember
the more Dimensions you add the more
complexity of the program will be having
the program will become more and more
difficult to debug and understand so
always try to take a wise call as to how
many dimensions you want to use in your
array and software developers need to
stay up to dat cre on the latest
advancements regarding the tools
Frameworks programming languages and
apps to achieve success Master the
latest coding tools strategies and
techniques through simply learn software
development process by enrolling in any
of these certification programs you will
gain expertise in skills like agile Java
devops HTML 5 CSS 3 AWS JavaScript es6
soap and rest and GSP with hands-on
experience in tools like angular mongod
DB you will catch the ey of top
recruiters so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll now a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses you can find the course
Link in the description box below and
pin comment welcome to this tutorial on
objects and classes in Java this is a
part of our Java tutorial Series where
we will be covering everything you need
to know to master Java let us look at
what we will cover today first we will
talk about objects and we will Implement
two programs on intellig to learn about
objects then we will move on to classes
in Java where we will see an advanced
program to learn classes more in depth
so what are objects an object is an
instance of a class let's have a look at
an example in this example animal is a
class and dog is its object the object
dog has States and behaviors we can have
dogs with different breeds sizes and
colors these are considered as the
states of object dog on Behavior side
dog has Behavior like barking eating and
wagging tail so an object has its own
States and behaviors now let's look at
an example using Java code there are
many platforms to run Java program so
for this video I'll be using intellig so
let's create a new project let's name it
as project one and finish there we go we
have a new project with we have a class
with Main and we have a main function so
the code that we write should always be
written in the main function so let's
create a new class to understand how the
object is used let's name it as student
we need variables so that we can access
the variables of this class so I'm going
to use student ID with the integer type
student
name and students
age there we go now we have these three
variables that we can use so let's go to
our main program and start our coding so
we have a class named student now let's
see how to create a object of a class
this is the syntax to create object now
the object here is s I created a object
s of class student now let's assign
values to the variables for this we use
the object s and use the dot operator
and we have options from which we can
choose from that we declared in the
class student so for this I'll use ID
and give a value similarly I'll give age
and give a value and finally let's give
a
name now we'll print its
value now we are going to run this
program let's see what output we'll
get and there it is we have name that's
simply learn we have age and we have ID
now let us see an example how we can use
multiple objects for a single class so
let's get started let's create a new
project and I'm going to name it as
Vehicles because I'm going to use cars
and bikes in this program so I'm going
to use Vehicles as a combined form and
yes here we have a class Main and a
function main now I need two classes for
this program so I'm going to create two
classes first I'm going to name name it
as bikes and the second class I'm going
to name it as cars so let's create
variables for these classes so in car
first I need string name and I need the
cost of the car so cost can be integer
as well because I'm going to use dollar
sign in that so I'm going to use string
because of that so same thing I'm going
to do with
bikes now that our classes are created
let's create objects for this class so
the process is same but we are going to
use different names for the object first
the car class and I'm going to name as
car 1 and yes we have created the first
object Now to create the second object
similarly I'm going to create five
objects of the Class Cars and I'm going
to change the name for them so I created
five objects of the same class so I'm
going to create five objects of the
bike's class as well so B one will be a
bit longer so I'm going to use B1 till
B5
and I'm going to name them to from B1 to
B5 so now I'm going to assign values to
the variables that I created in classes
bike and cars so first I'm going to go
with cars and let's name it as
Lamborghini similarly car to
Ferrari so I'm going to use names of the
cars that are very famous and costly so
that anyone over the world can
understand this so let's name car
3 I'm going to name it as
Bugatti similarly car
4 Pagani and car
five now I'm going to give names for
bikes I hope everyone will understand
the names that I
give
B4 and B5 last one
Yamaha now let's assign the cost for
bikes and cars as well so the procedure
is same so let's do it
130,000 same B2 so B1 goes for Harley
Davidson B2 for ducatti B3 for Suzuki B4
for Eos and B5 for Yamaha I'm going to
assign values for these values
accordingly for ducatti
$232,000 for Suzuki
$200,000
300,000 and the last one Yamaha
500,000 now similarly I'm going to
assign values for car 1. cost till card
5.
cost
$23,000 for Lambo I think I can copy
paste these as well so let's copy paste
it will a lot faster and easier to
do Car 2 car three car 4 and car 5 we
don't need this uh as per car2 let's
take it as
252,000
and uh let's make it at 3
million uh as for this let's keep it as
million 400,000 and lastly uh let's take
as 293 now that we have assigned all the
values for all this now let's print it
and get the value I'm going to create a
very simple program but a very
userfriendly program so it it's going to
be interesting for you guys so we are
going to ask the users what would they
like either bikes or cars so we need to
give them the options and our next
program will be based on the options
that the user select not the options we
give as the command so let's do
it let's give the options one
bikes and two cars I need to take the
value that user gives for this I'm going
to write this
command so I have not used scanner yet
so let's import
scanner and let's create a object for
scanner and yes let's get back so the
data type of choice variable is integer
that's why I'm using next int if the
data type was string then I would have
used next line so now that we have
Choice from the user let's use this
value if the user chooses the first
value that means bikes so the next thing
we display is we have models and we're
going to give five models for bikes to
the
user here I'm giving options to the
users so that they can choose easily
from number 1 to
5 now we can show these options to the
users so that they can choose from one
of these value so let's use one more if
statement so that we can find out
whether they have this value or not
before that I'm going to ask which one
would you like to
choose to enter the choice I'm going to
use one more variable let's say n so I'm
going to store
n if n is equal to equal to 1 that means
har devidson then I'm going to show the
cost of har
idson this is the syntax to print the
value for the cost or any of the
variable that we use in
class what if the user says second or
third or fourth or fifth so for that we
are going to use else if statement
if n is 2 that means ducatti so we have
to show the rate of ducatti or the cost
of ducatti to the
user now similarly I'm going to do for n
is = 3 n isal 4 and N is =
5 now I'm going to do for n isal
4 and lastly n is equal to 5 that is our
last bike
Yamaha what if the users put a number
that is not between 1 to 5 so for that
I'm going to use l statement and put a
message that please enter the value from
1 and
five so so now we have code for the
bikes and the same thing what if the
user selects that he wants to find the
car so for that we have this the choice
is equal to is equal to 1 so the same
thing we are going to do for choice is
equal to is equal to
2 and the same thing we're going to tell
to user that we have five
models the same names that I gave to
variables I'm going to give this to
here
second one
Ferrari third
bukari fourth
EOS and the last one
posch now we are going to ask the users
their choice that which number do they
want to
choose now we need one more value so
that we can have it as a variable which
can store the choice of the user so for
this I'm going to use
C now if C is equal to equal to 1 that
means if the user wants to see the cost
of Lamborghini that he puts the choice
as one so we're going to display this
message the cost of
Lamborghini and we are going to use else
if Loop to enter the next values for C
from 1 to 5 if C is equal to is equal to
two that means the user wants to know
the rate of Ferrari then we are going to
show the cost of the
Ferrari same thing if the user enters
three as the
choice if user enters four as the choice
then we go for
Eos
and the last one if user enters the
choice as five then we have to display
the cost of
Posh now what if the user enters none of
the values from 1 to 5 then we have to
display a message showing that please
enter the
value between 1 to 5
now remember the first choice that we
wanted from user to enter either bikes
or cars so what if the user do not enter
either one or two so for that we need
one more else function to tell the user
that either enter one or
two and with this we have completed our
code so now let's run this program for
this we need to go to run and then run
main there's a shortcut for it that is
shift plus F10 so let's run the program
and yes we have successfully executed
the program Let's test this program now
so enter your choice I'm going to enter
one and yeah we have five models Halid
Davidson ducatti Suzuki Pagani and
Yamaha so enter your choice I'm going to
enter one and yeah we have a result the
cost of har idson is
$130,000 so with this we have completed
our code and please feel free to type
this code in your own computer and try
out all the mentation and combinations
that you can with this program so with
this let's move on to classes and
understand the classes and their concept
then we'll have a new program on classes
now let's see what is a Class A Class is
a blueprint from which objects are
created a class describ state or
behavior of an object in this example
dog is a class the variables in this
class are breed and color the functions
or methods of the class dog are barking
hungry and sleeping we use objects of a
class to to use variables and functions
of that class with this let's understand
classes with a simple Java code let's
create a new
project next tick the box and let's name
it as
automobiles let the base package be
student and yes we have a class main now
let's create some classes to do code
on I'll create a new Java class as cars
and then I'll create one more class with
the name
bikes and then one more class
automobiles so I'm going to connect cars
and bikes with automobiles so that we
can use that program in Main and see
what can we do with the classes that we
create in automobiles I need some
variables I'll take private double and
let's say fuel and then same thing
private double and then ear and let's
take one more private string and brand
now let's have Getters and Setters for
this so these are used to get the value
and set the value for the variables
inside the class there we go we have the
Getters and Setters for it now let's go
to class cars so public Class Cars
extends
automobiles so in it I'm going to create
one more class or a
Constructor and I'm going to print a
message say a new car has been created
car has been created now the same thing
I'm going to do with Bikes let's go to
bikes and I'm going to use the same
thing extends automobiles this is
because I can inherit all the variables
from the automobile's class so I created
a Constructor and I'm going to print a
message
a new bike has been
created so I have created Class Cars
bikes and Automobiles so let's go to
main program so this is where we should
write our code so I'm going to start
with the code now it's a very simple
code I'm going to first I'm going to
create the variables or the objects of
the class with
private bikes bike so so one is car and
one is bike both are objects for the
classes so I'm going to use this
objects bikes bike is equal to new
bike this is so that my object can
function really well and now I'm going
to run it it will take some time to
run and yes there we go our program has
executed and the things that I typed a
new car has been created a new bike has
been created are done now let's try
something else using the classes so I'm
going to bikes so I'm going to create a
new method or a new function public void
kick for bike so I'm going to print
message the bike has been started with
kick bike has been started with kick now
the same thing I'm going to do with car
now how does a car start with the key so
I'm going to make a function public key
and inside it I'm going to print the
same message car has been started with
key oh I should write void there to give
the return value as wide so let's print
the message car has been started with
key rotation let's write that as well so
in the main program I'm going to use
objects to use those functions and let's
see what changes they'll do to our
program pike. KCK and car. KCK let's run
this and there we go first we used to
have this two messages but now these two
messages are also there as well because
we invoked those functions and methods
that are there in class cars and bikes
so if I write bike. key or car. kick
this won't work this is because key is
not a method of bike or kick is not a
method of car so that's why I gave
private static for the functions so if I
execute it these are the error messages
that I'll get cannot find the symbol
method kick or method key what is
polymorphism according to chemistry the
term polymorphism can be defined as the
ability of any element or compound to
exist in multiple crystalline forms this
is called polymorphism for example if
you have the carbon atom you can come
out in different forms in coal graphite
and Diamond what is polymorphism in Java
similarly in the terms of Java
programming language polymorphism is
defined as the ability of any object in
CLA in a class to perform a particular
task in multiple methods this is known
as polymorphism in Java we're going to
open up our Eclipse editor and we're
going to do some animal sounds with cows
cats and dogs just kind of a fun almost
kids likee uh example of polymorphis M
and uh you can see I already have my
inheritance in here uh let's go ahead
and create a
new uh package and we'll call this
polymorphism just to keep it
simple and once we have our polymorphism
in there we're going to go ahead and add
a class
in and if you were doing um an abstract
class we can little B as abstract we're
not going to directly access it and
we'll call it animal sounds maybe we
will we'll see how we
uh load the um program app but we'll
call this animal
sounds and let's create a uh public um
it's not going to return anything but
we'll call it sound on here and we just
want to go ahead and have it do a uh
system out
print and with our system out print line
uh we'll just have it say
animals
make different
sounds there we go so it's really simple
and straightforward we're just going to
have it print something out and uh if
we're going to do that let's go ahead
and just um uh good thing I didn't make
it abstract let's go ahead and just test
it out and see what it looks like and
we'll do um we'll call it animal Main
Animal
Main and in here let's go ahead and test
out what we just put together uh we'll
do our our static void main so it's
going to run on here and we'll create
our
animal
sounds we'll call it animal because we
don't know what kind of animal this is
we'll call it new animal
sounds and we'll just take that animal
um and I like to we put it in capitalize
but usually we like do this lowercase
there we go and we'll just have
our
animal uh dot
sound and and let's go ahead and run
this and see what comes
out we can see here animals make
different sounds okay that's not too
exciting uh so let's jump in there and
let's say we have um in this case we're
going to add in a couple of different
animals uh we'll add in a oh let's start
with a cow yeah why not a cow um so
we'll have our cow in here we'll go
ahead and click
okay and now we have our cow class um
but a cow doesn't just it makes
different noises but it
actually makes a you know a very clear
noise so we'll go ahead and give the cow
a
sound and we'll have the cow um say
moooo and the cow is going
to
extend there's our um and we'll put in
our extends animal sounds and then I
want to go back here to our Animal Man
and now we have a class cow so in our
animal man we want to do uh
cow
cow equals
new
cow and once we've created the new cow
we also need to go ahead and have the
cow
sounds there we go and we run
this you can see it comes out here and
it says the cow says moo moo so if we go
back to Cow we're just going to do this
real quick and let's say um we just take
this out of here the public void sound
and then we're going to go into our
animal Main and run
that recompiles animals make different
sounds because it doesn't know what
sound a cow makes uh so this is really
Central to polymorphism is we're taking
something going on in the um in one
setup that we've brought in and extended
from our animal sounds and we've changed
it to the cow says moo moo and we can
also add in multiple animals in here
we'll go ahead and just add in one more
animal uh we'll call this one we'll do a
dog why
not uh so here comes in our
dog and of course we want the dog uh to
actually say
something and we'll have the dog uh go
bowwow and then we'll go back to our
animal main we have to create a dog and
we'll say h
cow simply dog dog uppercase for the
class lower case for the actual object
and then of course we need the dog to
make a sound so we'll go down here and
go dog dot
sound and when we run this as you expect
the uh it's going to compile it there we
go animals makeing different sounds the
cow says moo moo the dog says Bow
Wow characteristics of polymorphism the
functionality of a method behaves
differently in different situations the
behavior of a method is dependent on the
data polymorphism is mainly used to
implement inheritance as we saw we did
the extends with the animal sounds
polymorphism is mainly used to implement
inheritance it allows same name for a
member of method in a class with
different types which we'll cover
briefly in a minute polymorphism
supports implicit type conversion types
of polymorphism there are basically two
types of polymorphism that can be
occurred in Java programming language
they are are mentioned as follows
compile time polymorphism runtime
polymorphism compile time polymorphism
gets executed during the compilation
stage here the overloading method gets
resolved in compilation stage so when
you saw me run those in eclipse and it
went through the compile time that's
looking at all the different changes we
made to those classes that's what we're
talking about here is during compile
time in method overloading in Java the
process of method overloading is
achieved when a class has two or more
methods with same name but the specific
method is selected based on the number
of parameters declared we'll now execute
a program based on the functionality of
additional operator in a different
situation and let's flip back on over to
our Eclipse so in here I'm going to go
back under the dog and uh let me just
highlight this and we're going to do the
same thing so you see right here it says
public void sound so this is identical
public void sound but instead of sending
uh nothing we're going to send it a
string we're going to call it Angry now
at this point you should note that what
if it's a happy dog I would have to add
an if then if the string angry said
happy then we'd print happy or something
else um but we're just keeping it simple
so we've entered another sound identical
to the first but we've added string
angry to it and this one's going to
print out the dog says growl growl now
if we go back to our animal Main and
here's our dog same dog uh same sound
but now we're going to add a string in
here and we put that string in here
we'll go ahead and just call it Angry it
doesn't really matter what string you
put in here because we haven't sorted
out what the string means uh for now it
just says uh grow growl it's going to
recompile it so remember this is a
polymorphism during compile time and
here we have it the dog says grow grow
so the dog says bowwow and then the
angry dog says grow grow so there is
another um thing called Operator
overloading Operator overloading is not
supported in Java authors of java wanted
to keep the language less
complicated explaining operator
overloading it basically is a way of
bundling operations into the call
statement and user procedures it's so
that it looks like a math on a paper you
have a plus add B plus C kind of thing
and it's all wrapped up in your call to
another statement this just gets
confusing and it really isn't necessary
so the Java developers decided not to
put it in there so runtime polymorphism
in Java programming language runtime
polymorphism gets handled during the
program execution stage here the
overwriting method gets resolved in
execution so far we've talked about
compile time polymorphism as you saw in
the program we just wrote when it's
compiling it does the extend and figures
out which overload method to use on
there in runtime polymorphism method
overwriting in Java the method
overwriting is a procedure where child
class is allowed to implement a specific
class that is already provided in the
parent class for runtime compilation
code or polymorphism we need to go ahead
and introduce the super key word now
from inheritance you should remember
that we can uh look at Super from before
but we're going to use it slightly
different it's kind of doing the same
thing as when we did The Inheritance but
we're doing like what they call an
override during runtime so the term
super is predefined keyword in Java that
is used to refer the immediate parent
class object or method defined in the
program in this procedure whenever you
create an instance of subass then
automatically an instance of parent
class is also created that will be
implicitly referred by the super
reference variable so going back into
our animal sounds let's go in here to
dog and if we add a super do
sound in here this is going to reference
whatever our extend is cuz we extends
the dog extends animal sounds and so
here's our super. sound and if we go
ahead and we run and compile this and
you can see here that it comes down and
it says the dog says growl growl because
that's what we had it um system out
print line to and then the super animals
make different sounds and so if we go
back to our animal main this is what
it's calling right here it's going back
into sound under the animal Mains and
it's printing out or doing whatever it
does here at this point we usually have
it returned something so you can look up
whatever um the original class was
using so getting back to uh these two
setups whether you're using the super to
use a runtime polymorphism because
that's what's happening during runtime
versus compile time polymorphism during
compile time polymorphism method call is
handled by the compiler itself so the
programs maybe take a second more to
compile but it runs faster in the run
time the method call cannot be handled
by compiler in the execution stage so if
you have any errors is not going to show
up either during the compile time we
have compile time polymorphism is less
flexible as it needs handle all method
calls in compile time so you really in
runtime polymorphism you're it exhibits
higher flexibility as a method call gets
handled at runtime coming in the
execution period for compile time
polymorphism is less U that's what I was
just talking about it compiles it so the
compiling takes maybe a little bit more
but if you're executing the same program
over and over over again once it's
distributed it's going to run faster
then of course with the runtime
polymorphism the execution period for
runtime polymorphism takes longer it's
just a little bit more usually in most
programs you don't notice this but if
you're executing the same script A
Thousand Times suddenly that 0.01 second
is a lot more it suddenly is adding up a
second each time it goes through the
Thousand iterations uh then with the
compile time polymorphism integrating
the right method call with the right
method is done in compile time and of
course in run time integrating the right
method call with the right method is
done in runtime again that's another
delay because it has to figure out what
it's doing it's not already pre-mapped
out and finally compile time
polymorphism occurs during method
overloading and operator overloading
where runtime polymorphism occurs during
the method overwriting advantages of
polymorphism programmer code can be
reused via polymorphism number one goal
of a programmer is to reuse the code as
much as possible so you're not
Reinventing the will over and over again
advantages of polymorphism supports
single variable name for multiple data
types reduces coupling between different
functionalities and some of the
disadvantages of polymorphism that can
come up is that polymorphism ends up
raising performance issues in real time
uh you can see where as you're loading
all these different things you might end
up creating Loops you didn't know you
were doing polymorphism reduces
readability of the code uh sometimes
you're actually code everything you look
at in Java is polymorphism all based on
a primary object so you could have a
very complicated setup and then actually
very easy to read when you actually put
it your final variable in there but when
you're going through lines and lines of
code it can be really hard to uh figure
out what's going on as you Loop through
all these different inherited modules or
classes programmers find polymorphism
difficult to implement just depends the
more you use it the easier it is let's
see the definition of encapsulation
encapsulation is like a capsule the
whole code and data is bounded together
into a single unit another way to think
about encapsulation is it is a
protective shield that prevents the data
from being accessed by the code outside
this Shield as you can see variables and
methods are defined inside one class
like a capsule now the question is why
do we need encapsulation the main
reasons are first better control of
class attributes and methods second
class attributes can be made read only
or write only third it makes Java code
very flexible this means the programmer
can change one part of the code without
affecting other parts apart from these
encapsulation is mainly used to protect
data and increase security of the code
as you can see to protect the data
variables must be private and they can
only be accessed through methods now
let's see Java code for encapsulation to
understand the concept better so now
let's create a new
project
next next and I'm going to name it as
NCAP
1 so here we have a main class we can
write the code here so before writing
the code let me create a new
class right click new Java class and I'm
going to name it as employee
so in this program we are going to use a
classic example of employee using
employee Name ID and salary so in this
class let me create
variables first string
name
then integer
ID and then int
salary so I can easily use these
variables in a main program by creating
object of the class so let me just
create the
object employeee is equal to new
employee now I can use e do ID name or
salary anything I need to but this
program is about encapsulation so this
is an easy program we can do but in
order to secure our programs when we
have a large number of program and large
number of lines in a program so we need
encapsulation at that time so that data
can be secure y so for that I'm going to
name it as
private now all three variables are
private so I can't use them see we can't
see them anymore if I write
ID we'll get a red color here so if we
go on it we can see ID has private
access so that means we can't use it
directly because of this we need Getters
and Setters that are normal methods that
are used for these so right click
generate and here you can see Getters
and Setters so just select all of them
and okay so now we can use these methods
instead of direct using the variables so
we can get in the starting then set then
get and again set so likewise it goes
like this so now we have set here so if
I want to declare variable and if I want
to put some value inside my variable so
how can I do that here you can see get
ID or get salary so if I go for get ID
sorry if I go for E do set ID and I set
it as six so this shows no error this
means we can use methods to access
variables so let's complete our program
now first I'm going to set
everything and lastly e do set salary
let's get it as 30,000 maybe in dollars
or maybe in rupees let's just set it as
30,000 for now so how I'm going to print
it for this I'm going to go to a print
statement and then
name and E do not set name but this time
I'm going to go with get name get name
is to return the value of the name that
I have given so in this case that's
simply
learn and next will be
ID and E do get
ID and lastly
salary e do get
salary so this is a simple program that
is used to Define encapsulation if we
don't use private variables that becomes
a normal program so when we use
encapsulation we are going to use
private every time whenever we declare
variables so that it's secure and no one
can access the variables directly so now
let's run the
program and there we go we have our
result we have executed the program
successfully and as you can see name
simply learn ID 6 and salary is 30,000
so I hope you understood the concept of
encapsulation so the main concept of
encapsulation is all the variables can
be accessed through methods so for this
we we use Getters and Setters that are
inbuilt functions for intellig or net
beans or Eclipse so with this let's move
on to our next program to understand it
better and how we can manipulate these
variables or methods using program so
again let's create a new
project and this time I'm going to name
it as encapsulation 2 because it's the
second program for
encapsulation and here we have our main
program program now this time I'm going
to use an example of cars so let me just
create a new class and I'm going to name
it as
cars so in this again I'm going to
create three variables that are
private so first I'm going to get string
name then private string price that
means price of the
car and third
one top speed of the
car so we can create the program that we
did before as it is but I'm going to
explain you more in depth how we can
manipulate these variables or classes so
I'm going to create a Constructor for
the class
cars and inside I'm going to give it
as arguments as string
name then string
price and string top top
speed and I'm going to give it as this
do
name is equal to name this is so that
the class can identify that we are going
to give arguments related to that and
the class can return the values of it so
similarly I'm going to give it as this
do
price is equal to
price and
lastly this top speed is equal to to top
speed so with this we have completed our
Constructor for it now let's have
Getters and Setters for the same thing
for these three
variables so generate getter and Setter
select all and okay this is a great
feature that we have in Java getter and
sets otherwise we'll have to type the
whole code so with this let's move on to
our main
program we'll write the code here first
I'll create object of the Class
Cars and inside this I'm going to give
arguments or inside this I'm going to
give values that I use in Constructor to
assign the values without using any C.G
name or C.G price so my first was name
so let me just name it as
BMW the second thing was price so I'm
going to give it as $30,000
and the third one was top speed so top
speed I'm going to give it as 20000 km/
hour so we have assigned all the values
to the variables and we have created
object as well all in the same line so
this is another way of creating objects
or another way of assigning values to
the variables that are private so if I
try to print these they can be easily
printed
so in the starting name and C dot so
this time I'm going to give get name so
it automatically gets the value that I
assigned to the variables through
Getters and
Setters after that
price price C do price get
price and in the
end top
speed C do get top speed so if I print
this let's execute
it and there we go we have name BMW
price and even the top speed now if I
give spaces between them it will look
neatly so let me execute it once
more and here you go name BMW price
$30,000 and top speed 200 km/ hour so
this this is one of our ways how we can
declare variables or assign values to
the variables without using any gets or
Setter so in this method we used only
gets to print the value that we have for
variables now how can we manipulate the
variables if you want to change value of
them now for this again I can do set top
speed or set price let the name be as it
is so C do set price so price I'm going
to set it
as
$50,000 and C do set top speed let me
increase it to 250 km/
hour so before printing that I'm so that
we can differentiate which one is new
and which one is old I'm going to print
one more
line stats
after
updation so now if I print these Val
vales I'm just going to copy paste
it so now if I print it let's execute
it and here you go first we have name
price and top speed then stats after
updations that means after we set the
value the value gets over written on the
variables and now we have a new price
and top speed and all the details so
this is how you can manipulate variables
or values inside the variables what is
an abstract
class the answer is abstraction is one
of the keys to achieving an
object-oriented programming approach and
designing a
software here the programmer tries to
hide the complicated implementation of
the code which makes the software run
smoothly most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it to do so we use an
abstract class or sometimes an interface
based on the
requirement so abstract class in Java is
considered as a template of methods and
variables which are used in a program
remember abstract classes cannot be
instantiated directly now moving ahead
we will next learn the important
features of abstract
classes so the first one is template the
main reason programmers prefer to use
abstract methods is because they act as
a predefined template for any future
specific class that you might use next
loose coupling is a procedure where an
internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world that is other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible after that we have the code
reusability implementation of the
abstract classes provides the developer
with one of the greatest features that
saves time which is none other than the
code
reusability followed by code reusability
we have abstraction as discussed earlier
data abstraction is the process of
hiding certain details and showing only
essential information to the user
abstraction can be achieved with either
abstract classes or
interfaces last but not the least
Dynamic method resolution
the abstract classes enable us with
Dynamic method resolution or the dynamic
method dispatch process the dynamic
method resolution is a mechanism by
which a call to an overridden method is
resolved at runtime this is how Java
implements runtime polymorphism when an
overridden method is called by reference
Java determines which version of that
method to execute based on the type of
object refers
to now these were the few important
features of abstract classes next in the
docket is the crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes all
right let us go through the rules one by
one as mentioned
below the first one is the keyword
abstract is mandatory to declare an
abstract Clause followed by that the
next rule says that abstract classes
cannot be instantiated directly directly
the third one is an abstract class must
have at least one abstract method next
to that we have another rule which says
an abstract class includes final methods
next an abstract class may also include
non-abstract methods it's not mandatory
that an abstract class should only
include abstract methods so the last
rule says that an abstract class can
include construct s and static methods
so these were some crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes in Java
so far we have discussed the definition
of abstract classes its features and the
rules to use abstract classes in Java
now we will learn how to achieve
abstraction in Java so basically there
are two different ways to achieve
abstraction in Java the first way is by
using abstract classes and the next one
is by using an
interface now this brings us to our next
topic that is the syntax to be followed
to use an abstract class and an abstract
method to declare an abstract class we
use the keyword called abstract followed
by that we use the keyword called class
then after that we declare the name of
our class the name of the class is up to
the user's choice for example I have
named my class as simply learn as shown
here followed by the abstract class we
have the abstract method to declare an
abstract method we use the keyword
called abstract then the written type of
the method as of now I have used void
then later we have the name of the
method that is based on the user's
Choice as you can see I have used simply
learn as the name of the
method so this was by using abstract
class method the next one is by using an
interface method
method now what exactly is an
interface so interface can be defined as
a boundary between the method and the
class implementing it in Java we use
interface to achieve abstraction in
other words we can also consider
interface as a container which saves the
signatures of the methods used in a
program now we will move ahead and
understand the syntax to use an
interface to achieve abstraction in
Java to declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface followed by
that we declare the name of a class the
class name is up to the user's choice
for example I have named my class as
simply learn as shown
below as discussed earlier interface
acts just as a container that stores
only the signatures of the method we
cannot have a complete method defined
inside it all we can do is just declare
an
interface now that we have a detailed
explanation about the abstract class and
the interface let us look into some
example programs based on abstract
classes now we have successfully booted
the Eclipse IDE now let's create a new
project so to create a new project just
click on create a
project
and this should give you a dialogue box
wherein you have to select Java
project click
next now let us give a name to our
project so simply learn will be the name
of my project here now let me click on
finish to finish this
process as you can see the project has
been successfully created and inside the
project simply learn we have the source
file and right clicking the source file
will give us a Dropbox where you can
just select new and inside new you can
select a new
package now let's name the package as
abstraction and click on finish to
create the
package moving further let's right click
on the package and select new and from
new select a class to create a new
class so the name of my class will be
employee let's click on finish to create
the
class now we have our employee class
ready now let's right click on the
package and select new and inside that
let us select another
class and the name of this particular
class will be person which will act as
our abstract
class so as you can see we have declared
this particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person so our first example which is
based on employees where we will have an
abstract class called person and this
person class will be inherited by the
employee class
and gets executed to generate employee
details now let us try to execute this
program and see the output to execute
the program just right click on the
package and go to the Run option and
select the first one that is Java
application now you can see we have the
employee named Petra and the gender is
female and the employee has logged in
success F so these are the details which
we were expecting to be presented on the
output console now moving ahead we shall
execute our next example which will be
based on
students so here the class student is
the abstract class and three different
student classes namely Raju pranita and
Punit will inherit the student class and
generate the output that displays their
particular ranks
so you can see our abstract class that
is student is been declared using the
keyword abstract and inside that we have
an abstract method which is get
Rank and these classes that are Raju
pranita and Punit will inherit the
abstract class student and display their
ranks now let us try to execute this
program and see the
output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console now let us move ahead and
try to execute one last example based on
abstract
losses so the third and last example is
based on interest rates provided by
different banks here we have an abstract
class named loan and all the banks
described in the program will inherit
the loan abstract class to calculate the
rate of interest on the loans provided
by them as you can see we have the
abstract class that is loan and inside
that we have the abstract method which
is interest so we have the classes Andra
Bank bank of Baroda idbc Bank State Bank
of India which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of Interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the
output as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
has been displayed in the output
console so with this we have entered
into our next topic where we understand
the differences between an abstract
class and an
interface so the first difference
between the both is the keyword while we
declare an interface we we use the
keyword called interface on the other
hand when we declare an abstract class
we use the keyword abstract followed by
that the second difference is when you
use an interface the sub classes
basically Implement an interface while
on the other hand when you use abstract
classes the sub classes extend an
abstract class and inherit the
properties of the abstract law followed
by that the third difference is multiple
in interfaces can be implemented but on
the other hand only one abstract class
can be extended at one particular
instance and the final difference
between the both is interface is capable
to support multiple inheritance whereas
on the other hand abstract classes are
not capable to support multiple
inheritances multiple inheritance is
none other than the diamond problem
which is not supported in
Java now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract class
now first we will discuss the
advantages so the advantages of using an
abstract class in Java are the abstract
classes are highly beneficial in writing
shorted codes the abstract classes avoid
code duplication they enable code
reusability which is a major advantage
and finally the last Advantage is
changes to the internal code
implementation can be done without
affecting the classes so these were few
of the major advantages of using an
abstract class now moving ahead we shall
discuss the disadvantages of using
abstract
classes few of the disadvantages of
using an abstract class in Java are
abstraction is expensive as sometimes
you need to handle cases and situations
which are not necessary followed by that
the second disadvantage is object
relational impedence mismatch in the
case of rdbms and the last disadvantage
is object relational mapping in case of
Frameworks like hibernate so these are
the few important disadvantages of using
abstract classes in Java that you need
to consider before using them into your
project what is
inheritance there are two other key
terms which are not going to be in this
agenda but you should also uh when you
get to them make sure you bundle them
together as you're understanding these
structures and that's the abstract class
and the
polymorphism so what is
inheritance inheritance is an act
through which a new class gets created
by acquiring the variables and methods
defined in the previous parent
class so we look at what is inheritance
we can take an example of say uh food
food we have veggies noodles fruits uh
where food is the parent and your
veggies your noodles and fruits are all
subclasses of that they're all kind of
children of
food why do we need
inheritance we Implement inheritance for
a multiple of reasons like creating a
possibility to add or remove features to
reduce the code length as we reuse the
code uh more comfortable to develop and
maintain the project
and so uh if we start looking at let's
say we have a cell phone we make calls
we have our SMS texting our
communication on our phone we have our
media we also had a browser on there
because now we have a
smartphone and we look at that we have
our phone setup and then we have our um
full smartphone media call SMS and
browser and we start to kind of Link
these instead of making them separate we
can have the call and the text and then
we can have them inherit uh we can
actually create a media that inherits
their quality so now you can text your
media now you can use the browser as
part of your call
scenario and I would even add one more
example in here and that is that all
programming languages that are object
base are built on inheritance uh Java
python C++ so this concept of building
an object and then that object then is
inherited by everything underneath of it
is important to understand even in these
most even as we're looking at more um
specific
cases so let's take a look at the
components of
inheritance and the most important uh
two components in inheritant the two
major components that are mentioned are
parent class or the super class and the
child class or the
subass and to see this let's go ahead
and jump into eclipse and take a look at
the actual code looks like so the first
thing I want to do is go ahead and add
in a new package and we're going to go
ahead and call this package um
inheritance because that's what we're
working with
oops gave me a default Java tutorial in
there inheritance finish and I I started
off with the Java tutorial is just a um
went in and created a new project and
made sure it was Java based so we have
our package um inheritance right here
we're going to go and add in a new
class and we'll go ahead and call this
class machine now one of the standards
when you're creating classes to
capitalize the first letter so always
remember to do that uh in some places
people like to have the whole word
capitalized it really depends on who
you're working with uh but it is kind of
if it starts with a capital letter it's
probably a
class and so once we have our
inheritance we have our public class
machine let's go ahead and give it a
little bit underneath there to do
something and we'll start with
um uh
protected string brand and so whatever
machine we're working with uh these
particular machines are going to be um
we'll call them s it'll be a Samsung
free uh they get some free vocab free
marketing right there for Samsung uh so
Samsung
machines
and then we want it to do something so
let's go ahead and put a procedure in
there and we'll make it
public uh void because it's not going to
return
anything and we'll call this um wash I
guess they're all wash
machines there we go there's our bracket
so a little trouble finding the bracket
on there and let's just have it uh
during this we'll just have it do a
quick uh print
line and we'll say uh
initiating
cycle there and then of course our
semicolon on the end all right so now we
have a public class machine and we're
going to get into um where we start
working with the actual inheritance you
can create an object with this machine
we haven't done anything special to it
it's uh like any other class you might
create in the Java language and we've
added in public uh void wash a procedure
with no return that's with the void
means and it's going to going to print
out and so let's go ahead and create
another um class in here new
class and this one's going to be washing
machine
washing
machine and U we'll go ahead and hit
finish on here and we come into our
washing machine this opened up a nice
new tab for
us and we might have a private uh string
model name
we'll change this to model type model
type equals so type of machine is is a
topl load washing
machine so we have a Samsung as the main
type of machines we're looking at we
have top loader or top loading washing
machine and then we're going to add up
here
extends
machine and so this is the the key code
code we're going to look for because um
we want this to have the properties of
the
machine uh so this comes in and says
whatever is in machine we now also have
in our washing machine and then of
course if we're going to do all this we
need to actually be able to run it and
if we're going to do that we want to go
Ahad and add in the public
static void main reserved um keywords
there and this is just your standard
main uh startup you have your string of
arguments um there we go
and of course our bracket and then in
here we're going to take and create a
washing machine object and so here's our
wash
machine it's of course the type washing
machine and it's going to equal a new
washing machine so we're initiating a
new object in here there we go uh and
then we want to do
something and if we're going to have it
do something we want it to go ahead um
let's see what happens when we have wash
remember our key word up there was
washing
machine. wash and where did that come
from well if you go back into machine
here it is public void wash there's the
procedure and it's coming into the
washing machine and this is inherited uh
that way we don't have to retype that
every time we have a washing machine
this could be washing
machine uh maybe the next one is I don't
know different kind of washing machines
I'm not an expert on washing machines we
have it do a wash and then specific to
the washing machine in
here we also had uh the type and so we
can come back up here or brand so we can
come up down here we can go uh
system uh dot print
line wash
machine. brand
plus put a little Dash in
there
um plus and then we're going to go ahead
and we have our wash machine dot model
type that model type we put in there uh
so the brand where does the brand come
from the Brand's coming from our machine
we have our protected string which is
going to be
Samsung and then we have our washing
machine which has the model type which
is a top load machine and if we go ahead
and run
this after of course we make sure we
have that semicolon in on the end there
we come up there we'll see initiating
cycle initiating cycle was printed out
from machine and then the Samsung
topload washing machine is the second
print out line here and so when we have
our wash print out here also the wash
machine wash is initiating cyle
and then we have that's where that print
out comes from we can go back up here to
machine you can see right here
initiating
cycle and then we flip back over to the
washing machine and we print out
washmachine
dobr which is the machine class and then
wash machine. model type which is
underneath the washing
machine so let's go over all that let's
take a look and see what we're talking
about here so we saw on the code the
extends keyword the term extends is a PR
defin keyword in Java that allows you to
create a new child class by deriving the
variables and methods from the parent
class to reduce code length and improve
the
performance and we see that right up
here in our public class washing machine
extends
machine so the next key thing to talk
about is access
modifiers and I kind of breezed over
them when I put together the code but
we'll dig in there a little deeper when
we talk about access
modifiers there's four different words
you really need to know and that's
default public protected and private and
I'm going to tell you right now default
equals
public so what is default default access
modifier is set implicitly whenever you
declare a class without a specific
access modifier by default the access of
a class or method when declared without
a specific access modifier becomes
available to any other method or class
within the same package and in Java the
default is public uh so public a certain
class can be declared as public by using
the keyword public any class or method
when declared as public becomes
available to any class or method
declared in the same package but if a
different method or class needs it it
should be
imported and then we have protected a
certain class is declared protected by
using the keyword protected this
provides access to the methods and
variables of the protected class only to
the rightful subclasses and protects the
data from any other classes which are
not
related and then private a certain class
is declared protected by using the
keyword private this provides the
ultimate protection to the data members
and the methods of the private class
this procedure is implemented by class
to encapsulate the method and
members so uh we'll take a a little work
is going to do a different example in
here but I do like this underneath the
uh washing
machine you can see right here we have
put in private a private
string what this means is that only
washing machine can access that private
string uh where if you have protected
the children can access it uh so a
protected screen if you're underneath a
machine up here we have protected so
that when I create the washing machine
and extend machine um I can still access
it but if I create a sub class of
washing machine and a market is private
that subass is not going to be able to
access it and so it has to do with what
layers of accessing think of this as a
big team project you create something do
you really want that to Cascade down to
the next class or who do you want to
have access to
that let's go a little deeper to really
bring this home because it's really
important to understand this terminology
uh let's go ahead and start a new class
here and we're just going to call this
particular class um
summation and go ah and create that
finish and so our summation class it's
going to be uh pretty simple in here uh
we'll go ahead and
do uh
public so anybody can access it just
remember here's our public on there and
then we'll just do a um uh integer
that's what it's going to return as an
integer we're going to call it add and
we're going to put integer X comma
integer
Y
and and we'll just return x + y so real
simple we're just adding two numbers
here's our two inputs that both have to
be integers and we're going to return an
integer and it'll be the summation of
the two so real simple class right there
and if we're going to have a summation
and let's go ahead and create a new
class and we'll call this one
child
and in our new child
class we're going to go ahead and keep
this simple and we're just going to have
our public static main uh we're going to
have our summation a equals new
summation and then system out print line
a. add 100 plus 200 pretty
straightforward everything's public in
here um oops okay there's our running
and we see that answer is
300 so this is public if we remember
correctly we're talking about public and
so when we use the public keyword any
class or method when declared as public
becomes available to any class or method
declared in the same
package uh but if in a different method
or class needs it it should be imported
so here we go that's our public setup
it's just open to everybody well
everybody that's under the package
inheritance so what whoever is using
that package can now use the this
particular
child and let's go ahead add a new class
in and this time we're going to do a uh
parent
class I'll just put that right in
there and we come in with our parent
class you can see right here the parent
class itself is public but what we want
to do underneath the parent class is we
want to create a
protected uh void because we're not
returning anything and print so we're
going to do the print there and this
protected print let's go and put our
brackets in there and we'll do just a
simple uh print line hello world and
once we have that uh print hello world
we want to go ahead and add a child
class to
this and let's see we already well we
had the child class when took it out a
second ago so we'll go ahead and put
that back in uh here's our child
class and for this childood class we
want it to go ahead and extend the
parent uh so inheritance there are
extend on there oops retype that all
right extends parent so now the child
class is part of the parent
class and we'll go ahead and put our
main in there so that it will run it and
execute it and we'll create our child x
equals
new child
class we go ahead and assign our um
variable X and initiate it and then
we'll do just the print and see what
happens here so here's our print
statement
and we'll go ahead and run this and
compile our child on there and when it
comes in there you see it says print
hello world and so the
parent has marked this as protected so
it's protected from um objects that are
not inheriting it but the child can
still access that information and print
it on
there so here's protected this provides
access to methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protected data from any
other classes which are not
related and a lot of programming that's
usually where you end up is doing a lot
of stuff that is um underneath your
parent that is protected you either make
them public or protected a lot of people
are sloppy and just make them public but
most of the stuff you want to make sure
it's uh protected and then we finally
have our private and I'm going to go
back here to um our child and we're
going to run
this and it's going to come up and say
uh proceed with launch errors in setup
and then it's going to give us an
exception thread main compilation error
the method print from the type parent is
not visible and that's because unless
you actually initiate the parent you're
not going to see this code because it's
private it's only private to the public
to the parent class so even if I extend
it in child it will not be available and
that again protects it that means it's
something that you don't want to inherit
and Cascade down because maybe it is a
piece of code that is going to beang and
so you don't want all the children to
crash every time you make a change to
it so with private this provides the
ultimate protection to the data members
in the methods of the private class this
procedure is implemented by class to
encapsulate the methods and members so
very important we have private and we
have protected and we have public the
more access you want of pieces of the
software code to have and other
programmers to have the more public you
want to make it and of course the
default is public
now one of the common workarounds for
this because you only have protected
data but you still want it to be used by
the
subclasses is to create what they call
like a git or a um we'll do it up here
we'll go ahead and do a
u
private integer x equal
5 and then instead of on your
inheritance instead of having it uh call
it from the the child we might have a
git thing or a g a git thing we might
have a
public it's going to return an integer
and we might have it say get
X and this simply just return
X and what this means is that uh when we
have something simple like this we just
does a return X I can go back into my
child here and instead of print X X
we'll do um X
do get
X and we'll go ahead and print this out
or you something simple with that we'll
go ahead and do a uh system print line
on
this and when we run
this you'll see it come up it's going to
recompile and we get our five What's
Happening Here is now I've created
underneath the parent private
information you you don't know what's
going on with it it's protected uh you
might have a procedure that's protected
in this case we had the print procedure
and then we access it from the public
and this could have easily have been
instead of um maybe we'll just call it
uh
public
void public
print kind of a a goofy way of doing the
code there we go and then it could go in
here and access our um print
and so we can actually still access this
print variable up here by wrapping it in
kind of a git or a public function this
allows us to protect whatever code is
going on in the parent class so it can't
be messed up it can't be accessed
indirectly it has to go through the
right processes and so when we get to
the child on here the child can then
still has the public processes but all
the other information is is protected
and is private it's really important to
remember that private right
there this brings us to Super
keyword and we talk about the super
keyword uh super keyword eliminates the
confusion between parent class method
and subclass Method super keyword is
implemented to access a method or
Constructor that is defined in the
parent
class so back in Eclipse we'll go under
parent and we'll take this we're going
to take the private out of there so now
we have an integer
five and we'll go ahead and just remove
the print because we're not going to do
that in the
parent um oops and the
public there we go and so let's create a
parent that just has one piece of
information it has an integer x equals 5
and then we're going to go to the child
and let's go ahead and add in here
integer x = 10 and these are by default
they're public we haven't set anything
on here uh telling it what it
is and so what I'd like to do is we'd
like to go ahead and create
a oops one more thing there we go create
a procedure here and we'll just call
this void Capital print it's just going
to be a system out print line and this
is what I want you to notice is we're
going to print out X and Super X uh so
we have the child class X and we have
the parent class Super X and if we um
come down here and we do
X um dot
print don't forget my
semicolon add a couple spaces in here to
make it uh look nicer when we print it
and we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see that the child class prints 10
and the parent class is five and so this
way you can actually store different
information depending on what it is
you're working on and what you're doing
and that's where this super comes in you
can see right here where the super
underneath the class and the print
module uh now you can't just put it in
down here under print and we can explore
what that looks like if I just take this
and I go ahead and highlight
it and let's say I wanted to just
instead of doing
xprint uh it's going to code up right
here and right off the bat you see the
super dox I can do x. super dox and and
it's still going to give me an error
right here it has to be underneath a
procedure in the actual class and not
under the main this brings us to types
of
inheritance and there's four main types
uh we have single inheritance which
we've already pretty much looked at but
we'll go back over we have multi-level
inheritance we have hierarchial
inheritance and Hybrid inheritance let's
go ahead and just start with the single
inheritance single inheritance consists
of one parent class and one child class
here child class inherits parent class
methods and data
members and let's go ahead and create a
a new class up here just to change it up
and keep it interesting
new class and we'll call this one
student uh and under the
student and we'll have a a simple setup
we'll just do an enrolled and it'll say
uh enrolled in simply learn there we go
so there's our uh class student and then
we'll create another class uh we'll do
it as a because we have our student or
base student and then we'll call this
one
new
class and we'll call this one uh
computers there we go so he's a rolled
finish and for computers let's go ahead
and put in a print line here and we'll
put
down
studying
computers and we want to go ahead and do
the extends
extends student so it's a student
studying computer subass computers and
this would all look familiar because
we've been doing this for you know a lot
of the other setups this is your basic
inheritance um and we'll change that
from enroll to studies and then let's
let's go ahead and put a main in here so
we can actually run it and we have our P
enrolled which comes from our uh parent
class and our P studies which comes from
the child or the um one inheritance it
the extends for student and let's go
ahead and run that there we go
run and you can say enrolled in simply
learn studying
computers and then we can go on to the
next
setup and this is where we look at
multi-level inher inheritance is also a
parent child inheritance relation but
the difference is the child class is
inherited by another child
class this is the basic structure of
most programming languages right here
you have an object you have all the
different things under the object and it
gets all the way down to whether it's an
array you're working with whether even a
class is a sub child that goes all the
way up to the object and we can simply
do that in our code in eclipse and we'll
just go ahead and add a new class in
there we'll call this one uh yeah Java
there we go oops Java and under Java we
want to go ahead
and oh create some of the similar stuff
and then I want to go back to my student
I took out the main in student just
because I don't want it to run the main
in there and in here we're going to have
system out um we're going to have
instead of studying computers
focus on Java which is what we're doing
right now and maybe we'll call this
classroom and then we can come down here
and we have our P equals new computers
well instead of new computers we want
our Java and it's going to be a Java
object and we need to put our extends in
up
here extends in this case we came from
uh
computers so there's our initial thing
and then we have our last print in
here and of course if we run this now
we'll see that it should if I did
everything correctly come up and say
enrolled in simply learn studying
computers focus on Java and we have the
enrolled which is the parent to
computers and then we have under
computers well we have student then
computers and then Java and so each one
of these classes just Cascades all the
way down and this is your multi-level uh
from your class A to class b to class
C and if you can have multi-level
inheritance we can also have a higher
archal inheritance where your parent
child relationship the only difference
is here multiple child classes inherit
from one parent
class and that is pretty uh um we'll do
another class here U if you remember
correctly we had uh student
computers uh maybe from student we'll
have instead of computers we'll have
project management uh
project management so you're studying
your idle and um all your other classes
in there for Cascade and for um uh doing
agile programming and in here we can do
that it's just the same as we did before
we just have a second child coming in
from here and so this would go ahead and
extend
[Music]
extends
student and of course whatever uh
subcategory you have one in here for
running
this and so for here we'd have like our
void studies in this case instead of
studying computers uh we're studying
project management
project management one of the other
wonderful classes that is taught from
the simply learn team and we'll go and
run that and you can see right here we
have uh computers oops of course uh
instead of computers I meant to
do
project management there we go and we
have to also initiate it as a
new and then when we run here we can see
this uh we're enrolled in simply learn
and we're studying project
management and then finally there is the
um the hybrid the name itself explains
it to us uh the Hybrid inheritance can
be a combination of any of the three
types of inheritance supported in Java
and so maybe we already saw that because
we have um our a and our
B if we flip back on over to um our
Eclipse we have our student our student
now has a
computers project management so there's
our um hierarchial and then they're
mixed because we also have the Java
which is an extension of the computer
and so we have multiple layers
there so one of the issues isues that
comes up with inheritance and classes is
what they call the diamond
problem and in the diamond problem the
Java programming language does not
support multiple inheritance as it ends
up with serious
ambiguity and that is where we have D
which inherits from both B and C which
might both inherit from a uh this is the
diamond Factor because as you start
tracking your supers going up which one
are you actually looking at B or C or a
uh and that's why they call this the
diamond problem it comes up more than
you would think you get very complicated
structures and you realize oh I need to
have both sets of instructions come down
to whatever I'm working on and you can
see where that can become a
problem let us take a look at is a
relation and has a relation now these I
mean they're vocabulary but they're more
of a concept understanding how things
fit
together and so we talk about is a Rel
when a class inherits methods and
members from a different class then the
relationship is said to be is a relation
examples orange is a
fruit and oh let's just jump back on
over here and we'll make
a
new class and we'll call this class
customer so we're going to have our
customers
oops there we go if I can remember how
to type so we have a class customer and
we I've gone ahead and and our team in
the back went ahead and prepped this for
us um let's just take a quick look
though we got public string name so it's
accessed uh publicly if you leave this
out it'll automatically be public
because that's the default and then we
have our customer and the string which
is a name and a string is a city and
then when you do a customer and you send
it the name in the city it will do this
name equals name and this city equals
City we could have easily done this
private we have a call into it to create
it uh so it wouldn't really matter too
much whether we did it private or uh
public I would actually be more likely
to do it
private and for this um example we'll go
ahead and create a another class and
we'll call this store we'll have our
store class we have customers and we
have a
store um and then we'll go ahead and uh
set up in here and this time we did do a
private we're going to create a list of
customer customers and then the store
list coming down and then this customer
customers and public list customers a
quick look at this is we did make this
one private uh which is nice because now
it can't be accessed externally except
from store uh and then store has the
public list customers so we can send it
a list of customers and then it go ahead
and Returns the customers from that list
and then when we add it to the store it
sets the customers in the store this do
customers equals
customers one of the reasons we have the
error lines in here is I haven't
compiled it so it doesn't see the
customers are part of our package and
we'll get to that in just a moment
here and then let's go ahead and create
another class uh we'll call this is a
relation since that's what we're working
on and here's our is a relation
setup and we're just going to put this
as the main so you have your main in
there um and then we went ahead and
prepared um a series of
customers and we'll just call it uh
customer C1 equals a new customer
customer C2 equals a new customer and
we're just creating a list here that's
all we're doing and if we're going to
have a list then we need to go ahead and
uh create a list of
customers and um we'll just do that with
a simple list
setup and then we got to add those
customers into the list so let's go
ahead and do
that so breaking this down we have a
customer uh one which is Raju Bangalore
uh Shiva hyperbad um sain Mumbai and so
on and then we just created a list of
customers a new array of lists and we
add in each of those customers so now we
have a nice uh list of all our different
customers in here and then we want to go
ahead and uh create our um uh
store and we'll put in store and it'll
be a fruit smoothies franchise I put
down fruit smoothies French um maybe
that's not a good abbreviation you might
think it's a French instead of franchise
uh it'll be a new store um and then we
have our new store which is um in this
case we're going to put in that new
store customers and if you remember we
went back here into store let me just
flip back on over
there it's going to take that list of
customers and put that into this
customers so now the private list is
going to equal that list of customers
and then of course we can come in here
and we do public list it's going to
return that list of customers so we have
public assets here and this door you can
add public at the beginning we'll go
ahead and do that just to make it clear
is it public uh is what's going to run
on there and let's go back into our is a
relation and uh who flip back to store
I'm going to go ahead and just change
this to uh customer list so here's our
list customer list and it's going to
return the uh customers from this
selection from our private
variable uh so we come into
here uh we can come down here and we'll
go ahead and put that in there we'll do
a loop on this we'll have a a list
customer and we're going to create a
list of our customers from our fruit
smoothies franchise and we'll get the
customer list from there and then for a
customer in the um in our for customer
CST in customer we're going to go a and
just print that name out
there now at this point if you have um
an error showing up here under list and
also underneath array list depending on
how you did your install you might have
to go ahead and import those your array
list from your Java utility not a big
deal uh and then once we go ahead and we
have this all set up you'll see here the
compiler goes through and then we have
the name of the customer um city and
then it just lists the customers going
down
here so when we talk about our
relationship of our fruit smoothies uh
franchise and customers the customers uh
they are uh relationship directly to the
French smoothies
franchise now the second idea is it has
a relation and let's go ahead and take a
look at that and see how that
differs and we'll go ahead and create
create a um oh let's see we had
customers so let's do um and we'll call
this one um we're doing with smoothies
so we'll have
flavors um or favorite we'll do favorite
flavors favorite flavors for a class
very strange
class and the see in favorite flavors
we'll go ahead and give it a couple
things to look at uh we'll have a
private string and a
name and then we'll have a public
string um get
flavor there we go and that's just going
to
return uh return we'll just have that
return the name of the
flavor there we go and then uh we want
to go ahead and
create one more class and this class
we'll call uh
has a
relation and I'm hoping you're guessing
where we're going with this let's go and
put some code in here to make it
work and let's go back to our favorite
flavors and put in a Constructor so that
we can load the flavors and then return
uh this name so we can return the
flavors we'll go back into has a
relation um and let's just create a
customer call it cust uh our new
customer is Toby Marshall from Mumbai
and our favorite flavors are strawberry
banana and peanut butter don't know it's
a strange concoction and then when we
run a print line we're going to print uh
the customer name from customers and the
flavors get
flavor and so when we're looking at this
what I want you to be aware of is that
uh neither the flavors nor the customer
are in the same class they're not not
it's not an actual relationship but they
have a relationship cuz we have Toby who
happens to like strawberry and peanut
butter and if you remember uh just a
quick note we were looking at the
diamond problem um you can create a
class that then has these two subclasses
in and that's how you go around the
diamond problem is you don't inherit but
you create classes inside the class
you're working with now let's quickly
begin with our session first of all we
we will discuss the right angle triangle
pattern so basically the right angle
triangle star pattern looks something
like this as it is shown on my screen so
to resolve this problem statement and
print the pattern we must assume that
this particular star Arrangement is made
in the form of a matrix where the first
row has single star and the second row
has two stars third row has three stars
and so on now to to execute this
particular code we might need two for
Loops so the first for Loop will be for
printing the rows and the second one
will be for printing The Columns now let
us execute a practical program and see
how does it work don't worry about the
codes that we will be executing here
because I have formatted a draft about
all the codes that I will be executing
today and that particular file will be
attached in the description box below on
my screen you can see the particular
pattern which is a right angle triangle
star pattern so as discussed before we
will have the first outer for Loop which
will be for printing the rows so inside
the outer for Loop we have the second
for Loop which we will be using for
printing The Columns you can see I have
defined the row value as five which
means we will be printing the star
pattern for five rows and we have used a
counter variable which is I which is
assigned the value of one and the
comparator operator is used here which
is I should be less less than or equal
to the number of rows declared and
followed by that we have a pre-increment
operator and once the condition is true
the control will be entered into the
second for Loop where we have the next
counter variable which is J so we have
assigned J is equal to 1 and the
comparator operator which is J should be
less than or equal to I which is the
value here which is in the outer for
Loop and followed by that we have the
pre-increment operator once the is true
the control will enter into the inside
for Loop and will print a star so here
just let us assume that the value of I
is one and the statement is true so the
control will enter into the second fall
Loop and it will see the conditional
operator here so J is less than or equal
to I so value of 1 is less than or equal
to 1 and the star will be printed after
that we have the pre-increment operator
so here the J value will be incremented
to 2 now if you compare the values 2 is
not less than or not equal to 1 so the
condition fails here so it will not
print a star again it will come out of
the inner for Loop and it will see the
next statement which says it should
print in the next line whereas in the
inside fup you can see we just used
print not print in the new line
so it will come to the new line and go
back to the followup again and the
increment of I will be taken place and
the same runs again now let us try to
execute this program and see the
output so you can see that the program
got successfully executed and the right
angle triangle star pattern is print
successfully now let us go into the next
type of
program so the the next type of program
is the inverted right angle triangle
star pattern so similarly according to
the previous example we also consider
this one in the form of a matrix so you
can see that in the first row we have
five stars in the second row we have
four stars similarly so on now let us
try to check out the code and learn how
does it work and how to print the star
pattern on our screen we back in the
Practical mode again so the kind of
pattern that we wanted to print is this
one which is a little bit similar to the
previous one but only think it is
inverted so the code is pretty much the
same but the only changes that we need
to do are related to the comparator
operator in the previous example we
chose that I should be less than or
equal to 1 and in the next stage we used
pre-increment operator in here we are
using using a different one which is
pre- decrement and inside the fall Loop
we have the J comparator operator in the
same way so here we have declared the
row value as five and inside the for
Loop we will equate the counter variable
equals to rows which is five and
followed by that the comparator operator
Compares if the value of five is greater
than or equal to 1 and followed by that
we will use the pred decrement operator
once the condition is true the control
will enter into the inside for Loop and
here the counter variable J is assigned
to the value one and the condition is J
should be less than or equal to I and
followed by that we have the pre
increment operator which is Plus+ G so
once the condition is true it will print
the value of a star and followed by that
it will again continue the loop so here
the fall Loop will work in the following
way in I is equal to 5 I is greater than
or equal to 1 which is true and pred
decrement so the condition is true so
the control will enter into the inside
for Loop where it will again compare
with value of J J is equal to 1 and J is
less than or equal to 5 and followed by
that we have the post increment so the
control will enter inside the followup
and print a star and followed by that in
the next instance
the value of J will be incremented to 2
so 2 is less than or equal to I followed
by that pre-increment and in the next
iteration it will print a star again so
this will continue until the condition
is true once the condition fails the
control will exit the fall Loop and
Print in the next line you can see that
we have print in the new line here which
is unlike the print function which is
inside the fall Loop so this will
continue continue until the statements
are true now let us try to execute this
program and see if the desired pattern
will be printing or
not there you can see that the program
got successfully executed and the
pattern which we desired for is printed
on the screen now let us move ahead into
the next type of
pattern so the next type of pattern is
the arrow shaped pattern and this almost
looks familiar to the previous two
programs the only difference is we have
combined them together to form an arrow
pattern now let us try to combine the
previous two programs and print
this so now you can see on my screen we
have our desired pattern which looks
like an arrow so as discussed before we
are trying to combine the two programs
that we executed before so the first
half of the program is designed for the
first half of the pattern which is
completely similar ilar to our first
program so the second half of the
pattern is from our second program but
the only difference here is we have
considered the value of rows is row
minus one because we don't want another
extra row to be printing here in this
way so you can see if we used I value is
equals to rows then the pattern would be
something like this we will not have a
pointed Edge so to get a point Ed Edge
we will use row minus one to get this
pattern what we desired
for now let us try to execute this
program and print the
output now let us enter the number of
rows we want let's enter
five so there you go let me expand my
output screen yeah there you go we have
the pattern which we desired for and
don't forget that we need to use row
minus one in the next stage which is the
second half of the
program so this is how the arrow pattern
is printed now let us move further and
see the next type of pattern in our list
so in the next pattern we have the right
angle triangle which is completely
similar to the first one but the
hypotenuse is on the other side as you
can see this is the difference between
the first program and this program so in
the first program we had the hypotenuse
in this direction and now we have the
hypotenuse in the opposite direction now
similarly to the first program we should
consider this one as well in the form of
a matrix so you can see if we consider
this pattern in the form of a matrix we
have four spaces followed by a star
similarly in the second row we have
three spaces followed by two stars in
the third one we have two spaces and
three stars and so on so the main point
that we need to consider here is first
we need to print the spaces followed by
that we need to print this stas to get
this pattern now let us execute a
practical program and see the output so
back in the Practical mode you can see
on my screen the desired pattern what we
are looking for is this so here the only
difference is we have to print the
spaces first so for printing the spaces
we will be using this follow loop with
the condition J is = to 2 into n minus I
and J should be greater than orals to z
and j decrement which is a post
decrement operator so what is the value
of n n is nothing but the value of rows
so the value of n is declared in the
main function and N is equal to 5 after
that we will be calling The Print Star
function which is over here and the
value of n will be carried over here and
then the counter variables I and J will
take care of the Fall Loops now let us
try to execute this program and see the
output so you can see that the program
is successfully executed and the desired
pattern is printed successfully so this
fall Loop will be run until the
condition is true once this fall Loop
fails we will enter into the next fall
Loop which is particularly designed to
print the
stars now after this let us move ahead
into our next type of
pattern so the next type of pattern is
an inverted right angle triangle pattern
which is opposite to the second type of
program that we dealt
with now similarly let us consider this
in the same way as we considered all the
other programs that is in the form of a
matrix so here we have five stars in the
first row four stars in the next one and
one space followed by that we have two
spaces followed by that we have the
three stars and three spaces two stars
and so on now let us see a practical
program and try to print this particular
pattern so we are back in the Practical
mode so you can see that the desired
star pattern is this and it is
completely similar to our previous
pattern so the only difference is we
Tred to print spaces first in the
earlier pattern and here we are trying
to print the Stars first so that's the
only
difference and we have the same for
Loops so the first for Loop is for rows
and it will print spaces and the second
follow Loop is for stars which will
print the stars as you can see we have
the row values and the column values
here as the comparator operator and we
have the comparator operator which finds
if J is greater than I in the first case
the loop will fail because the value of
J and I are completely similar because
we have declared I is equals to rows in
the first outer for Loop and same J is
equals to rows in the second inner for
Loop so obviously the condition has to
fail and it will not print any space
here it will directly enter into the
next for Loop and we print the star
pattern and followed by that we will
enter into the next line so this
followup will print the number of stars
in the first row according to the row
number for example if if we give five as
the row number then it will print five
stars in the first row and it will exit
the fall Loop and it will enter into the
next line and the same pattern will be
continued now let us try to execute this
program and see the
output now let us give five as the
number of rows needed so there you go
you can see the star pattern here so
this is how this particular star pattern
will be generated now let us move
further and check out the next type of
pattern program in our list so the next
type of pattern program in our list is
Arrow so this arrow is completely
similar to the previous one the only
difference is it is in the inverted way
which is it is pointed towards the left
side now let us check out the Practical
program and learn how to execute
this back on to Eclipse IDE so you can
find some similarities between the
previous two programs and this
particular program in the previous two
programs we tried to print the first
half of the pattern and followed by that
we have printed the second half of the
pattern now we going to just combine
both the programs and print this
particular Arrow
pattern so here the first half of this
particular program is concerned with the
top portion of this pattern which is the
right right angle triangle followed by
that the second half of the program
where we have the conditions
placed so this particular segment of the
code takes care about the second half of
the program which is the inverted right
angle triangle now let us try to execute
this program and see the
output so let us specify the number of
rows as five completely similar to the
previous two progr programs now let's
press enter now there you go let me
expand my
console so there you go you can see the
arrow
pattern so this is how you print an
arrow pattern pointing towards the left
side we have also discussed an arrow
pattern where the arrow will be pointing
towards the right side as the program
number
three again don't worry about the codes
all the programs that I'm going to
execute in this session are are drafted
in the form of a text document and that
is linked in the description box below
you can take that source file and
practice the programs for yourself no
worry now let's move ahead and check out
the next type of
program so the next type of pattern that
we have in our list is the pyramid we
also call this an acute angled triangle
star
pattern now let us understand the logic
for this now now you can see without the
Matrix format this looks completely
similar to our first program but only
the difference is we have a space which
is obvious but there is a small
difference let us check out what's the
difference is if we look this program in
the form of a matrix you can see there
are variations in spaces in the first
row we have two spaces one star followed
by that again two spaces in the next row
we have alternate space and and star
space and star and similarly in the
third row we have a star space star and
space so this is how the Matrix
continues according to the number of
rows provided so let us understand how
the logic exactly works for this
program okay so you can see the pattern
that we desired is in the form of an
acute angle triangle or pyramid now we
have two counter variables which is I is
equal to 0 in the out a for Loop and J
is equal to n minus1 which is inside the
for Loop so the value of n is equal to 5
which is the total number of rows that
we needed in our particular pattern now
you can see in the outer for Loop we
have the condition which is I should be
less than n so I should be less than the
number of rows which is equals to 5
followed by that we have the post
increment operator I ++ so the condition
will be true because 0 is less than 5
and it it will enter into the inside for
Loop where we have J which is equals to
5 - 0 followed by that we have the
condition so 5 is greater than 1 so the
resultant of this particular statement
is five so five which is now the value
of J is greater than 1 followed by that
we have the post decrement operator
which will decrease the value of J in
every iteration so once the state is
true it will try to print a
space so it will print the spaces until
the condition is true so once the first
for Loop fails the control will enter
into the next following for Loop where
we have J is equals to 0 and J should be
less than or equal to the value of I
which is currently equals to Z and
followed by the conditional statement we
have the post increment operator which
is J Plus+ so this particular follow
Loop is used for printing two things
which is the first one star followed by
that we have a space so once this follow
Loop gets executed the control will exit
it and will print in the new line so
this is how the program works now let us
try to execute this program and see the
order there you go the program got
successfully executed and the required
spaces and the stars are been printed
here so as you can see we have spaces
followed by that we have a star
similarly
space spaces on to the left a star and
the second
star so followed by the previous program
we have the next program which is also
considered to be like a pyramid but the
only difference is it is in an inverted
format now let us check out the logic
behind this program and try to execute a
practical program so logic wise it's
completely similar to the previous one
we have star followed by that we have a
space and again a star space and a star
next row we have alternate space and
star and finally we have two spaces star
and two spaces so the number of spaces
and stars is based upon the number of
rows we provide now let us try to
execute a program and see the output
don't worry this is completely similar
to the previous one but the only
difference is it is print it in the
inverted fashion so there will be minor
changes to the code let's try to look on
those changes so here we are back in
Eclipse so the desired pattern is here
which is an inverted pyramid and the
preium program was a regular pyramid so
here is the logic and we have The
Following fall Loops so the first fall
Loop is dedicated for printing the
number of spaces we require so inside
the exterior for Loop we have the
counter variable I is equals to 0 and I
should be less than or equals to the
number of rows minus one and followed by
that we have the post increment operator
I
++ so let us assume that we have
provided the number of rows to be five
and according to the logic I is equals
to 0 and followed by that 0 is less than
or equals to 5 - 1 which is 4 and
followed by that we have the post
increment operator which will increment
the value of I to one once after the
follow Loop first iteration is finished
so once the exterior for Loop condition
is true the control will enter into the
second for Loop which is the internal
for Loop and we have the second counter
variable which is J is equal to 0
followed by that the comparator operator
which says J should be either less than
or equal to the value of I followed by
that we have the post increment operator
on J so this particular code segment or
the first part of the program takes care
about the number of spaces we require in
our pattern followed by that we have the
second follow Loop which will take care
of the number of stars we print and the
number of spaces we require after the
star
pattern now let us try to execute this
program and see the
output now let us provide the number of
rows we need let's provide the value as
five
now there you go according to the logic
provided in the program the star
patterns are successfully generated
followed by this
spaces now moving ahead we have the next
type of pattern which is the combination
of first and second pyramids now let us
understand the logic and print this
pattern now you can see the desired
pattern is the combination of the first
pyramid and the second pyramid so the
first half of the program is derived
from the the first pyramid pattern and
the second part of the program is
derived from the second pyramid pattern
now we have combined them together and
now we are trying to print the rhombus
pattern now let's try to execute this
program and see the output let us
provide the number of U rows as five and
there you go so here you can see the uh
desired star pattern has been
successfully executed so ACC goinging to
the input we we have the first five rows
and followed by that we have the
inverted star pattern where we avoided
the first row and printed the following
four rows so that we have a proper
Rubik's pattern now moving ahead we
shall see the next type of pattern in
our list so followed by the previous
pattern we have the next type of pattern
which looks completely similar to the
previous one but the only differen is we
have printed the second type of pyramid
first and then the first type of pyramid
which makes it look like an our glass
now let us understand the logic and
print this
pattern so here is the desired pattern
what we are looking for and this was the
previous pattern what we
printed now followed by the first
segment we have the second segment which
is dedicated to print the second half of
the pattern which happens to be the
first type of pyramid which is a regular
pyramid but the only difference is
inside the first for Loop we are using
the rows minus one command because we
don't want an extra star so if we add in
an extra star this pattern will look a
little abnormal so let us try so this is
what it looks like if we had an extra
star there so let us remove
it so this is how our pattern should
look like so that's the reason why we
are using row minus one here now let us
try to execute this program and see the
output
now let us enter the number of rows we
want let us input
five enter so there you go you can see
the program got successfully executed
and the desired star pattern has been
printed on the console now let us move
further and have a look on the next type
of pattern in our list so followed by
the our glass pattern we have the next
pattern where we need to print a
diagonal star
pattern now if we look at the logic it
just a single line which is placed in
the form of a diagonal now let us check
the logic behind
it so you can see we have printed stars
in the form of a diagonal of a matrix
now we have the first four spaces
followed by that we have a star and
similarly three spaces provided by a
star then a space and so on now to print
this pattern what's the logic let's go
back to eclipse and try to print this
program so this is is our desired
pattern now let us go into our program
now inside the program we have two
counter variables which are one I 2 is J
so the first for Loop is I is equal to 1
I is less than or is equals to 5 which
is the ru number then I post increment
so when the logic is true which is 1 is
less than or equal to the row number
five the control will enter into the
second for Loop so once the control
enters into the outer for Loop we have
the second for Loop where we have our
second counter variable which is J J is
equals to Zer and J is less than 5 - I
which is 5 - 1 which is a current value
of I which is 4 so 0 is the value of J
currently so 0 is less than four
followed by that we have the post
increment on J counter variable so once
the condition is true the control will
enter into the second inner for Loop and
will print space so this Loop will run
until the condition is true once the
condition fails it will come out of the
inner fall Loop and will print a star in
the new line followed by that it will
continue to start the outer fall loop
again so this is how the flow goes ahead
now let's run the program and see the
output so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the design
pattern is printed now let's move ahead
and understand the next type of pattern
in our program so the next type of
pattern is a little bit similar to the
previous one so in the previous pattern
we had one diagonal right now we have
two diagonals which have formed the
shape of X so we can consider this as an
x pattern now let us check out the logic
and next after that let's execute the
program so according to the logic when
we consider this particular pattern in a
form of a matrix we have the Stars
printed in the first row followed by
that we have three spaces and then again
a star so this is continued in the same
way with alternate spaces and in the
third row we have a single intersection
point with one star so this is how the
pattern should look like once the
program gets executed now let us check
out the program and see the
output so you can see on my output
console this was our previous pattern
now what we're going to do
is make a similar pattern in the
opposite direction and make sure they
intersect each other now you can see our
program has two segments the first
segment and the second segment they both
look a little similar because the first
segment will print the upper part of the
pattern that is the first V and then the
second segment will print the lower part
of the pattern which is the inverted V
now let us check out the condition we
have the first outer loop which has the
first counter variable which is I is
equals to n n is nothing but the number
of rows that we want in our pattern then
I should be greater than or equal to 1
followed by that we have the post
decrement operator where we will
decrease the value of I then if the
condition is true then the control will
enter into the next statement where we
have the inner for loop with second
counter variable that is J is equal to I
then the condition is J should be less
than the value of rows provided then
post increment of J and if the condition
statement is true then it will enter
into the inner for Loop and it will
print a space similarly for printing the
star we have the next segment inside the
next segment the condition is a little
trickier because we don't want to print
any stars in The Space Between the x
pattern we provide this condition where
J is equals to 1 and J should be less
than or equals to 2 times the value of I
which is the outer follow Loop minus1 if
this condition is true the control will
enter inside the follow Loop where we
have F else condition if J is equal toal
to 1 or Jal toal to 2 into IUS one then
we should print a star else we should
print a space so this will print the
upper part of the pattern and similarly
we have another segment which will print
the lower part of the pattern which is
the inverse Ed V pattern now let's
execute this program and see the
output as you can see the program got
executed now let us provide the value of
n let us provide five and there you go
you can see that the program printed the
desired pattern so this is the first
half of the pattern which is the proper
V then this is the second half of the
program which is the inverted V so this
is what the flow of the program is now
let us move further and check out the
next pattern in our list
so the next pattern in our list is the
inverted V
pattern now let us check out the logic
behind it if you see this in the form of
a matrix then you can recognize this we
had already discussed similar program
which was the third one where we had
printed the pyramid shape but the only
difference is we have missed out the
star in between which makes it look like
a inverted V now let us go back to
eclipse and execute a program based on
this to print this pattern as you can
see we have our desired pattern on my
screen which is an inverted V so if we
check out the logic we have outside Loop
and inside loop so we have two for Loops
so the first outer for Loop has out is
equals to 1 out should be less than or
equals to the number of row size then
post increment of outside
variable if the condition is true we
enter into the inner for Loop where we
have inner loop is equals to 1 inner
loop should be less than or equals to
the row size into two then we have
increment operator which is a post
increment so if this particular
condition is true then we enter into
another statement where we have the IFL
statement so if in value is equals to is
equals to control X or n is equals to
print control y then we should print
star else we should print a space now
let us try to execute this program and
see the output
now let us provide the row size which is
five so as you can see we have got our
desired pattern now let us move ahead
and execute the next type of pattern
which is the V pattern now let us
understand the logic behind
it it is completely similar to the
previous program but the difference is
the pattern is in inverted position to
the previous one which is in the proper
V format so now let us try to check out
the code and execute execute the program
and print the pattern so on my screen
you can see the desired pattern what we
are looking for which is V now the
previous program was to print an
inverted V so the complete program is
same but only there is a minor change in
the logic where we have replaced I as
greater than or equals to
zero and there is some change in the
second segment as well now let us try to
execute this program and see the
output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the desired
pattern is printed here the value of n
or row size is equals to 5 which we have
declared here in the main part now let
us get back and check out the next
pattern to be executed in our
list so the next pattern is the
combination of both an inverted V and a
normal V which will result in the form
of a Romus now as you can see this is
our previous Pro program now we have two
segments in our code where we have the
first segment to print the starting or
the top position which is an inverted V
format and the second segment of the
code is designed to print the second
half of the pattern which is the normal
V pattern so we will combine these two
and print the Romus
shape now let me provide the number of
rows which is five so there you go you
can see the desired pattern now let us
move ahead and check out our next
pattern so the next pattern is
completely similar to one of the
previous ones which is a pyramid pattern
but the difference is this pyramid is
hollow or in other words this looks like
an acute angled triangle now let us
understand the logic behind it so if you
look at this Matrix then you can find
that we are going to print the stars in
the form of a side of the triangle which
is we will print the stars in the shape
of a triangle and nothing inside the
Matrix now let us understand and the
program and print this pattern so as you
can see the desired pattern is been
located here which is a triangular
pattern now inside this we have three
particular fall Loops so the first fall
Loop is the UT ofall Loop and the rest
two fall Loops are the internal fall
Loops so the first internal for Loop is
dedicated to print spaces where we don't
require stars and the second internal
for Loop is dedicated to print Stars
where we require them also we have an F
condition which this decides where to
print a star and where not to now if we
look at the condition I should be less
than or equal to the number of rows
provided and if the condition is true
then we enter into the internal for Loop
and in the internal for Loop if J is
less than the number of rows given then
in that particular location we need to
print a space once the condition in the
first for Loop is failed the control
will enter into the next for Loop where
we have the next counter variable that
is K is equals to 1 and K should be less
than or equals to 2 into i - 1 where the
value of I is 1 at the current
stage and followed by that we have the
post increment of the value of K if K is
equal to equal to 1 or I is equal to
equal to the number of rows or k is
equal to equal to 2 Star ius1 then we
should print a star so this will give
the location in The Matrix where we
should print star to make it as a
triangle pattern if location is anything
else than the condition provided then we
should be printing space there now let
us try to execute this program and see
the
output let us provide the number of rows
as
five so there you go we have printed the
desired
pattern so the next pattern after the
triangle pattern is the Box pattern so
this this particular program will be
completely similar to the previous
program the only difference is we need
to find the locations where we need to
print Stars so that the resultant
pattern looks like a box so for that we
will make some changes in our program
and those changes will be related to the
rows and
columns now let us understand the logic
so as discussed before we need to look
at this pattern in the form of a matrix
and check out the number of rows and
columns so where the number of row and
column are
equal we need to print a star so let us
now check out the program and execute
the program to print this particular
pattern so as you can see on my screen
we have the same program that we used to
print the triangle but now here we have
rows and columns so n is nothing but the
row and M is nothing but the column so
if the value of the external for Loop
that is I is equals to equals to 1 and I
is equals to equals to the number of
rows provided similarly J is equal to
equal to 1 which is the internal for
Loop counter variable value and if J is
equal to equal to M that is the column
value then we should print a star in
that particular location and wherever
the location does not match we should
provide a space now let us try to
execute this program and see the
output so there you go we have our
desired pattern which is the Box
pattern now let us move ahead and check
out the next type of pattern in our list
so you can see the next pattern is
completely similar to our first pattern
the first pattern was our right angled
triangle now we have the same right
angled triangle but the only difference
is we have used numbers here now we will
use the numbers from our fur loops and
we will print the same values in our
pattern so that it looks like a right
angle
triangle now let us understand the logic
so we will see this pattern in the form
of a matrix now we will print the
numbers where we require them where we
don't require the numbers we will print
spaces now let us check out the program
and execute it to print the following
pattern now you can see we have got back
to our same program but the only
difference is here we are using the
values of the iner for Loop which is j
instead of a star previously we used
star symbol here and we are now
replacing it with the inner follow Loop
value let us try to execute this program
and see the
output now let us enter the number
number of rows as five and there you go
we have the values of the internal for
Loop making the pattern look like a
right angle triangle pattern now let us
move further and check out on our next
type of pattern in the list so here is
another right angled triangle in our
list but the difference is we are using
the numbers in a continuous manner which
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 to 15 this type of
triangle is also called as floid
triangle now let us understand the logic
so similar to the previous one we will
consider this in the form of a matrix
and we will print the numbers only way
we require them that is to form a right
angle triangle where we don't need the
numbers we will try to print a space
there now let us check out the program
and execute it and print this
pattern now you can see we have got back
to eclipse and don't get scared about
the pattern it's completely similar to
the previous one only thing is we will
be using using one extra counter
variable which is K so we have provided
the value of K is equal to 1 and where
we are supposed to print Stars we will
add the post increment operator to the
counter variable K so whenever the for
Loop gets executed we will be printing
the values of K which is 1 2 3 4 5 and
so on now let us try to execute this
program and see the
output so there you go the values of K 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 until 15 so this is how the
Floy triangle works now let's get back
and check out the next pattern in our
list so the next pattern in our list is
similar to the previous one which is
Pyramid so this type of pyramid is also
called as pascals triangle now let us
check out the logic the logic is
completely similar to the pyramid's
logic but instead of star we going to
use numbers so this type of triangle is
called as pascals triangle and the logic
is also a little bit different from the
regular pyramid let us understand the
logic through the code so now you can
see the program on my screen so the
logic and the follow Loops used are
completely similar to that of the
pyramid but only the difference is we
going to print the value of
number so the number is firstly
initialized as one followed by that we
have a formula for that which is number
is equal to number into i- J / J + 1
which are the values of the counter
variables of outer for Loop and inner
for Loop respectively now let's try to
execute this program and see the
pattern so you can see the program
coulde successfully executed and the
Floy triangle has been successfully
constructed
here now let us move ahead and check out
the next pattern in our list so the next
pattern in our list is a box which is
made up of binary numbers now let us
understand the logic for it first so if
we look at this in the form of a matrix
we have binary numbers 1 and zero which
forms the pattern of a box now let us
check out the program and execute the
program to print this particular
pattern so you can see on my screen we
have the program to print that
particular box type of pattern using the
binary numbers so we have the external
for Loop for rows and the counter
variable I is equals to 1 and I should
be less than or equal to the number of
rows provided once the condition is true
we enter into the external for Loop
where we have the number and where we
have the condition I modulus 2 is equals
2 is equals to 0 and the number is
equals to 0 and inside that we have our
logic to print the binary
numbers now let us try to execute this
program and see the
out now let me place the number of rows
as five and there you go we have our box
pattern using binary numbers now let us
get back and check the next pattern in
our list so the next pattern is the Ruby
pattern this is completely similar to
our program where we printed the Ruby
pattern using the stars now we'll use
the numbers and print that particular
pattern now the logic for this is
completely same that of the Ruby pattern
we used but the only difference is
instead of a star we'll be placing the
value of the counter variables now let
us try to execute this program and see
the
output so there you go the program got
successfully executed and instead of
stars we have printed the Ruby pattern
using the numbers now moving ahead we
have our next pattern so here the next
pattern is completely similar to the
first one which is the right angled
triangle pattern but here instead of
numbers or Stars we will be using
alphabets so for alphabets we will be
using the asky values in the program let
us check out that program soon now first
let's understand the logic the logic is
also completely similar to the right
angle triangle which we followed for
stars and numbers now let's check out
the
program so as you can see the desired
pattern is the right angle triangle made
out of alphabets so the logic is
completely true but the only difference
is we are going to print characters
using asky values and alphabet
function now let us try to execute this
program and see the output
so the desired pattern is the right
angle triangle printed using the
alphabets now the logic is completely
similar to the right angle triangle
pattern but the only difference is we
are going to use the S values so we have
declared an integer type variable
alphabet with the ask value 65 which
should start the alphabets from capital
A because the ask value of capital A is
65 now let us run the program and see
the
output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
right angle triangle printed using the
capital alphabets now let's get back and
check out our next pattern so our next
pattern is a pyramid again so instead of
numbers and stars we are going to use
the alphabetical values now let's check
out the logic even here you can see the
logic is similar to The Pyramid logic
now let's check out the code and execute
the code and see the pattern now you can
even see the logic is also similar to
The Pyramid logic but here the only
difference is we are going to use the
ask value that is 65 which is equivalent
to Capital a now in the print statement
instead of a star we are going to print
the alphabets and this particular follow
Loop is for spaces now let's quickly
execute this program and see the
output so there you go the pyramid
pattern has been successfully printed
and software developers need to stay up
to date on the latest advancement
regarding the tools Frameworks
programming languages and apps to
achieve success Master the latest coding
tools strategies and techniques through
simply learn software development
process by enrolling in any of these
certification programs you will gain
expertise in skills like agile Java
devops HTML 5 CSS 3 AWS JavaScript es6
soap and rest and GSP with hands-on
experience in tools like angular mongod
DB you will catch TI of top recruiters
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses you
can find the course Link in the
description box below and pin command
let's start with the basics the
hibernate framework was created by Gavin
King in 2001 the latest version is 5
to10 let's start by discussing why we
need hibernate and why it was created it
is a framework that simplifies the
development of Java application to
interact with the database let's
understand why we need it with the help
of two scenarios let's consider a
scenario where a user has a program with
mySQL database
connectivity now if you look at the
illustration
here the user needs to write MySQL
specific code to create the database
connection now just in case the user
shifts from a MySQL to an Oracle
database the user has to repeat the
process of writing database connectivity
code which is Oracle specific so the
connectivity code is difficult to modify
because it's in the source code and
we'll have to recompile the application
every time we change the data storage
mechanism hibernate hence converts
database specific queries automatically
based on a dialc provided and it uses
hql or hyate query language which is
independent of the database so it
prevents the user from changing the code
and queries to map to different data
source once you change a data store
let's say from my SQL to
Oracle let's consider a scenario of a
user with various billing records the
user in the billing records data needs
to be stored in a dbms for this the user
class has to be mapped to the user table
and the billing records has to be mapped
to the billing records
table so this is the class that we will
actually set
up when you create the class the schema
for the user and build billing records
classes will automatically be created
for you so this is the class
representation with the data members and
this is the equivalent SQL statement
that will be created to generate the
respective
tables now what could be the possible
problems with
this the association problem we are
talking about object relationship
mismatch problems in terms of the
association Java can use Association by
having another class variable as a
member in SQL no standard concept is
available to represent Association
navigating data it is different in Java
and SQL and cost mismatching due to
manual handling of object relational
mismatch let's add two sub classes
credit card and debit card which are sub
classes of the billing
record now what could be the possible
problems here SQL does not support super
table and subtable relationship table is
not a type so it is difficult to create
super table subtable relationship and
writing SQL query for polymorphic
relation is
difficult in user table ID is the
primary key this is a foreign key for
the billing record table it is hence
difficult to change the ID we need to
update not only the ID column in user
but also the foreign key column in
Billing record we also need to add surit
key in user and billing record table the
surit key isn't presented to the user
and is only used for identification of
data inside the Software System user
surrogate ID and account number ID are
system generated values it is difficult
to decide whether these columns should
be added to data model or not different
persistent Solutions have different
strategies and this can cause
confusion what is a solution hibernate
provides an orm or object relationship
mapping which takes care of these
issues let's look at or and its features
or refers to automated and transparent
Persistence of objects in a Java
application to the tables in a relation
database using metadata that describes
the mapping between the objects and the
database
so here once we create a Java pojo class
or a plain old Java class in your code
and let's say we provide data members
like ID and name we will automatically
be mapping this to a table in the
database which the hibernate framework
will generate automatically for us with
the same set of columns and mapped to
the class structure that we have and
hence we said object relationship mapper
so the object structure that you have
will be mapped to the database table
structure
the advantag is obviously it can
significantly reduce development time
less code better performance and you can
support different database Management
Systems by adopting this by mapping
logical business model and physical
storage model om implements domain model
pattern it navigates the object
relationship transparency or provides
one way to translate the query to
appropriate database syntax it also
provides concurrency support where
multiple users can access the database
at the same time it provides a host of
services that enable developers to focus
on business logic it also provides cash
management to reduce load on database
surrogate key identifier and other key
features can be automated in the or so
the Java
application will connect to the or API
which facilitates create update delete
operations the or engine will facilitate
the creation of the mapping information
for the Java class that you create here
to actual SQL statements for the
database and the jdbc driver will
connect the Java application finally to
the database so it is the orm that is
doing the mapping from to your objects
that you write in the Java application
to tables that are actually updated and
created in the
database let's look at hibernate as an
orm framework from a architectural
feature persistence and API
perspective as an object relational
mapping framework hibernate is concerned
with data persistence as it applies to
relational databases via jdbc dbms
specific details and mapping file
details are specified in a file called
hibernate Doc configuration.xml and
mapping file. XML the hibernate engine
using the uses these files to generate
dbms specific syntax so the Java
application will have all the
configuration for your hibernate written
in the CFG XML file you can also have a
mapping file if you want to map table
names
to column names in the XML file and
finally we connect to the database
management
system hibernate orm provides its own
native API in addition to full jpa which
is the Java persistence API it maps
pojos of java objects to relational
databases it provides a rich tool set it
has better performance for caching
fetching and enhancing code performance
and it is also part of the Joss
Community this is where we can go and
download the latest version of
ibate the jpa provides a standard
persistent API as part of ejb 3.0
specification it is supported by all
major vendors of java industry hyate
model implements Java persistent object
relationship API and the hibernate
persistence provider can be used in any
environment of java platform be it the
standard or the Enterprise
Edition so here is the hybernate
programming model you create the
hibernate dogf CFG configuration object
you load the metadata information you
then create a session Factory object you
then make a hibernate API call on a
session object you close the session and
you close the session
Factory so the Java application will
create the persistence
object the entire hibernate framework
consists of the session Factory a
session a transaction a transaction
Factory and a connection provider and
the internal API which is used by
hibernate is the JTA the jdbc and the JN
di let's look at each of these
components of the architecture in detail
the session object is created within the
database layer in every Dow method or
data access object method it is known as
the persistence object it has three life
cycle States the transient state where
an object is transient if it has just
been instantiated using the new operator
and it is not associated with hibernate
session it is in a persistent state if
it has a representation in the database
and an identify a value it might have
been saved or loaded however it is by
definition in the scope of the session
detached is an object that has been
persistent but its session has been
closed the reference to the object is
still valid of close and the detach
instance might even be modified in this
state the hibernate core apis start with
the
configuration now you can see here the
or. hybernate CFG which gives two
services in the hybernate application it
loads the mapping file and configuration
file into memory and makes them
available to hybernate engine it also
acts as a factory to create the session
Factory the session Factory which is
part of a. hibernate session Factory the
hibernate engine implements this session
Factory
interface it is one per dbms mostly one
per application that you create it is
thread safe it is not a Singleton which
means it creates a session object the
session Factory encapsulates second
level cache connection pool meta
information cache and pool of the
session the hybernate interface also
contains the session the hibernate
engine implements the session interface
session object acts as a persistent
manager it is a lightweight object it
encap encapsulates connection and first
level cache session object is not thread
safe in every da method session object
is created it is used for crtd
operations the hybernate engine also
implements the transaction interface
when database connection is created by
hybernate connection associated with
session is in autocommit disable mode
whenever a cred operation is performed
the changes will not be reflected in the
database unless connection is maintain
in autocommit enabled
mode all the generator classes implement
the identify generator interface this
application will help the programmer and
may create own generator classes by
implementing this interface hibernate
framework provides many buil-in
generator classes you have assigned the
default value has to be explicitly
aligned to persistent object before you
persist it increment it increments value
by one it generates short in or long
identifiers native it use identity
sequence or below depending on the
database vendor sequence it uses the
sequence of the database if there is no
sequence defined it creates a sequence
automatically for example in the case of
an Oracle database it creates a sequence
named hibernate uncore
sequence it is used in high and low
algorithms to generate the ID of type
shot in and long finally the identity it
is used in sbase MySQL SQL Server B2 and
SQL to support the ID column The
Returned ID is of type short in or long
so it autog generates the ID which could
be the primary key in your
table how do you set up a project with
hibernate step one you create a Java
project you add the required JS and
libraries from the hibernate downloads
you then add the jdbc driver or a
specific jar file to connect to your
respective data store create the pojo
class save it in the SRC folder of your
project you then create the hybernate
configuration file which is similar to
the web XML file and you specify which
dialect of SQL are you using depending
on the databas is listed here my SQL db2
Oracle you then create the hbm.xml file
which is the mapping file and finally
you create the class that retrieves or
stores the persistent object and saves
it in the SRC folder and then you go
ahead and run the application
so first you download the latest version
of hibernate you click on the right
click on the project click on build path
click on ADD external jazs and you add
all the required hibernate jazs that you
downloaded then you download the my SQL
connector assuming you're connecting to
a SQL my SQL database or equivalently
the driver for the Oracle
database you then create the pojo class
that needs to be persisted into the the
database in terms of its object so here
we have role number and
name then you create the hibernate
configuration XML file here you see the
property mappings done you see the
connection URL to the database you see
the username password you see the driver
name you see the auto property set to
create which indicates every time you
run the application it will create the
table if the table exists it will drop
it and create a new table and here is
the mapping to the mapping file which
Maps the column names to attributes that
you have in the
class step five you can actually see the
mapping done name student table student
table the ID and the name are being
mapped then you create the configuration
object by creating an object of standard
service registry you then call configure
you pass the the XML config file then
you create an object of metadata call
the build method and finally an object
of the session Factory by calling the
build method of the get session Factory
Builder you can use property
names as create update create drop to
avoid creating the student table
manually so every time you have a change
and if you set it to update
automatically you will see that the has
been updated in the database Within You
Without You having to manually write the
SQL statement and this is the SQL that
will be generated in case you put the
value as create here instead of update
which means the existing student table
if it is already there in the database
it will be dropped and a new student
table will be created every time you
execute the
application let's talk about annotations
in
hibernate you have learned how iberet
uses XML mapping file for the
transformation of data from post Ojo to
database tables and vice
versa hibernate annotations is the
newest way to define mappings without
the use of XML file you can use
annotations in addition to or as a
replacement of XML mapping metadata so
if you're using annotations you do not
need to create a separate XML mapper
file which will map the values or the
attributes inside your class to the
fields in the
database so here you just need to
specify at the rate entity as an
anotation on top of your class at theate
table as well at the rate ID if you're
defining anything as a primary key at
the rate colum if you want to change the
name of the column from a database
perspective and simply save this file
and provide a mapping in the hibernate
CFG XML that's all you need to do so you
save the effort of creating a separate
XML file purely for doing a mapping of
the class attributes to the column names
in the database so here you you see we
are creating a configuration. configure
then we configuring and loading that XML
file and creating a metadata object and
calling build on it and finally
instantiating the session Factory if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more let's talk about create update
delete operations the acronym Crut
stands for create read update and delete
there are four basic operations that any
data driven application performs which
is create read update delete now
hibernate supports these operations by
means of a session
interface now multiple persistence
objects cannot be retrieved and this is
the limitation of using session methods
multiple delete and update operations
are not possible in parallel the
required criteria cannot be expressed to
perform some complex Crut operations to
overcome the above limit limitations we
have hql which is hibernate query
language the criteria API and Native SQL
which is structured query
language what is hql it gives query
language provided by hibernate it is the
same as SQL but it doesn't depend on the
table of the database it uses classes
the criteria API is one way of querying
the database in hibernate application it
can be used for dbml
operations criteria API is an
objectoriented after native for hql to
read data from database and it supports
compile time checking for the query that
we built unlike
hql here is a create operation we create
a configuration object a standard
registry object we then load the
hibernate configuration file we then
create a session Factory open a session
object begin a transaction create a new
student object set the values as role
number and name and save that into the
session call a commit on the transaction
and close this will create the table in
the database and insert the first record
inside it if you need to read the data
this block of code until the session
Factory remains common then you again
open the session begin a transaction get
that particular student class object by
passing the primary key and simply print
the value for an update operation this
remains constant you then open the
transaction you then get that
particular record of the student or the
student object by passing the ID and
simply do an update for a delete process
Remains the Same get the student details
call delete on the
session let's look at a demo on how to
work with hybernate the first thing we
will need is of course to install the
hibernate
API so the hibernate software is
available and you just need to go ahead
and download it from the hibernate
website you can Google for it and simply
then go ahead and unzip it okay
so if I go to this is the hibernate
folder that we've downloaded and you
just need to unzip it and you will
actually see uh all the files and the
jars inside it that are already there so
this is the file that we need and you
have a set of jars that we will actually
need uh so these are the set of jars
that we will need to import inside our
application so once you install the
hibernate
API you then need to just go and
download and install any database of
your choice in ask uh in this demo I
have installed MySQL the installation
document for MySQL and hibernate has
been provided to you in the LMS so you
can access it and complete the
installation of my SQL and hibernate uh
in case you need support on that
and uh eclipse of course will be our
editor and besides that we will download
the MySQL workbench so the MySQL
workbench installation document is also
been provided so you can go ahead and
download it and once you download the
MySQL workbench you will see that the
installation or the instance of MySQL is
available to you you just need to click
on
that it says opening in the
editor just ignore this and it is that's
about
it okay so that's all we need to
do
uh to connect to uh the
MySQL
instance and
uh once you get the MySQL workbench
installation done and the MyQ SQL
installation done you simply start
writing your SQL commands out here which
will start generating your database
names and then we will go ahead with
configuring our Eclipse application to
create a simple Java pojo class which
will via annotations as we saw we will
map it to the particular database that
we create
here let's start with creating the new
database so we'll say create
database and let's say hibernate
demo we'll execute this and you can see
the database has got successfully
created let's come to our Eclipse now
here we'll create a new
project we'll select Java
project the name
name hibernate
demo see new
project Java
project
oops Java project
next
here hibernate
demo
next we'll click on
libraries add external
jars and we will add our jdbc
driver so let's go
to
this is the hibernate folder so I'm
moving to the hibernate folder first
we'll go to our lip
folder and inside that required and we
will select all the files and open and
say
finish okay so it would have added all
the references as you can see here so
the libraries the
correct references have been
added now we'll need to also
add the
MySQL
driver so let's
go
[Music]
to the
web open
Firefox and we'll just
Google okay and here let's say we want
the
MySQL Java
connector or
driver
that should take us to the MySQL
website okay and here you
see uh the driver available we'll pick
the zip file so we'll say
download start
download okay
okay and it has downloaded the driver so
I'm just going to pick it up and put it
into my folder that says
jars and we'll just extract it
here
okay now the moment that is done we'll
come to our Eclipse we'll again go to
build path and
configure add external
jars go
back let me go to my jars
folder
and okay doesn't figure out so let me
check again it is in this
folder so we'll go and go to the build
path
configure add external
charts give the path here and pick up
the my SQL connector apply apply and
close so that has been
added now let's create a new
package for our pojo
class and we'll say com
dot transfer object
we'll create a new class within
it and let's name it player for example
finish let me add data
members start with a player
ID
let's
add player
name let's
add team
[Music]
name let's add
h
uh okay that's my
Constructor get rid of
this let's add from The Source the
Getters and setters
we'll also
generate a two
string two string method and save this
and let's also go to the source and
generate a parameterized
Constructor now time to add the
annotations for Entity
framework so we'll say at the rate
entity
we'll pick it from the Java x.p
persistence do
entity
package
then the player class is going to be a
table so we'll add at theate table as
another
annotation and we want the player ID to
be a primary key so we will add at the
rate ID above the player
ID
now let's
browse
to the hibernate
folder and within it we will search for
hibernate.cfg.xml
and you will see that there are couple
of CFG XML files that come up and these
are the readymade configuration files
that are there in the folder so we could
just pick one and and use
it
so uh I've just picked uh a typic a file
from that
location okay and uh I'm just going to
use it
uh so I'm just copy pasted a CFG file
after searching for it randomly so I'm
just selecting that coming
[Music]
to Eclipse
again clicking on the SRC and just
pasting so here's the file that we
pasted so if you go to the file the
first thing that we have is a database
connection setting where we provide the
driver name the URL
Etc then next we have the connection
pool setting to set the pool size we
have the SQL dialect depending on which
database you're connecting to we have
the cache if you want to turn it on or
off this is the line that will spit out
the SQL that J uh hibernate framework
will automatically be creating for us
this will allow us to drop and create
the table it will create the table at
the first run and on every subsequent
run it will modify and recreate the
table so it will drop the table and
recreate cre it now you see a mapping
class here here we will map it to com.
2.
player okay so that's the change we have
made then let's come to
class and this will be com do MySQL
do jdbc do
driver
let's come to the connection
string jdbc colon MySQL since we are
connecting to a mySQL
database Local Host the port number for
my SQL by default is
3306 and the table name we created or
the database name we created was
hibernate
demo
the
username on installation I had provided
as root and the password was also root
so we'll save
that next the SQL
dialect we will give it as my
SQL
diet
we'll
add one more value name equal
to current underscore
session
uncore
context underscore
class and we'll set this to
thread so that every session runs in a
separate thread and it's thread
safe so we are pretty much done with
uh the configuration of
uh I'll just validate
the so this
is hibernate demo and that's exactly the
same thing that we will provide here
now time to add a new package so let's
do
that com
dot
control We'll add a new
class and call it hibernate
main add a public static white main to
this
class have it ready so that's going to
be our entry
point first thing we'll create the
configuration
so we have created the configuration
first
configuration equal to
new
oops equal to new
configuration
Dot
configure just get rid of
this let's get this
from hibernate
package and then we will
say configuration
dot
add annotated class and our class name
will be com. 2
dot player dot class
then next we create
standard
service registry
Builder
Builder equal to
New Standard service registry
Builder Dot apply
settings
and
configuration dot
get
properties we put this onto the next
line
so this will go ahead and get us all the
configuration that is
available uh inside our configuration
class that we
specified so the first step we are
creating an object
of the configuration
class the second
step we are going ah
ahead and
creating an object of
standard service registry
Builder we are also adding our class
that had annotations with
it and that
class with the
annotations is nothing but the player
class
so this line of
code will
actually
allow us to apply the
settings of the configuration file that
we have set up post that we will
create a session Factory
object equal
to
configuration dot build session Factory
and we will
pass
the Builder dot build
method next we start creating the
session equal to factory dot Open
session let's add the hibernate names
space for
session
then we create a
transaction equal to session
dot begin
transaction then we create a player
object equal to
new player and we pass some
values
we import com. 2 and
also the transaction
package should be the hibernate
equivalent so we'll get that one
we also need to give a fourth parameter
here which is the team name so we'll
specify that then we use the session
object to
save the player
object post that
we say
transaction. commit so that it persist
the transaction and then we do a session
Dot
close okay so here we are setting up the
configuration we then adding the
annotated class which is player we
creating the Builder object loading all
the configuration properties from the
XML file we created setting up the
session Factory passing the Builder to
it which is the configuration
information we then opening a session
opening a transaction creating a new
record in terms of the object and hence
it's called object relationship mapper
because we just create a new object use
the session to save it and commit the
transaction and it will automatically
create a table with the right name and
insert that record into the
database
okay
so now all we need to do is attempt to
execute it so we'll just
check the SQL connector is referenced
we'll go to
our hibernate config
file and we'll just validate so we had
set the dialect
and it is trying to reach
the trying to load the class which is
the information class or rather the
driver so com. MySQL jdbc do driver so
let's run a check on
that save
this
let's change
this and use my SQL
dialect oops come back to the
hibernate
okay executed the incorrect file so
let's run it
again you delete the additional file
that got created come back to the
hypernet
file attemp to run
that save
all
so the update that we did to the code
firstly uh we have just changed the
driver alphabet D to uppercase which is
system defined and case pen
specific and uh the next change that we
will have to do is uh we'll have to add
the entire name space uh
to the equal dialect class so we will
say
orc
dot hibernate so this is the package
name dot dialect
LCT do MySQL 5 dialect so we've said a.
hibernate do
dialect.
MySQL
Dil okay and my SQL 5 is the updated
version of the SQL equal dialect class
that will automatically convert and
write the SQL statements to insert the
data into the
database and also create the updated
table for
me right so the these are the two
changes that we have done and the code
here continues to remain the same we
have a player object that we are trying
to store into the
database so we'll execute
this and and let's look at the output
whether
it okay
so you can see here now uh because in
the config file we had actually given
this uh configuration which says show
SQL true it has actually generated the
SQL statements in the background so it
says drop table if player exists and
that was because we gave the auto mode
here to create then it creates the new
table and you see the SQL that is
returned
automatically written for US based on
the structure or the attributes in the
class and then it has attempted to
insert a new record of type player into
the
database okay but has it actually
happened and updated in the database so
we'll go to our
SQL okay here we will just validate
whether the update has really happened
has it created a table out here and are
we able to R of the data so we'll say
select
star
from hibernate demo
dot
player okay and you see the data that we
actually inserted has come up inside the
database let's try with an
additional
record save this come
here and let us add another
player change the age
value and we will
also so we've created a new player P2
and we are saving it into the database
and you see after we've executed it
drops the table creates the new table
and it inserts the data into the table
okay what I've also done is I've just
introduced a TR catch block so in case
there are any errors where we have gone
wrong it would return the error messages
to us right else it's the the code
continues to remain the same with just
the new record so let's check in the
database now we'll execute this and here
you see the second record that we just
inserted has available in the
database now let's go back
here let's
comment the second record and the save
statement as as
well and let's
modify the value of the first record
from Amit to
verat now when we execute this let's see
what
happens so you see it's dropped the
table created the table again and then
inserted as individual Player record so
if we
go to the
database you can see that it's now the
updated value but it has recreated the
entire table and hence the second record
is
gone let's now if we need to preserve
the records and just do an update to an
individual record without updating the
entire table let's change this flag from
create to update and save
this and now when we come back
here we will
uncomment the second record and comment
the first one since it's already
there so we'll comment this and
uncomment the second player and
execute it's now generated a single
insert command let's check in the the
database what has happened so we had one
record you can see now it did not drop
the table it just updated it with the
second
record let's check what is that we'll
need to do if we want to retrieve a
record so to retrieve a
record let's say player P equal to we'll
use the session object dot
get player. class we
want a object of type player return to
us and let's say we want the first
record so we'll give the key as
10 and we'll simply
print the details plus p so we have a
two string that we have overridden in
the class so that should do the job for
us let's execute
this and there you see the player
details are returned for the first
player now let's say I want to write
some code to probably update those
player details so we can say player dot
set player name and change
it to another
player
and we'll say p do set
age so we've set the name and the age
let's execute
this and it says update player so you
see the statement update statement being
generated here let's check in the
database the current value is vat for
player ID 10 let's update
and you can see it has changed moment I
refresh what if you want to delete a
record we said it's used for create read
update delete we have done create read
update let's try the
delete so here we'll simply use the
session object dot delete and we will
pass
P1 or rather P which is the object that
we have just retrieved
now when we run
this delete form player where player ID
is this and you can see when I come here
let's refresh the table and you can see
the first record has got
deleted now similarly we have multiple
annotations
available so let's assume that we want
to autoincrement
the player ID every time a new player
Accord is generated so for
that we'll say Source we'll
create a
Constructor with just player name team
name and
AG so we've created a parameterized
Constructor we do not need the ID to be
passed we want to autogenerate
it and we'll say generated
value strategy equal
to we use the enumeration generation
type do
identity now this will
autogenerate the ID every time we try to
insert a record so let's come here and
we will
comment the delete
code let's
now add code to try and insert a
record so we'll add two player
objects P1 and
P2 give it 70 and oh we don't need these
values now so we'll get rid of
it so we just
need the names
so we've just given the names there and
we'll
say session. save
P1 and session. save
P2
now we'll go back to here and we will
say create since we have recreating the
table since we have changed the column
configuration and we'll come to our Java
code and execute
it let's go
now and refresh and you can see the
player ID 1 and two was Auto incremented
with and generated with the new values
that we just
added
similarly if we want we can also update
the column
name so let's say that for player name
we want to provide a different name for
the column in the database so we will
say
column name equal to
name and
let's say we want a different name for
the table as well so here we'll say name
equal
to player uncore table so we've changed
the table name from the database
perspective that we want
create and for the
column if you want to put a constraint
where you do not want null values to be
stored you can say nullable equal to
false
now let's come
back save the application and
execute let's come here and select from
instead of
saying player we'll say player uncore
table which is the new table and you see
the new table got
generated and you see see the name
actually the player name was converted
to name and that is the setting that we
had provided so this shows us how to
create insert read and update data using
the or hibernate and how easy it is to
provide annotations in the object class
and automatically map The Entity model
to the database create the table and
insert records what exactly is Java
Enterprise
Edition the Java e stands for Java
Enterprise Edition which was earlier
known as j2e and is currently known as
jaraka e the Java Enterprise Edition
provides a platform for developers with
Enterprise features such as distributed
computing and web services now let's
move further and understand why exactly
we needed Java Enterprise Edition we
needed Java Enterprise Edition for four
major reasons to have powerful API
support to reduce development time to
reduce application complexity and
finally to improve the application
performance so followed by the need for
Java Enterprise Edition we will move
ahead and understand the Java Enterprise
specifications so in the Java Enterprise
specifications we are going to discuss
the four major specifications used by
Enterprise developers so the first one
being the Enterprise specification
followed by that we have web
specification then we have web s
specification and finally some other
miscellaneous specifications we shall
discuss each one of them in detail
firstly we will move ahead with
Enterprise specification so in
Enterprise specification we have the
first one to discuss that is the context
dependency injection the context
dependency injection provides a
container to inject dependencies as in
swing next we have Java Enterprise Java
Bean the Enterprise Java Bean is a set
of lightweight apis that an object
container possesses in order to provide
transactions remote procedure calls and
concurrency
control followed by Java Bean we have
Java persistent apis so the Java
persistent API are the specifications of
object relational mapping between
relational database tables and Java
classes next we have the Java
transaction API it consists of java
interfaces and annotations to establish
interaction between Java transaction
support offered by Java Enterprise
Edition the apis in the abstract from
lowlevel detail to the interfaces are
also considered as lowlevel followed by
Java transaction API we have the Java
serlet the Java serlet specifications
Define how you can manage HTTP request
either in a synchronous or asynchronous
way so followed by Java transaction API
which is one of the Enterprise specific
a we will move ahead into the Java web
specifications so the first one in the
Java web specification is the Java
serlet so this specification defines how
you can manage the HTTP request either
in a synchronous or asynchronous way it
is lowlevel and other specifications
completely depend on it so followed by
Java serlet we have the Java web socket
so the Java web socket is a computer
communication protocol and this API
provides a set of apis to facilitate web
socket
connections followed by websocket we
have the Java server faces so the Java
server faces is a service which helps in
building graphical user interface out of
the components so followed by Java
server faces we have the unified
expression language the unified
expression language is a simple language
which was designed to facilitate web
application developers so followed by
the web specification now we will enter
the web service specification out of
which we have the first one which is the
riskful web service so the Java restful
API web service provides services having
representational State transfer schema
next we have the Json processing Java
API for Json processing is a set of
specifications to manage the information
provided in a Json format followed by
Json processing we have Json binding so
the Java API for Json binding is a set
of specifications that provide for
binding or passing a Json file into Java
classes next we have the XML binding so
XML binding simply allows for binding of
XML into Java objects for example soap
is an XML based protocol to access web
services over HTTP this API allows you
to create soap web services so followed
by the web service specifications of
java Enterprise Edition we finally enter
into the other miscellaneous
specifications of java Enterprise
Edition so out of that the first one is
the validation so the validation package
consists of various interfaces and
annotations for declarative validation
support offered by Bean validation API
in Java followed by validation we have
the batch applications so the batch
applications provide the means to run
long running background task which
involve large volume of data and which
need to be periodically executed
followed by batch applications we have
Java Enterprise connector architecture
so the Java Enterprise Edition connector
is a Java based technological solution
for connecting Java service to
Enterprise information system so with
this we will enter into our next step
where we will learn the system
requirements to install Java Enterprise
Edition so the basic requirements to
install Java Enterprise Edition into
your local system are you should be
having the Java virtual machine from the
standard six Edition or more followed by
that your local system should be having
at least 1 GB of RAM capacity next your
system should be having at least 250 GB
ROM space available and finally you
should be having the Java development
kit installed into your local system now
next we will understand how to install
Java Enterprise Edition into your local
system so in short these are the the
steps you need to follow to install Java
Enterprise Edition into your local
system first you need to browse into the
Oracle official Java site then go to
Java standard edition development kit
followed by that accept the license
terms download the jdk file run the jdk
file as an administrator in your local
system then set up the Java environment
I know this looks a little bit complex
but don't worry I will drop a link in
the description box below which will
explain you in a much detailed way how
to install Java into your local system
please check that to have a better
understanding of how to install and set
up Java in your local system so followed
by this we will learn the differences
between the Java standard edition and
Java Enterprise Edition so the first
difference between the standard edition
and the Enterprise Edition is the
standard edition provides basic
functionalities like defining classes
and objects whereas Java Enterprise
Edition mainly focuses on high-end and
corporate type of Java applications the
second difference between the both is
Java Standard Edition comes with only
the standard specifications which will
be used bya beginner and similarly on
the other hand Java Enterprise Edition
comes with some Advanced specifications
which support web applications and
servlets the third difference between
the both is the Java Standard Edition
comes with features like class libraries
and deployment environments whereas the
Java Enterprise Edition has structured
application with clients business and
Enterprise layers the fourth difference
between the both
is the Java standard edition is used for
desktop and mobile application
developments whereas on the other hand
the Java Enterprise Edition is used
mainly for development of web
applications the fifth difference
between the both is the Java standard
edition is preferred and used by
beginners and on the other hand the Java
Enterprise Edition is preferred and used
by experts in Java
field the sixth difference between the
both is the Java standard edition does
not have authentication whereas on the
other hand there are strict rules and
regulations to be followed when using
Java Enterprise Edition related to
authentication the problems in
Enterprise application development with
serlet and JSP serlet and code are not
usable web designing tools can't be used
in case of seret parallel development is
not possible to solve the problems and
Microsystems introduced a two design
patterns for developing Enterprise
applications model one page Centric
model and model to
MVC so here we have a request coming in
to the JSP page the request is forwarded
to the Java Bean so that the object can
be created it connects to the Enterprise
server or data source and then the
response is generated to the
browser request is sent by browser and
received by JSP Java Bean object is
created and business methods are called
if required it communicates with the
databases to get the required data JSP
then displays the processed data to the
end user there is no clear separation of
responsibility JSP access both
controller and View and the business
logic is separated using Java P so now
here you can see that the request comes
to the seret which access the controller
the serlet can actually connect to the
model Java Bean which maps to the data
source using some omm like
hibernate
that content can directly be pushed into
the JSP as well in case there is no data
and it can then go to the model bean and
retrieve data from the database via the
JSP as well and finally the response is
sent to the
browser controller or seret receives
request from browser and captures the
input controller invokes the business
method of model or Java pan model
connects with database and gets business
data model sends response to controller
keeps the process data and Heap memory
request session and serlet context and
controller switches the control to
appropriate view of the application the
limitations of the MVC model clear
separation of responsibility code
reusability single point entry for
application and support for multiple
view Technologies spring MVC is used to
develop web application that uses MVC
design pattern spring MVC is meant to
make web applications development faster
cost effective and
flexible contents of spring MVC we have
the dispatcher serlet we have the
Handler mapping the controller mode and
View and view
resolver the dispatcher seret it is
given by apring framework. dispatcher
serlet it controls the front controller
design pattern and whatever URL comes
from client seret intercepts the client
request before passing the request
object to controller in the web config
file write seret mapping in such such a
way that dispatcher serlet is invoked
for client
request then we have the Handler mapping
it is an interface implemented by
objects to Define mapping between
request and Handler objects when a
request is made to Springs dispatcher
serate it hands over the request to
Handler mapping Handler mapping inspects
the request identifies the appropriate
Handler execution chain and it delivers
it to dispatcher
serate handle mapping provided by Spring
MVC module can be implemented in many
ways Bean name URL Handler mapping which
is the default Handler mapping class
that Maps the URL request to the name of
the beans if URL pattern welcome. HTM is
requested dispatcher seret will forward
the request to welcome controller if
Street name. HTM is requested it will
forward the request to street name
controller and if process credit. HTM is
requested it will forward the request to
process
controller the controller are components
that are called by dispatcher surate for
any kind of business logic all
controllers Implement controller
interface the types of controllers are
abstract multi-action and Abstract
wizard form there are components called
view resolver their job is to provide
mapping between logical view name and
actual physical location of the view
resource then we have the model and view
it is represented by class a. springf
framework. web. seret model and View and
is returned by the controller object
back to the dispatcher seret this class
is just a container class for holding
the model and the view information the
model object represents some piece of
information that can be used by the view
to display the information this gives
abstraction in the spring framework any
kind of view technology can be plugged
into the framework like Excel Jasper
reports PDF xslt free marker HTML tiles
are supported
Frameworks then we have the view
resolver it is an interface implemented
by objects to resolve views using name
String mvc's module it encapsulates the
module View and the view object in a
single entity which is represented by
the object of class model and view to
resolve the view object dispatch a seret
view resolver is used inter resource
view resolver it resolves The Logical
name of the view to an internal resource
by prefixing The Logical view name with
the resource path and suffixing it with
the extension it resolves The Logical
name of the view to the bean name which
will render the output to the user the
bean should be defined in Spring app
context file this view resolver is the
same as Bean name view resolver the only
difference is that instead of looking
for the beans and springs application
context file it looks for beans defined
in a separate XML
file spring MVC framework the spring MVC
web framework provides model view
controller architecture that can be used
to develop flexible and Loosely coupled
web
apps so here we see the steps the
request comes to the serlet dispatcher
it goes to the Handler mapping the
Handler mapping sends back to the
respect dispatcher serlet that access
the controller we then call the Handler
request method on the controller which
calls the business methods on the
service which inter calls the Dao method
which talks to the database and gets the
response the response is sent to the
service sent back to the
controller sent back to the serlet
dispatcher which forwards it to the view
resolver so the Right View can be
returned to the seret dispatcher the
seret dispatcher then picks up the model
attaches it to the view and generates
the response so client requests a
resource in the web application the
spring front controller dispatch Ser
requests the Handler mapping to identify
the particular controller for given URL
Handler mapping identifies the
controller and sends it to the
dispatcher servet dispatcher serlet
calls handled request method and passes
these two objects to the controller
controller calls the business method
service class calls the da method for
business data da interacts with the
database to get the data database shares
the result da returns this result data
to service Dow data is processed
according to business requirement and
returns to controller controller returns
model and view object back to font
controller dispatcher resolves actual
view by Consulting The View resolver
object view resolver Enders view to the
dispatcher dispatcher serlet consults
the view to the dispatcher serlet View
executes and returns HTML to the
dispatcher serlet dispatcher serlet
sends output to the
browser the request processing workflow
of spring web MVC dispatcher subet is
Illustrated in the following diagram the
Handler
mapping going to the dispatcher serlet
second is the
controller data exchange with the
dispatcher serlet then it communicates
with the view resolver and finally The
View and the response is sent
out after receiving an HTTP request
dispatcher serlet consults the Handler
mapping to call the appropriate
controller the controller takes the
request and calls the appropriate
service method based on used getop post
method the service method will set model
data based on defined business logic and
return view name to the dispatcher
serlet the dispatcher serlet will take
help from view resolver to pick up the
defined View for the request once view
is finalized the dispatcher serlet
passes the model data to the view that
is finally rendered on the
browser configurations required for
spring MVC map request that you want the
dispatcher Ser to handle using URL
mapping in web XML create serlet name
seret XML file Define a controller
create a
view so you map request that you want
the dispatcher seret to Handle by using
URL mapping in web XML file use the
following code decare map Hollow web
dispatcher seret the web.xml file will
be kept in web INF
directory then you create the seret XML
file framework will try to load the
application context from a file named
seret XML located in the application's
web content directory the file name is
hellow web.xml the serlet name XML file
will be used to create the defined beans
override the definitions of beans with
the same name in the global
scope the component scan tag will be
used to activat ring MVC annotation
scanning capability which allows you to
make use of annotations like controller
and request mapping and the internal
resource viewer resolver will have rules
defined to resolve the view
names we Define a controller the at
theate controller annotation indicates
that a particular class serves the role
of a controller the at theate request
mapping annotation is used to map a URL
to either an entire class or a
particular handra method the request
mapping method is used to declare the
print hello method as the controller's
default service method to handle h HTTP
get requests then we create a View
Spring MVC supports many types of views
for different presentation Technologies
these include GSP HTML PDF Excel
worksheet XML velocity template xslt
Json view in web choose from over 300 in
demand skills and get access to 1,000
plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
finally the spring MVC program let's
write a simple web- based application
using spring MVC to create a spring MVC
model to display hello world so the
request will come in here saying hello.
GSP we will use at theate request map
ping then the dispatcher serate will
communicate with the hello controller
then the internal resolver View resolver
and finally the is hello. JSP which will
generate the response the hello world
example uses spring web MVC framework to
follow the model view controller
architecture the controller is
responsible for processing user requests
and building an appropriate model it
then passes the model to the view for
rendering in this example hello
controller Java classes controller the
view is responsible for rendering the
model data in general it generates HTML
output that the client's browser can
interpret in this example hello. GSP is
the
view we create a dynamic web project
with the name hello web we then add J
file to web content web INF lib then we
create a Java class hello controller
under SRC folder then we create spring
configuration file web XML and hello Ser
lit under the web cont content INF
folder then we create a subfolder with a
name JSP under web content then we
create a view file hello JSP under the
subfolder the final step is to create
the content of all the source and config
files and Export the
application here are the steps we create
a dynamic web project that we have
already learned we add the following
jars serlet API common logging spring
aop spring beans spring context spring
core spring expression spring web MVC
and spring web then we write the at
theate controller and request mapping
to/ hello we write the controller with
the request method as get and we say
model. add attribute message hello
spring
framework then we create the spring
config file that Maps the dispatcher
seret object and the hello web then we
map the spring framework internal
resource view resolver as well and we
put the web INFJs P property mapped to
that particular folder path then we
create the subfolder with a view hello.
JSP which simply returns hello world and
dollar of message is the
expression to run the application we say
Local Host Port hello web and hello
we'll write a simple web based
application that makes use of HTML form
using spring MVC framework to submit the
data to the controller and display a
processed result so the moment we say
project name/ employee it will go to the
dispatch
dispatch a seret which will talk to the
employee controller retrieve the
employee object move to the internal
resource riew resolver which picks up
the result. JSP and employee. JSP views
and send it out as a HTTP
response MVC architecture for form
handling example the form handling
example uses spring MVC framework it
follows model view control architecture
the model encapsulates the application
data and consists of pojo it creates
employee class containing ID name and AG
the controller is responsible for
processing user request building an
appropriate model and passes it to the
view for entering it creates an employee
controller. Java class to call employee
class methods the view is responsible
for entering the model data and in
general it generates HTML output that
the client browser can interpret Java
JSP files result. JSP and employ JSP are
used to display employees
information steps to write a web based
application using string MVC we create a
dynamic web project and add the required
jav files we then map the request that
you want the dispatcher serlo to Handle
by using URL mapping in web XML you then
create the Java class employee you then
create employee controller in SRC folder
you then create spring config web XML
and seret XML under web contact wef you
then create a sub folder with the name
JSP under web contact INF you then
create view file employee. JSP you then
create second view file result. JSP and
the final step is to create the content
of all the source and config files and
Export the application now we create a
dynamic make web project and add the
required jav files common logging or
spring framework ASM or spring framework
beam or spring framework context or
spring framework core expression web
serlet web and spring web. jar we then
Define the spring web configuration file
web.xml where we set up the dispatcher
serlet we give the serlet name as hello
web we then set up the employee class
with age name and
ID we then create the controller with a
request mapping of a URL /m employee and
map to a request. get method we then
return model and view with the employee
and command and the new employee object
we then do another mapping for the
request method. poost this is from the
form data to be posted we provide the
add employee method and add attribute
mappings for name age and ID next we
create a spring config file web XML and
serlet XML which map the GSP page then
we create a subfolder in a view which
Maps the view information as a employee.
JSP file where we create a simple table
to print out the data we create a second
view called result. JSP which has a
separate table that this gives us the
name age and ID of the
employee we create content for all the
source and config files and we run the
application let's look at a demo on
Spring web
MVC let's start with a small demo
demonstrating the capability of spring
web MVC so let's move to Eclipse so
spring MVC is an end to-end solution for
complete web app
development the serlet plays the role of
the controller and JSP plays the role of
the view it follows the fun controller
design pattern this means there will be
a serlet as a controller and the model
caters to collecting the data there is
complete sync between the model the view
is handled by the controller which is a
form of MVC design
pattern so springing MVC has a front
controller which is the dispatcher
serlet so we have created a dynamic web
project and we have added the
libraries so the reference libraries are
all the spring libraries in addition to
that we have added the commons
logging which is the other important
library that we have
added we have a views folder that has
four views home profile register trainy
and
success let's look at
the web.xml
file here we have the dispatcher serlet
configured with the name as my serlet
and here we are configuring my subet
with a URL pattern of Slash
indicating that any request that comes
to the dispatcher serlet which acts as a
controller will be catered to by the
dispatcher serlet so the moment you put
a slash which is the root URL in the
address bar the request will come and
hit the dispatcher
serlet then we have the my seret d
serlet dox XL
file so here we can actually see that
the sprig web container is going to look
for this file it is going to look for
JSP Pages inside this path which is web
in/ views and that is where we have
stored our JSP
Pages it will search for the controllers
in the com. controllers
package
and here in the source in the com.
controllers package we have set up a
controllers as you can see here the
internal resource view resolver will
find out which particular JSP page is to
be returned so the prefix is the path
where the JSP are stored and the suffix
is it's going to postfix all the view
names with a DOT GSP
extension next we come to to the my
controller. Java
file we use The annotation controller we
are mapping to the root so if somebody
gives the URL the end user passes the
URL as a slash we are going to print
home in the console and simply return
the home. GSP page so the suffix will be
appended to
this we have another
function called say name so in
case we request for this particular URL
route we will get the first name
parameter from a form we will map the
attribute of this particular value first
name and we will return the profile view
which is again present in the views
folder as we see here we have a third
route set up for the URL login so if the
URL is/ login we will will trap the
username and password fields from the
form we will check if the username and
password equals Tom and Jerry we will
add the attribute and we will return the
profile page if there is an error we
will simply return an error message so
that
constitutes the my
controller let's look at the
home.jsp we have the same name AC method
which will post to the same
name request map that we saw in the
controller the method is post we have a
submit button with Fame and we have a
login controller with username and
password and a submit button and this is
mapping to the action method login and
those are the two action methods we saw
we're mapping to say name or
login we'll come to the home page and
we'll execute
this we'll go to the default route which
is just a slash which takes us to the
homepage and
here it simply gives us a welcome
message as of now which says
hello welcome to Spring which we see is
the
default welcome message that we are
actually getting and we also have a say
name function that is actually getting
mapped when we click on this button
and we are going to route to a success
page so here let's
print first name and we can see
here that we actually going to map to
the first name function and if we go to
the
controller we have created an attribute
first name to which we are mapping this
value okay and we are simply returning
the user information so in case there is
a success it will simply go ahead and
route to that
particular URL so we'll just
provide or rather let's me go here
rather than the success and we'll make
that change so we'll go to the profile
because we navigating there and here we
have a first name and now if you see
here we are saying that we are going to
post this form to save name first name
is going to be the attribute that we
going to trap and we're going to return
profile so the first name attribute that
we are going to trap
here if you look at the
home.jsp okay the user is going to enter
a first name which we will trap as an
attribute so here that value is going to
get trapped we then return the profile
JSP when I go to the profile JSP we are
simply outputting that attribute first
name so so this is my page execution I
have just entered a first name I'm going
to click on the submit button and it
says welcome that particular user right
if I add another user it actually goes
and traps that user ID so again the flow
is that in the controller it's hitting
this particular request map it then
traps the F name stores that
value into an attribute called first
name and forwards it to the profile page
the profile. JSP is returned by the
controller and simply prints the first
name now we have another page here which
is register
training we are posting to an add trainy
method okay we are posting to an add
Training Method the command name is
training command and we have here if you
look at this we have actually included a
custom or rather a system Define tag
Library which is springf framework. org
tag so what we are using here is spring
forms rather than the system defined
HTML 5
forms and here we are saying s form
colon which is the prefix for this
particular name space that we have
imported on the top the action is at
trainy and we have a trainy name we have
a marks code we have a contact number
and a submit button okay and now uh we
are already going and setting part to
Comm controllers so in the com
controller we've created a register
controller here you see that we have a
request map for register and a request
map for ADD trainy and here you see the
trainy
command that is actually getting trapped
so the trainy information will
automatically be passed here and this is
the model map which acts as a scope
which allows us to pass data between the
controller and and the view so this
trainy object acts like the model data
so if you come to the com. two package
you actually see the traine class which
has traine name marks code and contact
number it has a parameterized
Constructor it has an overridden two
string default Constructor and getter
and Setter that's all the training class
actually
has the register controller as we saw
has two maps a register function that
returns register try.
JSP maps to the attribute trainy command
and a add trainy map that accepts the
trainy object along with the scope the
model map which passes data between the
controller and the view we are adding
attribute trainy and we return success
okay so if I go to the success. GSP we
are printing the trainy object if you
look at the register trainy here you see
the command name that we are trapping
and training name marks code contact
number which map to the fields that we
have in the model class or the end
entity class which is the trainy
itself so now if we actually look at
uh so let's close
this come back we don't add any
credentials we click on login and it
says invalid login credentials okay so
this is
the login that is getting called so you
see here it maps to the login and here
if we do not enter anything it simply
returns invalid login credential so this
is the login that's actually getting hit
when we click on that button and if you
look at the register training we
actually see the input type over here
equal to
submit and the moment we hit that
particular login URL it will simply
throw this message saying that you did
not enter the right
credentials so that is the login screen
for
us okay now if I actually add the right
credentials so if I add the correct
credentials here uh or let's say we
enter the incorrect credentials let's
say Amit and password and we say login
it continues to say invalid login
credentials right so in the home.jsp you
actually see the login so this is the
login block which is giving us that
action equal to login username password
and it is displaying dollar of error
message right so the moment I click on
this input button it looks for a JSP or
rather it looks for a controller which
has a request map so this JSP page looks
for a controller that has a request map
of
login so inside the my controller I have
a request map of login it will go here
it traps the username password checks if
it's not Tom and Jerry it goes to error
message if it is St and Jerry it
displays profile right and if I look at
error message error message is being
printed in the same page below so in the
home.jsp we actually are uh if you look
at the home.jsp page dollar of error
message is being printed and that's why
you get the invalid credentials out here
okay and if it is a success it will show
you the success page and
print uh that
information okay it will just display so
if you look at the my controller what we
doing is we are displaying the profile
page here so if I go to the profile page
it'll just display the first name okay
so let's try that so here if I say Tom
and Jerry it should just display the
first name successfully saying Tom so
when I log in it says welcome Tom okay
the URL continues to be
login now I when I click on this
register link what happens so let's look
at the home JSP again href equal to
register so when I click on the register
link I simply have a registration which
says click here to
register okay and I already have a
register trainy form created and this is
created using spring forms as we
discussed by creating you importing the
tag library for spring forms right so
that's the register trading now I have a
separate controller that is managing
that so here is the register so moment I
click on that link it will hit this
request map and it will bring up the
register train. JSP okay and remember we
had added the suffixes here in this
particular file so when I say register
trainy the JSP suffix will already be
automatically be added so we'll try that
we'll click on register and here you see
the register trainy spring form has come
up so we enter the traine name we enter
the marks
code and we enter the contact number
right now if you look at the register
training
form this is posting to add training so
if I go to the register controller here
is where I have my ad training it
accepts the training object as a
parameter maps to training command and
the scope which allows us to pass
information between the controller and
the model and here we are mapping the
training object and just returning
success. GSP and in success. GSP we are
simply printing the training object so
let's see when I click on submit
query so let's try the register
now so when we click on
register we'll enter a name for the
training we'll enter the marks code and
we'll enter some contact number and
we'll click on submit query and there
you see the trainy object actually
getting
displayed so in the success page we were
actually displaying the trainy object on
the register trainy as we discussed we
were connecting to the ad training
action in the register controller we had
the ad training action ction we were
passing the trainy object along with the
model map and adding the trainy
attribute to the map and finally
returning success and on the success
page we just went ahead and printed the
training object so you saw how the
string MVC pattern got the request to
the dispatcher seret it forwarded it to
the right model picked up the model data
and F and displayed successfully the
required
view which was the final view that that
actually got registered for us and that
is the success. JSP page that finally
got displayed so before we begin with
what exactly is a Java API we will
understand what Java
is so basically Java consists of two
major components that are Java runtime
environment and Java development kit so
when we get into to Java's API we might
want to dig a little deep into Java's
development
kit so jdk consists of three more major
components that are the Javas compiler
Java virtual machine and apis now we
will learn each one of them in a bit
more detailed way so at first we have
the Java's compiler so Java compiler can
be defined as a software program that is
designed to convert the high level that
is the user return or user readable code
into the computer readable code that is
the Machine level or bite code so this
particular bite code will be transferred
to the next state where we find the
jvm so what is jvm so jvm is an
abbreviation for Java's virtual machine
so Java's virtual machine is responsible
for processing all the bite codes and
providing an output to the user next we
find our topic for today's discussion
that is the Java API so just like Java's
virtual machine and compiler Java's apis
are the integral software packages that
come with the jdk the primary intention
of API is to establish Communications
between different applications so on my
screen you can see a pictorial
representation of java apis architecture
so at first we have the Javas program on
the topmost layer so this particular
segment will be having the user return
program and user language followed by
that we have the interpret pror Javas
API and the Javas virtual machine which
are responsible for reading and
compiling the Javas program so at the
last final level we have the application
Hardware which is responsible for
interacting to the Javas program so this
is how the Java APS architecture looks
like now followed by this let's dive
into the next topic so in the next topic
we find the types of developers using
various types of apis for different jobs
so at first we have the open Developers
next we have the internal developers and
at last we have the partner developers
don't worry we will understand each of
these developers in a bit more detail
and along with some examples for a
better
understanding so at first we have the
open developers so open developers are
used by topend companies so leading
companies provide access to their apis
as open source through authentication
via a unique secret key to keep track
and ensure the legal usage so basically
what happens here is there might be some
big companies like social media
companies or some more other companies
which provide the API they use for their
applications as open source to the
developers so these open developers get
access to their apis through getting
authentication so they'll be creating a
profile they'll be providing the
research details of their application
like what are they using that particular
API for and other reasons to use those
apis then they get the unique secret key
from the owner of that API and that's
done just to keep track that the API
provided is not misused so the open
developers majorly include the b2c teams
and some of the major companies that
provide the apis for open developers are
Twitter and Telex so one best example is
the Twitter where the Twitter provides
Twitter API for the Twitter developer
accounts for using that for any kind of
developing things or some data science
applications and and much more so
followed by the open developers next we
have the internal
developers so you can consider internal
developers as an organization so the
internal developers belong to a specific
organization and work in a closed
environment these apis run with a high
security that can establish
communication between the application
and the application Hardware so only the
internal developers that is the
developers belonging to that particular
organization have the access to that
particular API so this particular type
of apis run on a high security
level so internal developers majorly
include b2c teams B2B teams A2 a teams
and B2 e
teams so some of the major companies
that provide the internal apis are
Instagram Google mail and Google Cloud
virtual
machines next next we have the partner
apis so the partner developers are
similar or like internal developers but
the only difference is there is a
collaboration between two or multiple
companies for example consider yourself
to be linked with a different company
and you both wanted to create an
application so only you both can have
access to that particular API that
you're using to create your
application so partner developers
majorly use the b2c teams and the major
companies provide adding the partner
apis are Microsoft and finextra so with
this we finish the first topic that was
what is API and who exactly uses it and
for what purposes now we dive into the
next segment where we learn the need for
Java
apis so why exactly we need Java apis
now Java apis are used for multiple
reasons but the three most important
reasons for which we use Java apis are
to streamline the operations improvise
the businesses and finally create some
powerful applications we will discuss
each one of them in a bit more
detail so the first one is to streamline
operating procedures we have multiple
social media applications like Twitter
Facebook WhatsApp Etc followed by that
we have multiple delivery applications
such as Amazon flip cart then we have
the FNB such as zato SGI Etc so all
these applications are running smooth
and hassle-free because of the
significant Improvement in the
implementation of java API
by using Java's apis users are provided
with multiple options on the screen so
this kind of approach makes the
functionality very simple and easy to
use followed by this the next important
requirement is to improvise the business
introducing apis to the public leads
many companies to release private data
to generate new ideas fixing existing
bucks and receive new ways to improvise
operations the Twitter developer account
is an example for API that gives
programmers private API keys to access
Twitter data and develop
applications followed by that we have
the third one which is to create the
powerful applications online banking has
changed the industry forever and apis
offer the customers ability to manage
their finances digitally with complete
simplicity so this is made possible only
by the use of apis now followed by this
we will dive into the next topic where
we understand the types of java
apis
so basically there are four different
types of apis in
Java they are public private partner and
composite we will discuss each one of
these apis in a bit more detail at first
we will deal with the public
API so what are Public apis public means
open so public or open apis are Java's
apis that come with the jdk and they do
not have any strict restrictions about
how Developers use them so followed by
the public apis we have the private apis
so the private or internal apis are
developed for a specific organization
these particular apis will be accessible
through the authentication by only the
employees belonging to that particular
organization so followed by private apis
we have the partner apis so similar to
private apis even partner apis are
having some authentication process to
use so
the only difference is here instead of
one organization we might have two or
multiple organizations and the employees
belonging to that particular group of
organizations will be able to access the
apis and Implement them or use them
followed by partner apis we have the
last one which is the composite
API composite apis are microservices and
developers build them by combining
several service apis now that we have
covered the different types of apis let
us now discuss the categorization ation
of java apis based on the services that
different varieties of apis in Java
provide so data and API services are
another way to categorize Java apis
other than the previous type which is
the public private partner and composite
apis are also classified based on their
data manipulation capabilities and the
variety of services they offer so this
type of categorization has four
different types which are the internal
API Services external API Services CR
operations and user interface Services
we will understand each one of them in a
bit more detail at first we will
understand internal API Services
internal API services are developed to
offer organizations Services specific to
that particular
organizations these Services include
only complex data operations and
internal processes followed by internal
API we have the external API external
API are open source apis that developers
integrate into existing application or
website so internal apis are something
similar to private apis and externals
apis are something similar to public
apis next we have the CR operations so
CR apis provide data manipulation
operations over various data storage
units such as software and service that
is SAS and relational database
Management systems such as rdbms using
standard data storage unit connecting
tools like database connectivity that is
jdbc
Etc next we have the user interface
Services user interface service apis are
open source APS that allow developers to
build user interfaces for mobile devices
computers and electronics now let's
examine the rules and protocols that
Java apis must
follow so that brings us to API service
protocols the rules and protocols guide
the different functionalities of java
apis so different apis have different
service protocols let's consider an
example for restful API service protocol
as an example so for a typical restful
API developers must follow the following
rules for a typical restful API
developers must follow these rules
stateless uniform interface client
server cache layer no worries we will
discuss each one of these protocols in
detail first we will discuss stateless
so what exactly is
stateless
so since the restful API follows client
server architecture by default it is
recommended that restful API services to
be stateless all the time next we have
the uniform interface the entities in a
restful API are server and clients
applications that run on global scale
need uniform client and server interface
through hypertex transfer protocol or
HTTP and uniform resource identifiers
URI will allocate the required resources
next we have the client server
the client server model used in the
resell API should be fall tolerant both
the client and server are expected to
operate independently the changes made
at the client and should not affect the
server and vice
versa next we have the Kish including a
cach memory allows the application to
record intermediate responses and run
faster in real time a restful API also
includes the cach memory and next we
have the
layer a restful API is built using
layers layers of API are Loosely coupled
or independent from each other each
layer contributes a different level of
hierarchy and also supports
encapsulation next we will go through
some frequently used
apis so this is the list of most
frequently used apis in real time so we
have web API Facebook 4J Twitter 4J
Android API Java Advanced Imaging Java
data objects and you can also see the
acronyms for them in the right column so
some of them have no acronyms and some
of them have acronyms for example we
have Android API as Google Java Advanced
Imaging as ja data objects as jdo Etc so
moving into the next slide we have a few
more apis so we have restful apis Java
media Frameworks Java persistent apis
Java speech API Java 3D Java USB for
Windows Etc and similarly on the right
column we have their acronyms so for
Java media Frameworks we have jmf for S
apis we have nothing and Java 3D we have
j3d Java speech API as JS API and few
others so followed by this we will
advance into the next topic where we
will discuss about the advantages of
using Java's
apis Now using Javas apis will help you
with multiple advantages now we will
discuss the most important advantages of
using Javas
apis so the first one we have the
extensive SQL support apis in Java
enable a wide range of SQL Support
Services in users applications through a
component based
interface next we have applications apis
in Java provide effortless access to all
of an application's major software
components and easily deliver
Services next we have
efficiency Java's apis are highly
efficient because they enable rapid
application development also the data
that the application generates is always
available
online next we have the automation API
allows computers to automatically upload
a download update and delete data
automatically without human
interaction followed by that we have
integration Java apis can integrate to
any application and website and provide
a fluidic experience with Dynamic data
delivery followed by that we have scope
Java's apis make websites application
and information available to a wide
range of users and audience
followed by that we have
customization Java APS enable developers
and businesses to build applications
that personalize user interface and data
and finally we have the adaptability
Java API are highly flexible and
adaptable because they can easily accept
feature updates and change to Frameworks
and operating systems now let's talk
about what exactly is the junit tool all
about like what are the different things
we can Implement with the help of this
tool here so junit is basically a kind
of unit testing framework which is there
for the Java so it's kind of a default
offering for the Java programming
language that we can use the junit for
the unit testing framework for
performing the unit testing now the main
benefit of uh the junit is like it's
using the same syntax like a Java
programming language so it makes it very
easy for a Java developer to write and
execute the test cases so most of the
times when the developers are going to
work work on the Java programming
languages so they prefer that junit as
an default unit testing framework for
them because they get the language
Advantage they get the easily
Integrations in the eclipse so those
benefits helps the developers to decide
junit specifically for writing the test
cases and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code so uh all
the unit test cases will be executed
will be again executed there every when
you run a new belt so all the unit test
cases gets executed but you also need to
take care that if you are adding up a
new functionalities you also have to add
the corresponding test cases to that so
increasing more and more code will uh
will be done by the developers but at
the same time you have to sync or you
have to keep your test cases up to date
also and as a part of every build each
and every test cases will be re-executed
every time you're doing the build five
times six times a day every every time
the all unit test cases will be executed
over there and the response will be
given
back right now let's talk about what
exactly is a unit testing now unit
testing refers to the testing of the
small small modules or the small piece
of chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to have the early
identification of the defects and the
bugs because you cannot simply rely on
the de uh QA team to perform the testing
and then provide the feedback whereas on
the uh with the help of this unit
testing framework we can immediately get
the uh feedback right away once we are
running the test cases immediately we
will be able to know like these are the
different test cases which we have got
over here now the developers don't even
have to spend uh more time on fixing the
bugs and issues because these test cases
will help them with the easy and the
fast feedback so according to that they
can fix the bux and they can uh take the
decision whether the source code is
working fine as expected or there is any
kind of issues as such present with this
one so unit test casing is something
which is very important from the
developers perspective also because it
helps the developers to understand that
they whether they have written a
successful code or if there is any kind
of scope of issues or bugs over here
also it uh the successful unit test
cases uh increases the overall
confidence of the developers because it
uh increases the overall uh performance
and the quality of the product also so
by having the successful exec utions of
the unit test cases developers can
understand that yes the source code is
working fine as expected and there is no
scope of bugs or any issues as such with
this source code here so that's the main
benefit which we get with unit testing
that with this fast feedback Channel we
will be able to take uh the decisions
whether the source code is ready for the
production enironment deployment or not
so that's a main benefit which we get
with the unit testing here now of course
this can be done in two ways manual
testing and automated testing now in
case of manual testing you have to do
this thing manually within a manual
tester or a manual testing approach and
in this one you will not be depending on
any kind of automated tool which can be
scheduled or which can be executed in
non-interactive manner on the other hand
automatic test case is something which
uh is used to be executed using the tool
and uh it is something which is being
done so that you will be able to get the
complete automation there is no manual
efforts which is required as such you
are going to have like complete uh
deployment and automations being done as
such in this case so automated testing
is something in which we will be giving
more focus on the automated automation
tools you may be having one or couple of
tools which using which you can write
the automated test cases and you can
perform the complete Automation in case
of manual testing it's quite U you know
less reliable because you are dependent
on the uh particular uh tester which can
have perform the testing according to
his efforts and it's quite timec
consuming also because you can only run
the test cases for probably 8 to 9 hours
per a day whereas on the other hand the
automated test case is something which
is quite reliable because it does not
depends on a human so so requirement so
it can be done like 24 cross 7 so
anytime you can run those uh test cases
and that's the reason why these test
cases are quite faster as compared to
any other manual testing approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases really helps the developers
and the QA professionals to test the
source code much faster as compared to
the manual testing now let's talk about
the J unit installation now as part the
of the installation of J unit you don't
require to install any exe file or any
kind of program there there are a couple
of Jar files which is required which
needs to be there into the a class path
so that every time when you write some
junit test cases you should be able to
refer those jar files because without
having those jar files into your class
PA of your project you will not be able
to run the change unit test cases so
that's the only dependency you require
if you are running a Mayan build then
these dependencies will be added up into
the P XL file if you are referring or
doing the build from the eclipse or
doing the development from the acps then
you have to put up these jar files into
the uh class path of the project so that
these jar files can be loaded up and the
J unit can be referred over here so the
installation is pretty straightforward
but let's see like uh what are the
different steps we need to follow now as
a prequest of understanding the demo
about junit the first initial two things
is like you require a jdk to be
installed now you can download the jdk 8
over here from this Oracle website and
uh this is something which you can
download for the windows or whatever
platform you have you can pretty much
install it for whatever platform is
there so for Windows platform you can
download for 32bit and the 64 bit both
option over here and once it's installed
so you should be able to use the eclipse
latest tool now um all you need to do is
like you need to go to eclipse.org and
there you can download the latest
version of the eclipse now these two
main things which you require because
Eclipse will be required for creating
the change unit test cases and of course
how a kind of ID where you can run some
test cases CH test cases and all and
then Oracle is something which is
required as a runtime for running the
jdk also and the junit uh test cases
also and Eclipse here so that's a
prequal which we got over here at this
one so I have already got these two
things installed into my system and I
have Eclipse there so let's move on to
the eclipse and see that how it going
goes on there but before that you also
require the junit jar files because in
order to have a particular junit
framework loaded up we require some uh
particular files jar files over here in
this case so I can just search for junit
4 over here and when you search for
junit 4 so what happens like this
particular page
will help you or give you all the
details about the J unit 4 now you can
go for the uh version notes of the
different different versions but uh if
you want to download all you need to do
is like you can say like download and
install and the moment you go there so
it will give you the details now there
are two jar files which is required jun.
jar file is required over here J uh
hamist hyphone code. jar file these two
jar files are required here if you want
to download it into the test class path
if you feel that you want to uh use a m
based uh project then in that case you
have to specifically go for this
dependency in the pom file and according
to that that particular version will be
downloaded and will be referred over
there so these are the ways that how you
can get uh the particular softwares the
required uh things into the place so I'm
going to put up these jar files into a
location so that I should be able to get
uh the particular
details uh stored and I can refer to
them into my Eclipse so I'm going to
download this one here from the mavan
central so I'm going to download this
Char
file and then I'm going to go
back ham Crest hyphen core so that also
I want to
download download
jar so these two jar I have uh
downloaded and I will be referring these
ones into my project because these are
the ones which is being required into my
project as such so let's go back to the
eclipse and uh let's place this jar
files into a location so that into my
class PA I can refer the complete folder
with all these two Java files inside
that so let's go ahead with that so
let's create an particular new project
over here so we'll go for new Java
project and here I can give it like a
simple one
a simple project name I can provide here
and uh jdk I'm using like 1.8 so that's
the jdk version which I have utilized
over here and then finish so this is the
project which I have got like it's the
source directory now I'm going to create
a simple uh file over here a new class
file over here so I'll create it like
J unit class so I'm going to create a
class over here in this one and of
course I need to have a particular wi
meain also over here in this uh specific
class over here because this is the
initial class I'm trying to create over
here in this one I can create a custom
uh particular methods also over here but
uh let's see like if we can execute or
we can run some particular functions as
such over here now I'm going to declare
a function over here
public
wi
junit method
so I'm just going to create a method
over
here I'm just going to run a particular
print statement over
here
executing
junit test cases right now this is a
kind of a method which is there which of
course I can run into my uh public uh
void Main and uh this function will be
executed uh will be called upon over
here now the thing is that uh right now
uh since it's just a normal function but
the moment I convert it like I have a at
theate test mentioned over here so what
will happen like this will be converted
into the form of a test case
now of course like right now there is no
Imports which is available there as part
of this one so you can see that the uh
the the time I have added this
annotation at theate test I will be able
to see like yes add junit 4 library to
the build path is something which is
coming up over here or it's saying like
at junit 5 so whatever the library you
feel that you want to add you can do
that and that particular Library will be
added up over here now let's go for the
junit 4 Library here the moment I do
that what will happen you will see some
changes first you will see the changes
in the top saying that import oj. jun.
test that's a first import and second
import will be like junit 4 you will see
like these two jar files is
automatically being picked up by the
eclipse now even if you don't download
these jar files this is the main benefit
of the eclipse that these are already a
part of the plugins you can see their
parts that these are already installed
in PL plugins directory so the moment
you use these uh particular methods that
you want to use the junit these will be
automatically imported over here into
your system now you can just simply call
this method into the main uh void Main
and then the uh specific method will be
executed as a form of test cases so this
is the mechanism that how you will be
setting up the project initially you got
the Imports you got the uh particular
annotations configured and with that the
uh specific jar files will be
automatically being added up into your
class path whatever the jar files we
added up we downloaded previously we can
also have that added up into the custom
class path we can modify this uh build
path of junit 4 which is coming up
automatically we can just simply say
right
click build path and configure so this
JF unit 4 we can actually import we can
remove it from our system and we can add
our external jar files also into the uh
build path or the class path over here
so that depends upon you that how you
want to perform the customizations
around that part but yes the particular
main benefit of using the uh eclipse is
that it's already having the junit
plugin installed both four and five
version is installed whatever version
you feel that you want to include it
will be included and the plugins are
already installed so you don't even have
to download the CH files manually so
that's how you will be able to do a very
basic initial uh setup of junit and how
a basic project can be created over here
in case of J unit in the upcoming demos
we'll see like how we can execute these
uh particular test cases and we'll get
the response we'll come to that point so
let's go back to the main content right
so that was the uh Jun installation demo
which we saw and we saw like how we can
put up all load the jar files related
change unit into a class path and we can
resolve the uh basic uh you know
features about the change unit about the
test cases now let's talk about some of
the certain features of the J unit here
now there are a lot of features which we
can get primary with the junit let's
discuss about that one by one so the
very first feature about junit is that
it's an open source Network now it's
something which is available as an open
source to you uh we have also seen the
installation so you don't have to really
go for any kind of uh license or
something like that so you can do any
number of test cases with this
particular tool and this uh specific
automation tool here you can automate it
into Jenkins no way you require any kind
of license around this so um these can
be easily integrated these are already
part of most of the latest Eclipse
installation so you don't even have to
configure these manually because it's
already a part of your system right
second is that it provides annotations
now main annotation we have already seen
in the previous case that when we
converted a normal function or a normal
method into the test method by using an
annotation called at theate test so it
provides a mechanism to identify that
which particular method is a test method
and which method is a normal method
according to our classes so these
annotations really help us to identify
the methods also and it provides us the
flexibility that these uh particular
methods are not the normal methods you
need to execute you need to uh run it in
the form of test cases so that
identification is something we will be
able to do with the help of these
annotations here uh also it provides the
assertation uh to identify like what
exactly the results are there because uh
definitely when we are running the test
cases J Test cases we need to assert
that what should be the value so using
the assert uh you know we can
assertation we can actually compare that
okay this method is giving this value
Suppose there is an addition uh method
which is available there which is giving
like a + b is equal to C so C is like 5
+ 15 is 20 so with the help of assert
I'm saying like uh whatever the response
I'm going to get from the function when
I give the values A and B as 5 and 15 so
that should be 20 value so in the assert
I can hard code like okay this is the
value this is the response which I
should be getting and once the function
is executed I should be able to get this
particular output as in 20 over here so
that comparison when you do you will be
able to understand easily that yes when
we are doing the assert I'm getting the
proper response I'm getting the proper
output over here so assertation is
something which is very important to
compare the things to compare the inputs
which we are getting from the
application source
code next it pro provides the uh test
Runners so we can basically run the test
Runners over here to execute the test
cases so you can configure this within
the pipelines you can configure it with
eclipse and various automations during
the buil automations also you can
configure it so that flexibility you
will be able to get with these test
Runners here and it also uh allows you
provide a better feedback Channel
because it acts like a very good uh
feedback provider because the moment you
are done with the development you will
be able ble to get an instant feedback
so the overall quality of the code is
going to be increased in this case and
that's definitely helpful for you
because with this uh approach with this
J unit uh framework you will be able to
get a quite faster and a perfect uh code
writing tool or a Quality Tool which is
available there so definitely the
overall quality of the code is going to
improve with the help of this junit
framework and it provides the
automations also because these junit uh
test cases are having the flexibility
that you can configure it within the
pipelines you can automate it with the
help of this framework that you can
completely help or you can have a
complete automated workflow with the
help of this particular framework and it
provides you an instant feedback the
feedback channel is quite instant in
case of this
junit now let's talk about the junit
annotations we have already seen like
the benefit of The annotation is to
define or to provide the metadata about
the methods to the different ones so
annotations also refer to the
synthetical uh method data added to the
Java source code so having a particular
better of feasibility and uh
identification is also quite easy so
also the overall structure of the source
code can be done in a better way and the
readability is also good when we talk
about the annotations here the biggest
main difference between the uh junit and
the junit 3 was the in the introduction
of the junit annotations so uh earlier
before J unit 3 we were not able to
identify like if this is in kind of a
test method or this is a kind of a
source method over here so that
identifications is quite easy after the
involvement or the introduction of the
junit 4 framework over
here also like uh this is something
which is really helpful to us to see
like how exactly we can overall uh read
the overall source code because you have
so many so many source code there
present to your project so annotation
should be able to uh you know help you
to identify the that these are the main
portions with these are the components
which is part of the unit test cases not
the actual source code so add theate
test is something which is um U you know
going to tell us that uh the the
specific method with the public wide uh
declaration can be run or can be
executed as a test cases this is not a
simple method this is not an application
source code method this is a test method
over here now atate before is something
which is uh used to run some statement
before each and every test cases
executes maybe having some uh additional
or initial connectivity is something you
can do with the help of atate
before at theate after is something
which you can do after the execution of
the test cases like some statements
which you want to execute after the uh
test cases so that's something you can
do or you can go with the help of at
theate after and at theate ignores is
something which you can configure if you
feel like during the test execution you
feel to ignore some statements so that's
a way you can use the at theate ignores
there so at theate ignores atate after
atate before and at theate test these
are the four annotations which is being
used most of the time into your junit
test cases right let's talk about somewh
more now adate before is something which
is being used to execute the classes uh
some statement before even you know any
kind of test class executes so not only
uh you know before executing any method
this is something before even loading up
any kind of uh test classes or before at
the at theate before class is being
used similarly at theate after will be
there to execute it after all the test
classes and uh if we have a timeout
configured so what will have that we
will be able to set up a timeout while
executing the test cases so timeout
value can be configured over here and
then uh if you feel like if you want to
handle some exceptions during the test
execution so that's where we can use
this custom annotations over here to
have the uh exceptions handled or
configured over here in this one so
these are some of the very important uh
annotations which is available there on
the CH unit perspective now let's talk
about some uh another demo on junit
testing in the Java like how we can
pretty much configure the test cases in
J unit for a programming language called
Java and how we can get along or get
execute those things so now we are going
to see like how exactly we can you know
go for the
um execution of some Java files onto a
command line and how we can uh using the
command line run some execution of the
test cases typically we do it from the
eclipse but uh from the command line
also we are going to see like how
exactly uh you know we are performing
the setup and the executions over here
now what we really need to do is like we
need to see like how we can proceed
further with the execution so I'm going
to open this uh particular Java file
over here so to get a better
understanding here so I'm going to use
the uh oj. unit junit uh class over here
in this case so we are having a couple
of imports these are the standard
Imports so you can do like oj. unit uh
junit dostar also if you don't want to
go for the specific Imports here now
here we are going to create a test unit
as an sample class and in this one we
got the void main over here which is the
main portion of any kind of class here
the only thing which we got over here is
that we have created a test method over
here called test print uh message so we
are ass in a value called message uh
variable over here as an simply learn
now what happens like uh we will be able
to uh like you know do the assert equals
over here that if the value of message
is like simply learn so it will be able
to help us with the proper output and uh
there will be no uh errors as such over
here so everything will be smooth and
that's what we are trying to execute
over here in this case and uh we are
running into the null void that these
are the test cases we want to run or we
want to execute over here okay now all
we need to do is that we need to compile
this one we really need to compile thisa
uh test cases over here this file and
then we have to run that one so for that
let me open the command prompt so now in
this case we will be using the Java C
command prompt here and we will be
copying the junit into the uh class path
so that uh we will not be able to get
any kind of uh class not found issues
over here so test unit jun. Java we are
going to run so if there is no uh
exceptions as such we will be able to
get no errors here now I'm going to run
the uh particular class file with the
help of java command because Java say is
to convert the Java file to the class
file the compile format and then in
order to run the class file we have to
go for the Java Comm line here now this
means that uh there is no issues as such
with the test cases and everything is
working fine as expected over here in
this one so the assert equals is going
to help you to identify the that if the
execution is proper and let's say like
if we put up some content like some
different content over here in this
assert equals so I'm going to again
execute this one so that I will be able
to see like if you know what will happen
that if this message value and this
value does not match us like in normal
situations it will say like okay uh the
uh particular uh you know output is
going up and uh there is no errors as
such right so let's see like what
exactly uh it will happen that if we go
for the executions like if we save this
file in such a way that we are providing
some wrong inputs and what will happen
to our assert equal over here so I'm
going to again compile the file here so
again a new class file will be available
and uh this time I'm going to execute
this class file again over here in this
case and the moment you did it the
assert will give you the uh comparison
over here saying that there is a failure
of the comparison why there is a failure
of the comparison because according to
the the code base it was expecting the
value called simply learn but it simply
got the value called simply learn one
two which means that your test cases
over here got failed on so this is the
real uh way that how you will be
providing the comparison like what you
should be putting up to the application
and what kind of response you should be
getting in in in Return of that so
that's where you will be able to provide
a proper and a complete comparison here
which will help you to understand that
what exactly output you're going to get
over here and that's where the output
will be uh completely uh available to
you and you will be able to get a proper
output asset here right so this is the
way that how the comparison will be
performed and how you will be able to
see like these two comparison being done
here as such so this is the way that how
you're going to run the test cases in
the form of the uh from the command line
here so let's go back to the main
document right now the next one which we
got over here is the jit test cases
using the Eclipse because from the
command line we saw like using the
command line we can do but we got like
so many test cases which is available
there so it's not easy for us to run
those one by one so we will be doing it
through the eclipse so that we can see
like how the execution can be really
done and we can get a hold of those
particular components so let's go back
to the eclipse and this time we are
going to run the test cases in the
eclipse here now let's create a new
project again
here
J unit
project right and uh finish so a new J
Project a junit project will be created
now in this one you can see like there
is no uh executables libraries for J
unit but you can include it now also but
I'm going to do it later on so I go for
the J unit project class right so this
is a kind of a test class here so I'm
not going to put the null of the public
wi meain over here in this one so finish
now in this case what I'm going to do is
is like I'm going to you know replace
this content over here so uh with this
uh particular ones and uh going to have
some basic code base added up over here
so I'm going to import some uh
particular junit uh libraries over here
so over here like oj. junit I'm going to
import these ones and I got like this
class over here junit uh you know
project so I just have to rename it a
little bit so that it can be the name of
the actual class uh name here so the
that's fine so everything is fine but
the only thing is that we are getting
some failures and problems over here
because it's not able to identify these
uh specific uh junit related executables
like the functions and the methods for
this one again the previous like
previous case you have to do the uh
particular addition of the library to
the build path so that you will be able
to have like uh these automatically
resolved over here in this one right so
you can see now that day unit 4 started
reflecting over here in this this case
and you do not got any kind of Errors
now over here in this one so you can
simply save this and now you you are
good to go for running the executions
over here so you can simply say like
right click over here run s and junit
test and when you do that on the left
hand side you will be able to get a
little bit different Viewpoint over here
which says like yes testore junit is
something which is executed perfectly
fine if for any reason let's say like I
change the value of of string one here
as in string one just an typo error I'm
trying to do here so that I can show you
that how the test cases really fails so
assert equals is basically helping you
to find out that if the comparison
between the uh two attributes is correct
that means that uh you know the inputs
which we are putting up and whatever the
output we are getting it's both the same
here when you do that you will say like
there is an failure over here to the
test cases now I'm seeing the failure
Trace over here so I'll just move this
one to the console view so it says like
it should be like string but I got like
string one over here which is causing
the problem here because of the typo
eror which I did the whole execution of
the test cases got failed so I'm just
going to rever my changes back here and
again run the test
cases it will all be okay right now
again over here so that's the main
reason that how the execution really
happens and the overall mechanism and
the system can be implemented over here
in this case so that's how we basically
go on and we excute some junit test
cases here now in this one we are going
to talk about like how exactly we can
use both mockito and junit here to go
for the unit testing but before even
talking about these two tools here let's
focus on to understand like what is
exactly a unit testing here now there
are various kind of testing which is
actually available into our particular
industry and into our software testing
World there but yes there is a very
important scope and a position of the
unit testing here so unit testing is
something which uh we also call is an
kind of a component uh uh testing is
actually a software testing technique in
which single component of a software is
being tested we are not talking about
like how exactly our application is
going to interact with other
applications and it's going to interact
with uh it's not a complete full-fledged
application testing so in this case what
we are looking forward is like it this
is something in which we are focusing on
how exactly we can only validate and
test out a single component a single
component is what we are basically
talking about over here right and uh
when we say like how exactly uh we want
to perform we want to achieve the setup
here so this is the main uh mechanism or
this is the main kind of testing which
an individual developer performs at its
own end to see like whatever the piece
of source code he's writing whether it's
working fine as expected or not so so
this is where uh we are able to see like
uh the exactly what we are trying to
achieve here and how a full-fledge or a
basic testing validation can be done now
the main objective of this unit testing
is to pick a unit a very basic small
small unit of the source code to verify
it so that it will be uh the the moment
the developer develops the code base at
that moment of time only this thing will
be validated and will be fixed on so
this is something which we are looking
forward over here to achieve like how
the automation needs to be done and
needs to be achieved over here in this
case next thing is what exactly is the
mocking here now we talked about like J
unit here but next one is like what
exactly we are talking about as in a
particular mocking over here now when we
talk about mocking so we are basically
uh trying to understand like what
exactly uh we are performing for what
purpose we are going for the mocking
process here so mocking refers to the
development of objects which are mock or
clone of real objects they are not the
exact uh objects or we can say like
that's not the exact scenario which we
are going to implement but it's kind of
a duplicate or it's kind of a temporary
mocks which we are creating so that we
will be able to get it implemented so
mocking is something which is kind of a
reference or a kind of a clone of an
existing or a real object here so in
this technique what happen happens that
the mock objects are being used instead
of the actual real object so it's not
like we are directly or we are going to
access the exact real objects over here
so we are talking about like uh using or
going through the uh specific mock
objects over here in this one so that's
where we are putting up the main focus
right and mock objects actually give a
particular output uh for each and every
input whatever the inputs you Pro you
going to provide you are going to get
get an particular desired output so the
mocking is going to process all these
inputs give you the desired output and
to understand like how the uh
implementations and the setups can be
done right so for this kind of mocking
process mocking uh framework is
something which is quite popular so uh
moito is one of the framework which is
available there which uh is desired for
this kind of uh work or this kind of
approach only where we are trying to see
like how we are want we want to perform
a mocking implementation over here right
so let's talk about the marketer tool
because that's a primary tool which is
there for the mocking activity and we
have already focused on like marketing
is an process in which we are uh trying
to uh process uh the mock objects rather
than the real objects so that's kind of
uh verification here so mockito is a
kind of a Java based framework which is
being used for uh doing the unit testing
on the jav application so if you have
written the source code in Java
programming language then marketer is a
kind of a framework for you so this this
is something which is helpful for
validating the development of the um
kind of application source code here so
you will be able to validated that how
your application is going to behave and
it's going to work so when we talk about
mock uh marcket over here so it g
basically gives you a variety of
information like what exactly approach
you are looking forward and what is the
end result you are trying to establish
over here so that's the main focus of
the moito which we are going to get and
it's for the basic uh approach over here
so Java Reflection API is basically used
uh internally to generate the mock
objects that's a core component you can
say like the backbone of this whole uh
mocking approach over here mockito is
used to simplify the test development by
mocking the external dependencies and
using them in the source code so it's
kind of a uh blending in the whole
environment there so that your
application is going to get the desired
uh environment and uh being in that
environment it can start processing the
inputs and then give the desired output
accordingly so this is what we are
trying to uh you know Implement as such
over here to see like how exactly this
mocking can be done and moito can really
help us in this approach
here right now what are the different
prequests which we require to learn
moito so we basically need two important
prequest over here first of all we need
the hands-on experience in Java
programming language so Java programming
language is very important
because mokito is something which we can
write in the Java programming language
it uses the Java programming language
syntax so that's very important thing
there to be considered and second one is
the junit framework implementation so
these two things we basically require
for performing a complete full-fledged
mokito approach or mocking testing over
here so these are the two important uh
components or you can say like uh the
two core prequests which we need to
process before going for the mokito
implementation
right so let's go to see understand like
how mokito framework can be configured
in Eclipse because eclipse is the prime
tool for creating the uh development
source code for the CH programming
language so we need to see like how we
can configure the MoGo framework over
there because that's the one that's a
single ID which will be utilized by the
developers there so let's go ahead in
that in this demo we are going to talk
about like how we can create a simple uh
junit and mokito related uh program over
here so that we can have a basic project
created and we can also have some basic
program created on that part so let me
open the eclipse here now in this one
what I'm going to do is like first of
all I'm going to create a maven project
once my Maven project is created then
I'm going to include mockito and J unit
related dependencies and after that I'm
going to write a very small source code
uh just to see like uh how exactly our
dependencies are getting resolved and my
source code which will come up as an
error earlier will come up as an healthy
over there so all all I have to do is I
have to just right click over here new
and here I need to go for project like I
want to go for a particular Maven
project here so I can expand the maven
over here and go for Maven project here
it will basically ask me certain values
uh I want to use the default workspace
location so I'll just say next um then I
want to have it uh like I want to go
ahead with this uh overall process so
these all projects like what exactly uh
you know archetype you architecture type
you want to go so I can just go for the
default whatever is selected I can just
go with that and here I will be
providing like what is a group ID so I
can provide a group ID called com.
simplylearn or depending on your
organization you can actually provide it
so here I can provide mockito and uh the
version will be like this and uh this is
the same way like how the project will
also be created the package will be
created in case of the project here so
then I'll just say finish and uh on the
left hand side I will be able to see
like my uh uh specific source code which
is available there so this is something
which is uh going to come up over here
so it's actually trying to uh resolve
some of the uh particular uh options
like some of the uh uh you know like uh
the components test executions those are
required over here so I'll just uh go
for this particular resolution later on
right so I'll just open this pal. XML
file here and this is the pal XML file
right so it's basically looking forward
for certain changes like this jar file
so this jar file is not actually
available over here so uh once I ran the
build and uh you know those kind of
setup can be done then it will be able
to download uh those particular
dependencies so if you right click on
this one you will be able to see that uh
particular Maven build option here so I
can just run the maven build or I can
just run the maven clean
here so according to that the Mayan will
be uh downloading certain plugins and
it's just trying to do some uh
particular process over here so uh on
the left hand side the source main
test the same package which is available
there the same packages is coming up
there so app test is available there so
here the test is being available here I
can see like some couple of junit
related test cases is already being
there like I created a kind of a sample
project so in here a BAS Bas Java and a
basic uh class file or a test suit is
already being available here so all I
have to do is like I have to just try to
see like if I can go ahead with this uh
executions there now it's using like
junit uh 3.8.1 over here so I can
definitely go for a version which is uh
higher like around J unit four or five
there but let me try to do a clean build
over here Maven build over here so uh to
see like if it really works on there so
uh what are the goals I need to do I
need to go for the goals called clean
install so that's a goal which we need
to do here so uh mvn will automatically
be resolved there but clean install is a
goal which I want to look forward over
here so let's see like what it really
happens so it's going to download some
couple of plugins whatever the plugins
I'm trying to provide here some
dependent plugins will be downloading so
all that stuff will be downloaded this
is the first time we are running there
so that's why it may download some
little bit more uh jar files than
expected ones not you must have seen
like these are all jar files is not like
something we are using into our project
but these are kind of Jar files which is
being used by the plugins by the maven
itself so for that purpose it's actually
going to that particular level but once
these are cashed up there next time if
you do the run if you do any kind of B
there you are not going to see all these
entries so let me rerun the build here
to show you like how clean the output
would be there so I can just go for
clean install again and say
run and this time the output which will
be a little bit less there so in this
case as you can see if I expand the
output so here first of all it ran like
it performed the clean activity then it
compiled my source code here it also
compiled my test cases here in this one
then my test cases got executed over
here so you can see like it's something
which got exx uh ex executable over here
so this is the test which is available I
can click on that and I can see that and
uh after that uh it went on and prepared
the uh final artifact here which also
means like it performs both the
compilation and the test cases execution
and this is what we are doing in any
kind of moven project and on top of that
I'm using a junit related Frameworks so
this is a mechanism where we can have
some uh dependencies like I can go for
junit here I can increase the
dependencies I can try out the bill so
all that stuff I can do here right and
one more dependency which I can include
is of of the moito here so I can uh
include the mockito related dependency
also over here so that uh we can see
like how exactly the response is coming
up there so uh you can see like it's uh
you know uh when I go for the resolution
over here like clean
build clean install so I can just go
ahead with
this so This Time It's actually going
for the mokito one so you can see like
all the steps has been executed and we
have got the end result so the build is
successful and I have got the test cases
also so this is the test file where I'm
actually loading up some junit related
uh uh executables there so I can just go
with that and uh whatever the activity
assert uh we are using over here so uh
using which we can do the comparison so
this is a way like how a basic project
can be created in May one and on top of
that how we can manage the dependencies
for mokito and for CH unit here right so
that was a demo in which we talked about
like how exactly we can configure moito
into our Eclipse here now let's see like
when exactly we uh required the moito to
be implemented now in this case what
happens like uh when when exactly you
feel like you need to have a mokito
implementation or how we can go for the
mokito uh implementation all together
here so for example when a component is
to be uh tested or a single unit needs
to be tested so this unit or component
actually depends on some other component
which is uh kind of uh in in development
process or maybe some other developer
owns that component and you are not
exactly validating that component you
are validating your own component but
since it's actually dependent on other
uh component or some other uh uh unit of
the of the whole application so that's
the reason where you may not be going
you may not be able to perform the end
to endend testing but yes with the help
of mokito you you will be able to get
the mock objects so that you can perform
the uh testing there you don't have to
held up with that uh other component
dependency you can resolve all these
dependencies like that and uh you can
just proceed further with your
verification and your implementation so
this is the main benefit which you get
when you talk about the marketer so that
you can G see that a full-fledged
understanding like how exactly these
different components are going to be
processed here right and uh when there
is any kind of concern like uh if if uh
you know like if you feel like there are
some infrastructure components which is
making the testing impossible so in that
case also we can use the mocker to mock
some infrastructure components so that
we can proceed further with the
validation and the testing here so all
the hindrances and all the problems
which we normally face when we talk
about the implementation all those
things can be really implemented with
the help of mokito here so that's a main
benefit which you get over here in this
one now let's start talk about the next
concept so the next concept which we
have is what exactly is a stub very
important concept here so stub is a kind
of object which holds up a predefined
information a predefined data we cannot
do a kind of a dynamic uh verification
in case of unit testing because we have
to uh limit the scope of testing we are
putting up some inputs over here just to
see like how our application is going to
behave these predefined data will act
like a inputs and uh the test cases are
going to process these inputs and give
us the desired output so these outputs
we will be then analyzing to understand
that how our application is going to
behave or in other terms like how
application is reacting to these inputs
so that we can get an end to end desired
output as such here also it can be
referred to as an object that looks like
exactly a carbon copy of a real object
uh of course it's not a real object it's
a kind of uh mock object over here in
this one but it will give you the exact
different uh details or you can say like
the exact output as such over here in
this one so that's a main benefit which
we get with the stuff that it helps us
to get a mock object instead of the real
object so that we can get ahead with the
testing and we can get all our
environment for our test uh executions
here right and stubs actually um they
can actually return uh the specific uh
output here like whatever the output you
require so that will be returned over
here whatever the inputs you provide
that is going to be processed by this
one and the desired output will be
provided to you over here in this one
now these stubs are used to reduce the
complexities right so that occur while
uh creating the real object so that's
also the complexity which is going to be
reduced when we talked about the uh
these specific stubs as such here so
whenever we talk about the stops we talk
about the implementation so this is
where the complexities get reduced when
we talk about the uh replication or the
mocking of the real objects
CM right so let's talk about like how we
can uh see the stub in real action so
that we can get a better understanding
because from there we will be able to
know like what is a mean uh importance
of stub in the whole mocking approach
here so let's go ahead with that in this
demo we are going to talk about like how
we can create some pre request for
testing out a stab here so I'm going to
create a required M project and uh
couple of class files over here to make
a kind of environment so that we can
test it out the stub implementation in
mochito so first what I need to do is
like U I need to just go ahead with a
maven project so Maven project is what I
need to create a very basic project I
want to create over here uh we don't
have to do much of the changes like not
uh much things you need to talk about
over here so uh the package Direction I
can make it like um okay I just want the
uh particular package if uh if you don't
want to have the package and you would
want to directly store The Source Code
in Source meaning Java and you want to
put the class directly over there
without having any kind of uh particular
com and all that stuff so you can do
that also over here in this case so that
will be much faster so then you can just
go for the finish
here and uh you will be able to see like
a project created like a source main
Java then uh this particular package
name is there then Source uh test Java
is also there so here is the test file
here is the main file I I can go ahead
with this one I can create a file over
here U you can pretty much do that stuff
also so uh or you can change like this
existing one also so what I'm going to
do is like I'm going to create a new
class file here so I'm going to say like
okay create new class file and in this
one I'm going to put uh the uh
particular class name and a specific
content so uh let's see like how exactly
we can go so uh we can go for a
particular uh class Creations as a here
or we want to uh create so one class and
one interface we want to create so that
we will be creating over here so I'm
going to create a interface here right
so to to service so that's the interface
name which I'm trying to provide here
and uh in this one I'm just pasting the
content so this is already configured
here so just have to configure like
this right so uh then I'm just going to
resolve this one so
the java. u. list is also resolved so
this is the to-do service. Java which is
available there now what I have to do is
like I I I'm just trying to create it
over here and I'm just uh trying to
create another class file over here in
this one so which is like my to-do
business IML over here which will be
using this interface right so I'm going
to
create a particular class file in this
one and uh we are going to create it
okay great so in this one again I'm
going to paste this content so I have to
just
sync uh this one so this is what so I
have to just rename it a little bit of
this one so I have to
just rename as an particular this as a
tu here great so now uh I'm pretty much
done here so whatever the inputs are
required I can actually go it just this
Delta I want to remove it and uh here we
go so we are creating a particular to-do
Service uh mechanism over here in this
one so we are also talking
about the uh list here so these list I
can go for the auto resolution here so
I'm just going to save it and uh then
I'm going to see like for Todo here so
Todo is something which is coming up as
an particular uh service here so a
little bit changes in this uh interface
also so I can just you just have to sync
it on the names so uh whatever name you
are following you are using so that you
need to change over here in this case so
here also in Doo service I have got it
renamed so that's where it got
successfully resolved and uh as far as
the error list is confirmed so I can
just import that also so I'm just done
here so if you by chance change this uh
class name then you change the Java file
name also according there so that you
will be there in in proper uh sync up
over here so that's uh something uh
which is available there which we can
use to see like how the implementation
can be done and that's a basic output
which you're getting over here now this
is where we have got all the required
source code available there when we will
be testing out the tuub so at that time
we can actually use these one interface
and one class over here so this class is
basically going for the interface call
over here in this one and that's how
it's going on the implementation so
we'll come back during the testing
during the verification of this stuff at
that moment of time this will act as a
kind of a basis for us here so this is a
kind of basis structure that how you
create a basic uh program or a basic
source code over here in this one so
what I'm going to do is like I'm going
to just create these stabs over here in
this one to test it out to validate that
things there so last time we created the
Java Source codes there now the stabs we
will be creating over here in this one
then we are just trying to create first
one is for the to-do service so to do
service stop so that's the name which
I'm going to use and just finish it off
and uh I'm just going to put the content
over here so just in order to try out
the uh particular matching over here in
this one so uh to-do stub is what we are
trying to implement so that's what we
are going to see here so I'm just going
to remove uh this mechanism so I'm able
to see like all the Imports is working
fine um uh in this case we are just
trying to put some a dummy information
so you can see like this is the array
this is the array list content which we
are trying to provide over here in this
Stu so uh we are basically trying to
understand like how in the mocking
activity we are trying to mock some
particular inputs here so that my stubs
will be able to pick those up and they
will be able to return those there so
that's what we are trying to do here now
as far as this uh stub is uh configured
this is done so we have to go for
another stub here which will be there
for the to-do business IML so we have to
create uh this one for uh that
particular implementation so we have to
put the content over here in this one to
do to put the two uh do business IML
stop here right so I'm going to paste
the content here just to uh just to
match up the things so I have to uh just
put this content here so I have to just
rename this one because uh even if we
create some file sometimes we may have
to rename it so that keeping in mind I
can just put this one here and say okay
and uh I'm just going to remove this
component here and here we go so we have
got like uh these components like this
is something which is available there we
have got uh the implementations which we
are trying to do we have got to-do
service and Todo service Stu both here
but I can these are the kind of wrong
interfaces so idly my interfaces is com
dot simply learn. stub so that's where
we have got the uh particular to-do
service over there and uh similarly here
also we have got the uh particular ones
which is available so which is also
there in the uh specific com. simply
learn. stub. too service stub here so
this is a mechanism where we will be
able to find out even if I don't give
this import that's totally fine because
I'm already there in that package so I
can just refer it from there and we also
have the junit related ones which is
available there so we are getting the
errors for the junit uh components over
here in this case so we also have the
pal. XML file here in which my junit is
being utilized so uh you know in this
one we are basically trying to use some
references around the junit here so you
can get it on board on that case so I
can just try to run on the uh particular
Maven build here to see like if all the
dependencies are getting implemented so
that we will be able
to download some required dependencies
so clean install again I'm going to just
refer it over here I can just uh run the
uh specific test also like if I feel but
I'm just trying to download some couple
of uh components over here in this case
so if there is any kind of issues which
you're getting during the execution so
you will be able to see over here for
instance like oj. junit does not exist
over there right so um since these
packages are not downloaded or not
installed so that's why you're getting
the issue choose as such over here in
this
case right so these are the uh
references which is available there I
can just go ahead and uh import some of
the J unit related ones in this
case if I feel like I want to run it so
I can run this Java file also over here
this file also I can run it over here
right so those are different options
which is available which we can utilize
in this case so I'm just adding the
junit 4 Library so that my uh all
references related to junit should be
resolved here and the moment I picked up
that one you can see like all the errors
related to junit is gone now I can run
my build here to see like if it's
getting successful so uh this time okay
so uh it's it's going for that
particular mechanism so I can change
the
specific uh version as in 4.0 let's see
like uh it's getting resolved so it
should be able to download that
particular artifact so I just have to
find out that what is the version what
is the latest version we want to provide
and according to that the artifacts will
be there and it will be executed so uh
there are some cases when we are using
uh uh the default mechanism of creating
a j unit or a moven project in uh
Eclipse sometimes it actually uses an
older version so it was using 3.8.1
version which is old version so I'm
using 4.0 so this source code is
actually prepared according to 4.0 and
the moment I started using that the
moment I tried on that one there so you
can see like here it got executed like
both the test cases got executed over
here I have got the response over here
in this one like these two test cases is
being provided over here so test run is
two there is no failure all good and
then ultimately it went onto the J file
operation here so this is a way like how
this tub is actually going to uh
particular uh you know it's going to
call the particular specific classes but
yes in this case we are just trying to
input some values some uh static values
which is not the real objects but it's
kind of a mock of an a real objects and
that's how we are going to continue with
our test cases just to see like you know
some inputs if they are not there we can
still go for the testing and we can do
the verification here so this is a
mechanism like how we can test out stub
to go to see like to understand like how
the overall mocking is going to happen
here so that was the main uh
implementation on how the sub stub can
be implemented in the whole process to
see like how exactly we can go ahead
with that now the next uh demo which we
are going to talk about is like how we
can full-fledged implement the complete
moito code here so that the in in
implementation of the mocking of real
objects is what we can get over here in
this one so this will give us the
complete insight about this whole
process now first we will be creating a
specific uh we are taking up a stock
inventory kind of example over here so
we are going to create a Java file over
here which is named as stock. Java so
I'm just going to create a class file
here called
stock and uh in that case we will be
providing the content here so I'm going
to create a stock class which is having
certain methods certain functions stock
is the main function which is available
there um now we have to create a
particular uh interface which is going
to uh you which is going to be used to
get the stock there and uh then
ultimately at last we will be creating a
one test file which will be testing out
these thing the communication and see
like if the moito is getting passed or
the test case is getting passed or not
so this is the class file which is
available there get stock ID set stock
ID so basic getter and Setters are being
used used over here in this case so now
I have to create a particular interface
here
with the name called stock
service and in this
case I have to call
the kit price over there so kit price is
basically configured over here in this
one right so we are going to just call
upon on that to see like how exactly it
goes out there right so we will be
utilizing this one so this is the
interface which is calling up the class
called stock. Java now once the Stock
main class and stock service or stock
interface has been created now we have
to create a particular portfolio class
here this portfolio is a kind of uh
interface which is going to uh consume
this uh specific stock here so portfolio
uh class is what we are going to create
here so I'm just going to use it
and it's using some list operation so
I'm going to just import the java.util
also so that these can be imported so
these are some couple of uh activities
like a under this one we are also
calling up the uh stock service
interface so that that can be calling up
the stock internally and uh this is kind
of a business logic which is happening
so portfolio. Java is kind of a business
logic business layer where I'm just
trying to call the M uh the main class
here to fish the details through an
interface and in this one we are
basically doing the all uh processing in
like whatever the activities I'm trying
to do so here I'm doing the processing
about the data here right so this is
what we have uh from the sourcecore
perspective now we will be moving on to
the test cases perspective where we will
be writing a test file to uh do the
mocking over here and to get the stocks
and uh try to do some verification so
now I'm going to create a particular
portfolio tester here which will be
testing this specific uh portfolio here
so that's what we are going to do right
so uh it's going to use some of the
moito related uh jar files here and uh
since we already have those uh
dependencies like the we already got
those added up to our P XML file so and
these are also being shown up as an MAV
dependency here so both 4.0 and this
marit to dependency is there in the MAV
dependencies and that's why we are not
getting any errors for these Imports
here and uh we are getting some list
related errors so let me import those
also and uh we should be fine by now
here so as you can see like here we are
when we are doing the uh verification
right so using this portfolio tester we
are actually inducing some stats so here
you can see like we are doing some setup
we are calling that stock service over
here so that we will be able to call
upon or we will be able to get the
information and here we are actually
putting up some content so the whole
idea why we are putting up this content
just to uh have the implementation we
are just trying to replicate uh real
objects here uh these are not the actual
real uh configurations or real
information which we are getting from
the uh end users but these are the the
dummy informations or the dummy data
which we are trying to provide here and
depending on that we will be able to get
like how it's going on there so we are
basically trying to call a function
called tester. setup there tester. setup
is what we are trying to uh call upon
over here which will set up the initial
information and then we are calling the
the test market value so my test market
value will basically give me a a pass or
fail kind of uh result set here so that
depending on that I can decide that
whether it's successful or not and this
test market value only here we are
putting up some dummy informations and
again these dummy informations the test
cases will be executed so let's just run
it uh my build is already success so I
don't have to run it again there so what
I need to do is like I need to go for
this portfolio tester. Java here so that
I will be able to get the results and
here we go we are getting the pass
output over here in this
one right so this is what we are trying
to do just to see like how the
implementation should be done there I
can go for a negative scenario like
where I can just little bit modify uh
something over here in the output and uh
I'm just trying to change a little bit
of uh specific uh output so that's what
I'm trying to do here so um I can
definitely go and see like if this is
something going to uh processed properly
or is there any kind of problem which we
are getting over here uh I can also
remove this decimal value just to see
like if uh I'm I'm getting successful
over here or not so I'm just running the
test cases
again and here we go we got the response
as in Failure because um the expected
thing is not coming up like whatever we
are returning so that's where the
failure uh it's going the for the
failure I'm going to roll back my things
here and see like if it's again getting
success or not so yes here we go we got
the past success over here the past
status over here in this one so just
like that you can actually mock the
objects you can put some inputs and
according to that the responses will be
coming up there and you can go ahead
with that particular mechanism so this
is the way that how the things really
gets moved on when we talk about the uh
mockito and how we can mock the real
objects and we can uh test out our
application here so that's what we do
with the moito here so that was a
complete complete moito code or you can
see like the complete demo over here
like how the overall process really gets
implemented over here in this one right
now what are the different benefits of
mokito let's process that one by one
so the main benefits of moito is like
first of all we'll get started with the
very first one is like the no
handwriting so that's a very first
benefit which is coming up over here now
second one is the object
creation third one is the safe
refactoring then we have an exception
support uh benefit which we get over
here then we have got like The
annotation support which is available
there and then the order support so
these are some couple of benefits which
we got over here to completely
understand like how exactly the uh
particular mareto can be really achieved
over here in this one and software
developers need to stay up to date on
the latest advancements regarding the
tools Frameworks programming languages
and apps to achieve success Master the
latest coding tools strategies and
techniques through simply learn software
development process by enrolling in any
of these certification programs you will
gain expertise in skills like agile Java
devops HTML 5 CSS 3 AWS JavaScript es6
soap and rest and GSP with hands-on
experience in tools like angular mongod
DB you will catch die of top recruiters
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses you
can find the course Link in the
description box below and pin command
that is the top 10 Java project ideas so
the first project that we will deal
today is the Online Career management
system so this particular project motto
is to deal with the career management
system the system will be used for
day-to-day activities like buy written
booking delivery and non- delivery and
sell self pickup Etc it is not easy to
build this particular project all alone
as the technicality of the project is a
little complex for a single programmer I
would suggest you that you get a team
with you and also look out for some
Automation in the process by developing
the relevant software robotic process
automation is the new normal in today's
life the web enabled interface allows
the user to log in from anywhere in the
world and track their career and also
view the customer rating the system is
designed to integrate with financial
accounting to eliminate duplication of
data entry and is also scalable to grow
along with your company the system needs
to be built with userfriendly screens
rich in functionality and features and
finally the major part it should
maintain a high level of data Integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular Online Career Service as
discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product in information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executive we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and build reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software
requirements so the software used in
this particular project is the
programming language that is Java
database is the Microsoft Access and
some convenient RPA tools and finally
the IDE the ID for this can be anyone
which has a good support for Java the
most preferable one would be the eclipse
and then comes the intellig net beans
and many more now creating this kind of
a project will give you a valuable
experience based on building a
fully-fledged e-commerce website or an
application I mean this is how the
world's leading applications like Amazon
flip cart zato Etc are basically planned
and have reached Greater Heights today
this kind of project on your resume
could make a huge difference and who
knows tomorrow you might even get into
one of those companies and start working
on their projects or build a company of
your own followed by the Online Career
system we have the online voting system
now thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the ease to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets buying clothes and
household items to consult your doctor
for minor issues bill payments and many
more yet for quite a long time going to
polling booth and standing in a long
queue to cast a vote has been persistent
and it has been challenging for the
government to motivate common people to
participate in the election system and
cast their vote just because there is no
other way to do such thing as such an
online voting system but all the credit
can be achieved by software Engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their oat to their
respective candidate as their own choice
with an unmatchable
ease this can be done just by click on
their fingers this is an advanced Java
project developed to show online voting
functionality followed by the abstract
we will get into the technicality of
this particular project so the first
phase of this particular project has the
admin phase where the admin has the
right to manage the candidates manage
the voters and the profiles and
passwords and finally election results
followed by the Admin we have the voter
or the user of this particular
application the voter or the user gets
to register himself or herself into the
application followed by that he can use
the login and log out options and next
we have the profile and password
managements so followed by that we have
the option to choose the positions to
vote and finally to cast the vote now
this particular project is an advanced
level Java project developed to show
online voting functionality it showcases
the use of java servlets HTML and CSS
again coming into the ID the ID for this
can be anyone who has good support for
Java the most preferable one would be
eclipse and intellig followed by the
online voting system we will now
continue with the online Healthcare
Management named as the corporate
Medicare management this e Healthcare
Management System is a web-based project
developed in Java the main aim of this
particular project is to provide
effective management of data related to
staff and patients in hospitals or
clinics the features offered by this
particular project should be as follows
it should optimize bed occupation the
project should improve the use of
operation theaters awarding the
cancellation of operations to know how
much emergencies affect the
administration of the hospital
departments or Services which include
cancellation of
operations to optimize the allocation of
human and material resources to ws and
shifts to detect the influence of
certain diseases in the hospital
services and finally to find clusters of
patients the software requirement for
this particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end and Java
as the programming language and data
mining tool which is Waker and Oracle
for the database JavaScript for the
scripting language and finally cat as
our server the E Healthcare Management
System is a web- based application that
assess the management of Staff doctors
and patients in a easy comfortable and
effective way here the concept of data
mining plays a vital role to develop an
effective Healthcare Management System
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
Healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
Healthcare Management this system is
very reliable and flexible from all
aspects so new features and modules can
be easily integrated into the system in
the future followed by the E Healthcare
Management System we have a new normal
online banking not interesting and
arousing for a normal person but for a
hardcore programmer it is as exciting as
a roller coaster ride in an amusement
park because this is how the major
national and Multinational Banks
Implement their banking facilities in a
wide range so that their customers could
experience the ease of banking at their
fingertips one such type of project on
your resume could bring major highlight
to the recruiter especially if the
recruiter is from a banking or financial
based Company online banking system
project is a model internet banking site
this project should enable the customers
to perform basic Bank transactions by
sitting at a corner of their home or
office through a phone or laptop the
customers can access bank's website for
viewing their account details and
perform the transactions on account as
per the requirement Bank employees can
login and add customer and account
information to perform transactions with
internet banking with internet banking
the break and motor structure of the
Traditional Bank gets converted into a
click and portal mode thereby giving the
concept of virtual banking a real shape
thus today's banking is no longer
confined to branches ebanking facilities
banking transactions by customers around
the clock globally
the features you can offer through this
particular project are homepage for
online banking site creation of new
accounts login and log out manage
profiles and passwords view the balance
of the account deposit the amount into
the selected account VRA amount from the
selected account transfer the amount
from one account to another close the
account so the software requirements for
this particular project are Java
programming language and and JavaScript
for scripting language and Oracle for
database and Tom Cat for Server so
followed by the online banking project
we have the online examination Project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like CET gr cat Etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios many schools and
colleges have now turned towards the
online education system and are looking
forward to hosting online exams for
student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations this particular project has
two parts first is the admin part admin
has the right to add students create
onetime login add in questions receive
answers and finally to evaluate followed
by the first part we have the second
part which belongs to the students so
the students can log in update their
profile and password select answers for
the mcqs write answers to questions and
finally closing the session and log out
this particular project can be made a
grand success by making use of simple
Java servlets and Java programming
languages and server like Apache Tomcat
followed by the online examinations we
have the Smart City Smart City Java
project can be a webbased software
developed to store the details of a
particular City the main purpose of the
project is to help tourists and other
visitors to a city by providing
information about hotels Transportation
facilities air ticket booking shopping
details City News Etc the Smart City
Java project serves the visitors as a
guide of the city and hence the project
is called as city guide project in Java
using this project the details of the
city can be accessed from anywhere at
any time the implementation of the city
project promotes tourism and business
effectively hotels can be searched more
easily from anywhere with the help of
this online software students can look
out for academic institutes located in
the city you can view the complete map
of the city using this project followed
by the abstract we have the features of
this particular project the features
offered in this particular project are
login update profile and password search
for the options select an option like
booking a ticket or hotel or anything
like Transportation Etc and finally
selecting that particular option booking
that option and payment window finally
the confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below they are the Java
programming language fromat server
scripting languages like JavaScript Etc
and database as Oracle for interactive
data storage this could be escalated to
another level by following design drones
that can act like a cop act as a tourist
guide for the people touring the city a
drone that has capability to take
pictures videos of suspected activities
and Stor store it for future reference a
drone can intimidate a cop if any
suspected activities are detected there
can be many drones in the city with
different functionalities and finally
you are required to implement the
functionality of the Drone to the users
to interact with the Drone users could
be Travelers or cops or travel agents or
cab agents the code for all these
projects are provided in the description
box below followed by the Smart City we
have the buck tracking system
the backtracking system is a web-based
application developed by Java
programming language for software
companies the main aim of this project
is to manage the errors or bugs that
occur during the software development
phase and cycle after the implementation
of this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access below are the features
of this project and source code of this
project is linked in the description box
below coming into features the software
is applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution the system is
fully secured and authentication method
is adopted to manage security it stores
the older bug reports so that they can
easily be solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating The Works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are programming
language which is Java web based
applications such as jdbc jnd di
servlets JSP and article database or
access database as the database followed
by that the server deployment is Red Hat
jbos as Etc and the client side
scripting as the JavaScript and the ID
for this particular project would be
Eclipse with all the my Eclipse plugins
and and finally the user interface can
be designed using HTML and CSS so with
this we can move ahead into the next
project which is the facial
recognition the face recognition with
open CV is an open source computer
vision library that has tons of modules
like object detection face detection and
argumented reality the major features
that this particular project offers are
managing the use of faces facilitate
face ident identification easy login and
log out store face IDs identify suspects
with just images enhanced way to find
cyber criminals so followed by the
features now we should look into the
software requirements to build this
particular project so the programming
language we need for this particular
project is Java and followed by the
programming language we need the Apache
ant framework Ming ww 64 and finally the
cake framework so followed by the facial
recognition project we have the next
project which is the vehicle
recognition so Java is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence Machine
Vision and neural networks so the
feature offered by this particular
project are high level language for
numerical computation interactive
environment for iterative exploration
mathematical functions built-in Graphics
functions for integrating matlb and many
more so this particular project can be
fulfilled by using open CV and Java
programming language along with some
natural language processing algorithms
so followed by vehicle recognition
project we have our last project which
is the speech recognition system so
speech recognizer converts audio to text
Java x.s speech. recognition package
defines the recognizer interface to
build speech recognition plus a set of
supporting classes and interfaces so the
features or stages in this particular
project are to create a speech
recognizer allocate resources load and
enable grammar attach result listener
commit changes and finally provide the
process
results so this particular library is
readily available in Java and you can
code this project using the Java
programming language and an ID such as
eclipse at first we will start with the
beginner level interview questions so in
the beginner level interview questions
the first question we have is
what is
jit so the answer for this question
is jit is an abbrevation for Java in
time compiler it increases efficiency of
The Interpreter by compiling the bite
code in the
runtime jit or Justin Time compiler
compiles code to Machine level directly
for higher speeds of code
execution so basically just in time
compilation is a feature added to the
inter interpretor of java so this
involves conversion of the code directly
to Machine level during the compilation
stage this improvises the speed of
execution of a Java program now after
the first question the second question
in the docket is what is a class loader
now let's discuss the answer for this
particular question so basically class
loader is the first file to load when
you execute any Java program so the Java
class loader is the integrated part of
java virtual machine so the
functionality of class loader is to load
the class to the Java virtual machine
while it is demanded to execute a
class Java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders so the
third question in the docket is what are
the memory allocations available in Java
so the answer for this particular
question is Java provides multiple types
of memory allocations but the five major
types of memory allocations which are
most frequently used are class memory
Heap memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory so the
next question in the list
is will the program run if I write
static public void meain so basically we
write public static void main but in
case imagine if I write the program as
static public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is yes because Java does not
follow any specific rule for the order
of specifiers you place in your program
so when you execute the program with
such pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully so the next
question we have
is what is the default value stored in
local
variables so in C programming language
when you declare a local variable or a
global variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable I equal to zero
then you're storing a value in that
variable I that is zero if you just
declare it as in I then the value stored
inside that I variable will be a garbage
value so similarly when you declare some
kind of local variable in Java then what
will be the default value stored inside
it so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any Primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them so
followed by the fifth question we have
the sixth question so what would be the
output of the following code segment is
the sixth question so this might happen
sometimes so basically what happens is
your interviewer will throw a question
at you which has a code segment so all
you need to do is decode that code in
your mind and provide the output so this
would be the code that we will be
dealing
with so you can see our question has two
print of statements the first one has
100 + 100 plus a string which is simply
learn and in the second print of
statement we have a string that is
e-learning company plus 100 + 100 so
what we will be the output of these two
print of
statements so the answer for this
question is really
simple so we'll be having 200 simply
learn as the first output and e-learning
Company 1 1 0 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again so when you see the code segment
once again so the first prin of
statement has 100 + 100 plus simply
learn so J M here understands 100 as an
integer value and the plus symbol as an
addition operator here so followed by
the addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers 100 + 100 so
followed by that we have another plus
symbol here so followed by the plus
symbol we have a string value so here
the jvm considers the plus symbol as a
concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learn similarly in the second
printer statement the jvm encountered
with a string value so it considered the
plus symbol as a concatenating operator
similarly it happened with the second
plus symbol as well so that's the reason
we have add e-learning 1 1 0 as the
second
output now followed by the sixth
question we have the seventh
question what is an
association so the answer for this
question is an association can be
defined as a relationship that has no
ownership over the other so to
understand this definition we can
consider a simple
example consider a person associated
with multiple Banks so consider person X
who has got accounts in Bank a bank B
and Bank C and similarly a bank is
associated with person X that is a bank
a bank B and Bank C are associated with
the person X but no one has ownership
over the other a person X who is an
account holder with all the three banks
that is a b and c does not possess any
kind of ownership over the three Banks
similarly Banks a b and c who has the
customer which is the person X but the
banks do not possess any kind of
ownership over the customer so the
relationship between the person X and
the banks ABC can be considered as an
association now followed by the seventh
question we have the next question that
is the eighth
question Define copy Constructor and
Java so the answer for this question is
as
follows a copy Constructor in Java is a
Constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy Constructor in Java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
Constructor is the one which will help
you out in this
situation so followed by the eth
question we have the ninth question
what is a marker
interface so the answer for this
question
is an empty interface in Java is
referred as a marker interface
serializable and clonable are some of
the popular examples of marker
interface so basically a marker
interface is just another interface but
normally in interface we provide some
signatures so these signatures belong to
particular methods so in normal
interface we just have method signatures
but not the complete implementation or
at least we'll be having some variables
but in a marker interface we do not have
any kind of data manipulating method
signatures any data members nothing they
have special functionality unlike a
normal interface so followed by the
ninth question we have the 10th question
what is object
cloning I guess the word object clone is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
Java Java provides a built-in function
or method that is the Clone method to
clone an existing object offering the
same functionality that of the original
object so followed by the 10th question
we have our 11th question why is Java
not completely object object oriented so
this question might be a little
confusing but it's true Java is not
completely objectoriented but what's the
reason yes I'll explain you why Java is
not completely
objectoriented so the answer for this
question is Java is not considered as
100% object-oriented programming
language because of the data types it
uses it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are int float
double and few others so so this is the
only reason why Java is not considered
as completely 100% objectoriented
programming language so the next
question is Define rapper classes in
Java so the answer for this question is
in Java when you declare primitive data
types that is the int float double Etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types just as we discussed
before Java is not one 100%
objectoriented programming language just
because of the primitive data types it
uses so when you include such primitive
data types then rapper classes are the
ones which convert them into objects or
reference types for the ease of
compilation and execution of programs
without any issues so followed by this
question we have the next question
Define single T classes in Java so the
answer for this question is in Java when
you make the construct of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singlet ton classes so
followed by that we have our next
question that says Define package in
Java so if you use some of the popular
Ides that is the integrated development
Enterprises such as in TJ or Eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file
so basically you create a project first
and inside the project you will be
having your Source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
Java program so here the question is
Define package in Java so the answer for
this question is as
follows package is a collective bundle
of classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and jav files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your Java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of Jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your Java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirement and the class files are
bundled together and this helps out in
code reusability making sure that the
program files or the Java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good
practice so followed by this we have our
next
question can you implement pointers in
Java program so so if you remember C
programming language we had pointers
there so we use pointers to directly
access the
memory so similarly can you use pointers
in a Java program this is a little
tricky question for beginners but
basically it's really
simple now the answer for this question
is no because Java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implic l so Java's major Moto
was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
Implement pointers in Java
program so followed by that we have our
next
question differentiate between instance
and local variables so the answer for
this question is really simple instance
variables are declared inside a class
and the scope is limited to only a
specific object inside which an instance
variable is created so followed by the
instance variable we have the local
variable so the local variable can be
anywhere inside a method or a specific
block of code also the scope is limited
to the block of code where the variable
that is the local variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next question explain Java
string tool so the answer for this
question is a collection of strings in
Java's Heap memory is referred as Java's
string pool so for example you wanted to
create a new string consider your name
so your name might be some XY Z so if
you wanted to create XY Z string then
you provide that particular code to your
jvm so what does jvm do it will not
directly create that particular string
first it will search for the XY Z string
in your string pool if that is already
existing in your string pool then it
will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if XY Z is not
there then the jvm will create a new
string that is the XYZ string so
followed by this we have our next
question that is what is an exception so
the answer for this question is an
exception in Java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program so for
example just consider that you are going
to write a program for division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
zero or any other sort of input so if
this kind of input is is provided to
your program then your program might
crash so you can avoid this kind of
Crash by using exception handling so
basically you can use try and catch
blocks so you can embed your code inside
the try block and say to your program
that if any kind of wrong input such as
special symbol or zero is provided by
the evaluator then send a message saying
wrong input or divide by zero exception
so this kind of approach will provide an
output but this kind of approach will
avoid your program from crashing so this
is how exceptions are handled in real
time so followed by this we have our
next
question what is final keyword in
Java so the answer for this question is
the term final is a predefined word in
Java that is used while declaring values
to variables when a value is declared
using the finite keyword then that
particular value of that particular
variable will remain constant throughout
the execution of program so sometimes if
you include a normal variable and
provide an operation on that particular
variable then the value of that
particular variable will change after
the execution of program but when you
declare the same variable using final
keyword then no number of operations or
any kind of manipulations Applied onto
that variable will not change the value
of that particular variable so that's
the speciality of final keyword in Java
so followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is what happens when
the main method is not declared as
static so the answer for this question
is when the main method is not declared
a static then the program may be
compiled perfectly but ends up with a
serious ambigu and throws a runtime
error that says no such method error so
when you basically declare a main method
don't forget to specify the static
keyword so with this we finished the
beginner segment of questions followed
by the beginners segment we have the
next segment that is the intermediate
level segment so the first question in
the intermediate level is what is jdk
and mention the variance of
jdk so the answer for this question is
so jdk is basically an abbreviation for
Java development kit this is a combined
package of JRE that is the Java runtime
environment and developer tools used for
Designing Java applications and applets
Oracle has the following variants for
Java development kit so the first one is
the jdk standard edition which is
normally used by beginners and
intermediate developers next after the
the jdk standard edition we have the
Java development kit for Enterprise so
this particular Enterprise Edition is
used by professional Java developers for
developing Java based applications and
Frameworks now the last one is the Java
development kit micro Edition now
followed by 21st question we will dive
into the next question that says brief
access specifiers and types of access
specifiers in Java so the answer for
this question is as follows basically
access specifiers are predefined
keywords used to help a Java virtual
machine to understand the scope of a
particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in Java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is Public Access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package followed by that
we have the private access specifier so
unlike the public access specifier when
you provide the private access specifier
then the accessibility of that
particular private data member or the
data manipulating method will be
provided to specific classes and
specific objects only and finally we
have the protected access specifier so
the protected access specifier is a bit
more secure than the private access
specifier so the access for this
particular protected data member or
protected data manipulating method could
be a little more difficult to access
unless you are going to implement
everything which is present in that
particular package so basically if you
are trying to access the protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method of a different package then you
need to First import the package into
your existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier Works
practically so finally after the major
three access specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
Java virtual machine so in case if you
declare a variable or a data
manipulating method without using any
specific access specifier setup public
private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is can a
Constructor return a value so the answer
for this question is as follows yes a
Constructor can return a value it
basically Returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
Constructor return a value explicitly
but automatically it Returns the
instance of a
class so the next question is explain
this keyword in Java so in Java we do
have a keyword which is called as this
so what does the keyword this mean in
Java is the question so the answer for
this question is the term this is a
special key keyword designated as a
reference variable so the term this
keyword is used to refer to the current
class properties like data manipulating
method instance data member and
Constructors so followed by the 24th
question we have our next question that
says explain super keyword in Java so
the answer for this question is as
follows the term super is a special
keyword designated as a reference
reference variable so similar to this
keyword even super keyword acts as a
reference variable but the difference is
super keyword is used to refer to the
immediate parent class object so
followed by the 25th question we have
our next question that is explain method
overloading in Java so basically method
overloading and Method overriding Etc
are the concepts of polymorphism so now
let's have a correct answer here so the
process of creating multiple method
signatures using one method name is
called as method overloading so for
example consider that you wanted to
include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you'll be having two integer
types of parameters similarly you wanted
to perform another addition operation
with the same name add so here you will
provide the method name completely same
to the first method but inside the
parameters there is a difference you are
adding three parameters here so when you
pass the values to the add method then
which method to be overloaded that's the
confusion right so should I overload or
should I execute the first ad method or
the second ad method so this completely
depends on the number of parameters you
pass if if you are passing two
parameters then the first method will be
executed if you are passing three
parameters then the second method will
be executed so this is how the method
overloading happens in Java so the
process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly I've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's let's enter into the
next
question can we overload a static
method so as discussed before the values
of the variables or data manipulating
methods will not be changed when we have
used the keyword static in front of it
so the question is can we overload a
static method now let's discuss the
answer for
this the answer is no Java does not
support overloading of static method the
process would through an error reading
static method cannot be referenced so
followed by this we have our next
question so the next question is Define
late binding the answer for this
question is binding is a process of
unifying the method call with the
method's code segment late binding
happens when the method's code segment
is unknown till the method is called
during the runtime so followed by this
we have our next question Define dynamic
method
dispatch so the answer is the dynamic
method dispatch is a process where the
method call is executed during the
runtime the overridden method is called
through a reference variable of super
class so this process is called as
runtime
polymorphism now we have our next
question why is delete function faster
in link lless than an array so basically
link list and array are the Java
Collections or in other words it's also
considered as data structure so to
answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of Link list and
array so basically an array is a
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations so consider that your
memory location starts from 100 and your
array has 10 locations so it's a
complete reserved block of from 100 101
102 to
one9 so you have 10 memory blocks so in
case if you wanted to add a number or
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into link list you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
Heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the notes through
addresses so in case if you wanted to
eliminate a number then what you do is
just to manipulate the addresses so the
address of the consecutive node will be
changed so that's the only change what
you make so now this is the reason why
the delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in link
list compared to array so now let's have
a brief answer on this delete function
is faster in link list as the user needs
to make a final update to the point of
value so that the note can point to the
next successor in the list now followed
by this we have our next
question give a briefing on the life
cycle of a
thread so the life cycle of a thread
includes five stages which are as
mentioned below newly born state
runnable state that is it provides the
jvm with a feedback that I'm ready to
run now followed by that they run stage
where the thread is actually running
followed by that the block stage so
basically the thread will be blocked for
some reason for some intermediate output
or something if the thread is waiting
for an input from another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked State comes to existence and
finally the dead State once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm now followed by this
we have our next question that
says explain the the differences between
the operators provided here so the
operators might look similar but they
are different now let's understand about
these operators in a much better way
through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
perform the operation of right shifting
so when you provide a binary number or
binary value then the bit will be
shifted towards the right and the second
symbol or the second operator which is
having three greater than symbols is
used to shift out the zero fill bits so
this is the functionality of these two
operators now followed by that let's
have the 33rd question brief the life
cycle of an applet so the answer for
this question is the life cycle of an
uplet basically involves the following
stages the first stage is the
initialization stage next is the start
stage third is the stop stage fourth is
destroy and finally we have
paint now the next question is why are
generics used in
Java so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in Java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation generic methods and classes
help programmers to specify a single
method declaration a set of related
methods or with a single class
declaration a set of related types so
followed by this we have our next
question explain externalizable
interface so the answer for this
question is the externalizable interface
helps with the control over the process
of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates operates read
external and write external methods so
we have listened to a new term here
which is serialization so what exactly
is serialization serialization is a
process of sending your Java code or
Java project from one computer system to
a different computer system so basically
if you wanted to execute some kind of
java program from a different location
then you serialize this particular code
to a different location where you
actually want to execute and this
particular process of transferring your
code is called as
serialization now the next question is
explain demon thread so the answer for
this question is the demon thread can be
defined as a thread with least
responsibility the demon thread is
designed to run in a background during
the process of garbage collection in
Java the set demon method is used to
create the demon thread in Java
programming
language so we have our next question
now explain the term enumeration in
Java so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
Java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
Java now the next question is why is
Java considered as a dynamic programming
language so the answer for this question
is Java was designed to adapt to an
evolving environment Java program prrams
include large amount of runtime
information that is actually used to
resolve access to the objects in real
time so this is the reason why Java is
considered as dynamic programming
language now followed by this we have
our next question can you run a code
before executing the main method so the
answer for this question is yes we can
execute any code even before the main
method we will be using the static block
of code in the class when creating the
objects at load time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main
method now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called so the
answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the
finalized method just for
once now with this let's enter the
advanced segment of interview questions
based on
Java so the first question in the
advanced segment is can the keywords
this and super we used together so the
answer for this question
is no this and super keywords should be
used in the first statement in the class
Constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea so
you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
Constructor that is the first class
Constructor now this is how you can use
super keyword and this keyword together
in case if you want it to use so with
this let's continue with the next
question in the advanced level so the
next question says explain JSP page so
the answer for this question is JSP is
basically an abbrevation for Java serlet
page so the Java serlet page consists of
two types of text the first is the
static data and the second one is Java
serlet page
elements now the next question is
explain
jdbc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbrevation for Java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a Java
application next question is explain the
various directives of
JSP so the directives are instructions
processed by JSP engine after the JSP
page is compiled into a serlet
directives are used to set page level
instructions insert data from external
files and specify custom tag libraries
directives are defined between the
following symbols
so these are the symbols that I used to
specify the directives in a JSP page the
different types of directives are shown
us below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tag lab directive so
include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page the page directive is used
to define specific attributes in the JSP
page like error page and buffer the tag
lip directory is used used to declare a
custom tag Library which is used in the
JSP page followed by that we have the
next
question what are Observer and
observable
classes so the answer for this question
is objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that The Observers
that it has changed its State The
Observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of
this followed by that we have the next
question what is session Management in
Java so the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of offer random
conversation between the client and the
server the essential Communication
channel includes the string of responses
and request from both sides typically
the most popular way of implementing
session management is the employment of
a session ID in the communicative desk
SC of the client and the
server the next question is brief about
spring framework spring framework is
basically the framework of Frameworks
now the answer for this question is
spring is essentially defined as the
application framework and inversion of
control container for Java basically the
chief purpose of spring framework is to
create Enterprise applications in Java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any Java
application so the next question is
explain jca in Java so the answer for
this question is jca is basically an
abbrevation for Java cryptography
architecture so jca provides a platform
that gives architecture and apis for
encryption as well as decryption jca is
used by the developer to combine the
application with the security measure it
also helps in performing the third party
security rules it uses the hasht
encryption message digest Etc to
implement the security so the next
question is is explain jpa in Java so
the answer for this question is jpa
stands as an abbrevation for Java
persistence API the jpa is enabling us
to create the persistence layer for
desktop and web
applications jpa deals with the
following Java persistence API query
language Java persistence criteria API
object mapping metadata Etc so the last
question in our list is explain the
different authentications in Java seret
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form based authentication in this
particular type of authentication the
login form is made by the programmer by
using
HTML followed by that we have the third
type of authentication that is digest
authentication digest authentication is
similar to basic authentication but in
this the passwords are encrypted using
hash formula this makes digest more
secured and lastly we have the client
certificate authentication the client
certificate authentication requires that
each client accessing the resource
Source has a certificate that it sends
to authenticate itself this requires SSL
protocol and with that we have come to
the end of this Java fundamentals course
I hope you found it valuable and
entertaining please ask any questions
about the topics covered in this video
in the comment section below our experts
will assist you in addressing your
problems thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here